good morning everybody
um
education committee looks like we're
here all awake sort of
I know it was hard leaving here at 5 30
getting to bed around 12 15 getting up
at five ish to drive down it's it's a
very short sleep
so today on our hearing process here
we're starting out uh with HB 627 this
is relative to local education
Improvement plans and disparities in
education representative sure are the
prime sponsor of that bill
foreign
so welcome
good morning
oops good morning everyone
for the last few years
excuse me for the last few years we've
been saying or I've been saying I would
like to see accountability on all of
this money we keep giving more and more
money to
um
schools in general
and
there's no we don't know what it's being
used for we don't we you know we get the
assessment at the end but that's it and
I've been saying can't we put something
on there well last year
in the um
Foundation
whatever the book
education funding plan there was
accountability
and it was supposedly just for schools
that are what we would call failing
right but I said as far as I'm concerned
every school
could improve I mean when our average
State proficiency is less than 50 in
both reading and math and like 27 in
math as far as I'm concerned every
school
could use Improvement so I basically
lifted the words straight out of that
changed a few not much mostly to make it
a standalone and that's what I am
introducing
um
I wasn't sure where to put it
and I left it up to OLS but
rsa193h is actually a very appropriate
place to put it but they took the first
section
and repealed
uh four
and put it there and that's not really
what I wanted
but this bill I didn't even get it until
December 23rd and I thought I'm not
going to try and revamp it in that short
amount of time you know we were up on
the deadline then
I figured you guys would have more
things you might want to amend anyways I
just amend it once we had this and I got
everybody's feedback
but what I would like because I like the
wording that's there in four now and
that's for basically what we would what
we would call failing schools
um
and I like that what I would like to do
is put all of this after that section
because my intent is this for to be
every school not just those schools that
are
basically failing schools
I would like it to go for all of them
um
so the first part
says each public school I think I put
every public school but at any rate
um
shall have until July 1st 2024 so that
gives them a year from the time this
actually will be enacted to come up with
an improvement plan it was called a
turnaround named it an improvement
plan because some schools
everybody can improve not everybody
needs to turn around but everybody can
improve so I I called it an improvement
plan and it's basically to get every
school to look at
what are some issues what are some
things we found where we need
Improvement you know they can look at
their own
results that come back from the
Statewide assessments and say you know
we our math scores are really low or it
looks like kids you know are have
struggling with this or that part of it
or the same thing so
that's to encourage them to come up with
a plan
and
after talking with all of the rest of
the
the parents the teachers the community
the industries and see what they're
needing and what you know how the school
could improve to meet those needs for
employment
I just wanted to peek at a few things
you know steps to improve or expand
child welfare services and has
appropriate law enforcement
they may not need that but they may have
a few kids who could use that right and
so it's just making sure that the
families and the kids know what's
available it's not to say the school has
to do this or push this but make sure
they they understand and communicate
what's available for various parents
kids whatever
[Music]
um
let's see most of the things are pretty
clear
and even assessment it's not one
particular assessment it's multiple
measures of school performance and
school Success student attendance you
know all of that safety if you got kids
fighting in the Halls all the time or
being rude to the teachers or whatever
you need Improvement right you need to
be looking at what can we do can we
change this culture in the school
you know what can we do that's going to
help the culture and help
um
try to make a culture of learning and
support of each other
as opposed to fighting and and arguing
and
so that can be an area and that can make
a huge difference in how students do if
they're actually looking forward to it
or dreading it
parent and family engagement that's
something that I think has gone by the
wayside in in some school districts
that parents are no longer there and
involved and
according to um
scls
any of the social emotional any of the
studies with that basically it's been
determined that the number one
ingredient to being successful in any of
those areas are having the parents
intimately involved getting those ideas
into the parents and then ultimately
into the community and a culture of
working together of helping each other
of being nice you know that
take a breath deep breath before you
respond all of those things can be
helpful
but you need to get the parents you need
to get the community involved and so
there's a step of that parent and family
engagement building a culture of
academic success where ah you're just a
nerd and you know whatever and kids are
afraid if they do well to even let
anybody know to yay congratulations good
job and that's that's a culture and I
think a lot of that is dependent upon
the principle as I think our wonderful
illustrious chairman will agree the
principal does a lot to set the mood and
the tone of the school and
um
and then the second sect so they have
they will have a year to come up with an
improvement plan and then beyond that
every three years they're going to come
up with a new
with an ongoing plan
um
if they're going to evaluate it every
year and that's for okay we've put in
our Improvement plan we've worked it out
some and we're still seeing this
population or this population whatever
that is
is just not doing as well and and we
can't we we can't predict what a
particular school's what population is
is not going to be doing well you know
because every school is different every
population is different
so they will look and say well you know
this worked for these kids but it didn't
work for these kids so what can we do
how can we change it how are we going to
reach out for these kids
and so that plan is in some ways a
little more
detailed but at the same time they had
more time to get to that plan and in
that we're involving the um
Commissioner of Education the doe as
well
because we will have had time for them
to start to come out with okay what do
we see Statewide what do we see in
general populations that are are
not just not improving and
setting some goals
and um so that's
that's pretty much what that is
again
I'm not expecting that the schools are
necessarily going to
provide like it's a social services to
support students social emotional and
physical health that doesn't mean the
school has to hire somebody it means
that they need to know what's available
and what's in the community
and you know what what's there in
existence already that they can be
better utilizing
um
exp it says expanding Early Education
and pre-kindergarten program within the
district and consultation or in
partnership with community-based
organizations and that again doesn't
mean that the school has to agree for
writing or the town has free for writing
that's why it says
in partnership with and I'm thinking one
of those I was thinking of
um
English language learners
if you have as exist in some cities or
towns a church group that has decided
that they're going to be the welcoming
group for people coming in from this
country you know a particular place and
maybe bringing them in they may have
already set up an English language
learning you know teaching the adults
and during that time those adults have
kids so they may well have like a play
grouper or whatever where they can be
again working in English
reading the little stories with the
picture books in English to try to start
getting those kids ready and used to
English so it won't be so hard when they
get to school so it's not necessarily
something that the school has to fund or
do
but they need to see what's in existence
and make those connections and see what
they can do to encourage maybe they'll
send a teacher or so over there as a
volunteer on a Saturday to read and play
with the kids you know but getting them
used to English
um
diversifying the educator and
administrator Workforce diversifying
diversity comes in all kinds of flavors
and colors and it may just mean
that instead of all of your teachers
having come straight from the schools
you know went to school went to college
came and teached that instead some
percentage of our teachers are going to
be coming from the workforce are going
to have done the workforce and then
decided they wanted to teach and get
their certification and teach so you
have a diversity of experiences A
diversity of backgrounds
so that that there's a lot there to
offer
um
and at any rate I'm assuming that you
guys can read and read this but those
were just some things I wanted to
highlight so I'm ready for questions
thank you very much representative I I
do have one question for you
uh obviously that the the sectional law
within this chapter uh you're you're
dealing with 193h colon four well that's
where they put it but it is is directly
related to the preceding sections in
this chapter where we're talking about
comprehensive support and Improvement
plans for the lowest five percent we're
talking about the targeted support for
those that have significant difference
between subgroups uh and it's also part
of our waiver for the Federal grant we
call it Essa right and this portion here
and it part of that is also related in
193 H4 in terms of how we address the
Improvement plans for these these
programs which are required by federal
law right by changing uh what you have
here are you uh then also saying to the
department that we're going to have to
change the nature of our waiver for the
S no no
as I said I didn't know where this I
gave OLS the piece of what I wanted in
for all schools
and they put it here I didn't know where
to put it and I don't think that's where
it goes
but I don't know where it goes and so
that's part of what I want to do is
amend where it goes and so I'm looking
to wiser heads
to to figure out where this should
actually go if I want all schools to be
doing this not just the lowest five
percent where does this need to go and
so that's as I said I would like to make
an amendment when we're done with all of
this that correct fixes any of those
things and that's the first one I knew
right off the bat needed to be fixed I
don't know what to fix it to but I'm
hoping you will give me some good
suggestions well just enough up would
you think then that in order to do that
so we don't
run the risk uh of changing something
that's been approved uh federally right
now and we're talking
oh yeah I agree it we absolutely that is
not where this goes would it not be
right that it not be done just by this
committee but it also be done through
the Department of Education too
absolutely this language is originally
written I I believe that was Heather um
Gates and myself sat down and did this
and we just look at these guidelines
over here regulations and we looked at
this and saying this is what we need to
change to be in line alignment with
those right and I and that's why when
they said when this came out and it said
it was going to be repealed and I'm like
I don't want that repealed that's really
good it needs to stay so I have to
repeal it right and and that's fine and
that's why I said this needs to go
somewhere but where do we put it so
thank you yeah thank you further
questions representative
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question I mean this is a
massive uh change here that you're
proposing so could you just summarize
the intent
of the bill the intent of the bill
is for schools to be
um
to be accountable to all of the money
which we give them by coming up with a
plan of how they're going to use it how
they're going to use the extra like the
things that we give for
um the free and reduced lunch population
the things we give for the English
language learner population
Etc instead of just here's the money
have at it what's your plan how are you
going to use this how are you going to
improve how your school is doing because
I think we can all agree that schools
need to improve
from where they are for other questions
yes representative a hall
uh yes now I gotta go to the page thank
you for taking my question thank you Mr
chair uh you mentioned when you were
talking about diverse diversifying the
the workforce you mentioned experience
background I also see you have political
points of view
can you speak to that I can I think it's
important not to have all just one voice
I think having multiple voices and and
different points of view doesn't
necessarily mean Republicans and
Democrats it can mean Libertarians it
can mean green party it could mean
whatever but a diversity of points of
view
so that
um well hopefully certainly when I went
to school nobody knew where our teachers
stood on any of these things because
they'd lost their jobs if we did so
teachers weren't allowed to do that but
these days it seems that it's a
different environment and teachers are
free
to give their opinions
and it's so let kids have hear multiple
opinions that's all okay
let's go okay around with one question
piece right now representative Ellison
and then represent Belcher uh thank you
Mr chair I I I have about 25 questions I
doubt that the chair will allow me to
ask the wallet uh following up on on
representative Halls this is just this
is the tiny little follow-up but not my
real question but this goes back to the
political point of view if I'm a
principal and I'm a hiring you know two
English teachers
how do I determine what their political
point of view is and what kind of
questions do I ask them hopefully you
can't
and I will take that out of there as
long as we
I will change that wording as long as we
understand that what we're looking for
is a diversity of points of view okay
thank you my real question was a real
question
represent Hall is going to be all over
you in a minute this is a quick one this
is a quick one uh on on page three and
line three and then again on line 18 you
reference evidence-based
programs
uh line 18 seems to imply that the
commissioner that determines that but I
guess my question is who determines what
an evidence-based program is is that the
Commissioners at the superintendo
schools the school board is it the local
community who makes that determination
all of the above
oh
thank you I mean that's why you're
that's why you're going to all of these
people somebody can come in and say and
present I mean we evidence-based means
that they have there's been studies
there's evidence of improvement Etc but
not everybody knows what all of those
things are so you may have somebody from
the community say hey there's this
program and here's all the evidence and
it worked really well or you may have
the commissioner say where I'm aware of
these things the idea is you're reaching
out to all of these groups to get ideas
and not just staying in your own little
this is what we know if you're going to
improve you want to take in lots of
different ideas and choose amongst them
so you do some research if you're trying
to choose between A and B you know
but evidence-based there should be there
should be data
out there supporting those or how can
they be evidence-based thank you
represent Belcher
thank you Mr chair thank you replicas
for let rep lack us for this
um so I think the point of the bill is
is to create a mandate that schools
improve while also providing somewhat of
a free hand
um but I'm a little concerned about
where we're providing a free hand in
this looking at the bottom half of page
one there's
um
superintendent Improvement plan sorry a
line 16 going down talks about things
like the implementation of mental health
screening and care
in schools as well as improving welfare
services and law enforcement services in
schools so is the intent of the bill to
provide a free hand to schools in those
Arenas as well as the academic realm
well as I said
sometimes you have particular
students who need outside help and so
it's important that they know what that
help is and so part of that I expect
there to be some way for that to be
noticed communicated Etc not that the
school has to be doing it but the school
needs to be familiar with it so they can
hand off so to speak this child
you know to this person who can evaluate
to this person who can deal with them so
it's not no the school doing all of this
but as part of the Improvement they need
to know who those Community people are
how do we hand that off that's part of
the
um
was it ntssb part of the idea that
you have the general population and then
you have Stu some students who who what
we're doing generally isn't working for
them and so we have those
um connections
representative
so I'll make the statement that I try to
make about 20 or 30 times a session and
that is that public schools are over
regulated and underfunded and that's the
basic problem that we should be
addressing not all this other stuff but
I'd like to know
um
if this is based on model legislation
and if it applies since it's each public
school does it apply to Charter Schools
and if not why not thank you
so it is based on I don't know if you'd
say model legislation the bill that we
had last year to enact
um the
whatever that's
the booklet that we got
no it helped me out rep Miler is uh 709
it's yes the
the one that's sitting on some of your
tables right now the foundation
yeah we'll get into that in a little bit
here that's my next question for you I
was going to yeah
we had a law that we had a bill put
forward by the Democrats and I think
particularly uh rep luno and Rhett miler
that had almost word for word what I
have here I said I changed a few small
words there was one paragraph
I couldn't parse because it was a large
run-on dependent clause and I divided it
up into individual sentences best I
could meaning the same thing
and there were a few things that
referred to the plan that I had to take
out but almost word from word from that
bill from last year so that's what this
is based on it is almost entirely what
was in that bill that we had last year
and we were told and this bill has
accountability and I said woohoo I would
love to see some accountability and so I
figured if I used what was in there then
there would be less objection
okay
what oh and the charter schools
I was leaving I
I was leaving that up to
I think I had said every school and I
was kind of leaving that up to this
committee to decide whether we wanted to
do and Charter Schools or not I don't
have a problem with it Jefferson cascad
thank you Mr chair thank you um for my
questions for answering my questions I
want a couple clarifying points first
before I can ask and make sure it
applies my first comment is in hiring to
staff administrators are bound by Title
IX non-discrimination and certainly risk
managements there are questions you can
not ask I don't care if I like the
sweater or don't like the sweater right
you know what I mean it's we are very
guarded and we have specific areas that
we we can ask going back to page one
um the section that representative
Belcher had
mentioned
comparing it to the law in the book if
I'm in the right place and I'm not sure
so is this part four all new language
from the law because I I'm looking at
-h colon four as I said
this is not where I think this bill
belongs this is where OLS put it I got
they didn't even come out with it until
almost the end of December 23rd
I decided rather than trying to
do that in the few days that we had
around Christmas that would be something
we as a committee could decide I don't
think that's the right place and I do
not want to repeal and replace HB 193. I
think that would be the wrong thing to
do okay so my question actually pertains
to that if I may
um
so what this says is that a
superintendent might take great pride in
that good
um
is going to be responsible for
addressing Social Services Health needs
School nurses are optional Services by
the way according to statutes not
provided inadequate education
improve and expand child welfare
services
law enforcement in the community we
can't all afford sros
Workforce Development practices actually
the goals of some of these are part of
what schools do but I perceive this
language as saying now you got to take
on more and you've got to be the Hub and
you got to be able to tend to the whole
child
whether the parent does or not but
addressing specifically F on financial
plan
I I don't know how many school board
members you how many school board
meetings you've attended you may have
attended many
but for the three school boards that
I've worked at at least at a minimum if
not every other week at least once a
month
all the warrants and expenditures are
itemized x amount of books x amount of
jerseys with the prices the vendor and
those have to be approved by a school
board and those are public documents so
I'm not sure what other Financial
accountability you'd be looking for
that's not already in a required warrant
for public is there something else
you're looking for no the idea was these
are
these are places for the superintendent
well the whole Community because the
part above that says we're all going to
be in on this right and and addressing
the whole Community all the stakeholders
whatever the one who's fine is
responsible for finalizing the plan is
the superintendent after taking into
consideration the input
from everybody you know the teachers the
the parents the businesses Etc and these
are the steps
not that he not that the superintendent
is going to come up with entirely
themselves but with all of that their
job is to to put it together in a plan
and the steps to improve might just be
making sure that all the parents know
that these are the resources available
to them I mean it's not it's not saying
you have to that's why I was trying to
say you don't have to say the school has
to provide all of this but the steps
might be the school has to provide the
information you know we're going to make
sure that every parent knows that this
is available and that might be all of
the step that they decide to do or they
may decide more based on their you know
they it I can't say what it's going to
look like because it's completely school
to school and time thank you very much
um I have uh one last question to ask of
you here because I know we have a number
of other people probably would like to
speak on this as well but in near
opening statement you mentioned that
schools be accountable for State funds
um are you talking about the grants that
come out that are not part of base
adequacy and disparity differential and
differentiated Aid which are mandated by
the Londonderry and Claremont type
decisions and they're unrestricted
monies and or are you are you talking
about changing the whole format where
there to receive these you're going to
have to x y and z
I'm not saying what they have to be
spent for I'm only saying that they have
to come up with a plan and let us know
what their plan for using that money is
as opposed to just here's some money
have at it
we give them extra money for
um for instance English language
Learners that's one of the things we
give so what are they going to do to
improve what are they going to do with
this money to help English language
learners
we give them extra money if they have
um more free and reduced lunch so
because they have that part I don't want
to be argumentative here but we are
required by the court system
and the cases which we have to identify
ell free and reduce special education
and remedial reading Etc in
differentiated Aid and every child gets
the same amount proportionally to that
formula that we have established right
how can you then then say that turn
around and say that you're gonna in
order to receive those monies you're
going to do have to X Y and Z when we do
that possibly possibly for specific
grants which are outside of the
State's responsibility of adequacy
all I'm asking is that they have a plan
for what they're going to do with that
instead of just putting into to the
general fund
it's like if you're getting that extra
money it's not yes you have to spend it
for we're not telling them how to spend
it we're saying
we're asking them we're giving you this
extra money what are you going to spend
it on to help those populations
so we're asking them yes it's
unrestricted we can't tell them what to
do with it but we can ask them at least
to try to think about what are they
going to do with this money we're giving
them the money how are they going to
improve those populations after all
isn't that why they're getting extra for
English language learners
so that they can improve the outcomes of
English language Learners so do they
have a plan are they planning on using
it to improve it I mean that's the point
right thank you uh one one last one from
representative Woodcock then we're going
to have to get other people we're going
to be cruising in on the limit of time
we have for this Bill thank you chairman
um I have one question two questions the
first one is following on Mike's thing
and Corinne's uh on the second uh the
first page just specifically the time of
the Workforce Development on lines 24
and 25 it says the schools will provide
students and family with meaningful
employment skills and opportunities does
that mean we're going to be using
student funds to do uh development and
skill training for parents in the
schools
the schools are often owned by the town
and I have seen in our school system
where the school has arranged to have
speakers or whatever come in in the
evenings and give
um
employment skills that's not speakers
skills odd skills
that's what I was saying having people
come in on the weekends or the evenings
and use those school facilities okay
to come and teach particular skills and
there are ones that will do it for their
organizations that will do it for free
there are businesses that will do it for
free so it's not necessarily using other
than the school facilities
actually spending the money that was
meant for the students the follow-up is
the primary question goes back to the
funding under lines 35 and 6 on page two
into three where it talks about the
superintendent uh creating all these
plans specifically to individual schools
and then specifically for English
language Learners low-income students
special needs as you can see I I
Envision a superintendent put in hours
and hours and hours creating a plan of
all these programs that are going to
support and assist say low-income
students and yet not have the money to
do it so like false expectations these
are the things we need to make the
program grow but we don't have money for
it which which concerns me of going
through all all that work for
superintendent because the money is not
there I mean this plan that you're
talking about that that fine Democratic
plan to re do Educational Funding it
wasn't a democratic plan I think
representative Ladd was a critical piece
of Representative luno it had University
people want to have Financial ideas on
us but the point is that was
redistributing a formula of how Avery
provided right and none of it shows has
a superintendent allocating by building
by district and I'm just concerned that
without the the entire Bill the entire
funding mechanism that supports the
language of this it's like taking one
piece it doesn't fit the rest of the The
Design This Limitless concerns a
question out of all that representation
yes do you agree
[Laughter]
we keep redesigning the funding formula
I think every year we have some new way
of doing it or some bit so the question
is
you're getting this money this doesn't
always work well no okay what I agree is
there's x amount of money coming in how
are you going to use it that's the
question how are you going to how are
you going to use what you have thank you
thank you very much I thought we had
some pink cards here we don't even have
any more pink cards on this thing so we
have another four minutes or so I mean I
didn't expect coming in from out there
in the neighborhood
okay I didn't figure they cared
no any other questions
um yes representative
represent dry thank you Mr chairman
um there's no fiscal note attached to
this I'm assuming a lot of stuff already
exists on somewhere somebody's desk and
a lot of these
um points but do you what do you
anticipate for a fiscal note
I don't in well it's possible
that the doe may or may not I mean this
is partly their responsibility already
um May request
that they get something I'm not sure but
really what this is
how are you spending the money that
you're getting right not how are we
going to give you more money we keep
giving more money and we may still do
that that's separate from this
we give the money but how are we going
to use it that's really what this is
about how are you going to use it to
improve student outcomes
yes represent Damon
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question following up on
representative drive's question
seems to me that the collaboration
described in this bill among many
parties and the amount of reporting does
have an expense attached to it the
superintendent or whoever is creating
these plans isn't doing something else
so
I'm not sure how to make that into a
question I just don't understand how
this is free
um partly because I believe this is
already the superintendent's
responsibility and I know in our town
we do have all of the we do have isn't
it to decide how your school is going to
run and what plans you have and how you
want to improve it
I'm I'm happy to hear from the
superintendent if I'm wrong I I don't
ask the superintendent we had we have
several administrators I mean quite well
but two if she would like to respond to
that she doesn't have because the person
testifying can't ask a question of
somebody on the committee right
I'm not sure what your question is you
may have to reiterate it but my question
to you is would you consider an
amendment
that adds the hiring of an assistant to
provide support and manpower to be able
to accomplish even half of this in my
district there were no assistant any
things
you're it
and so in terms of the time frame
you need another person so are you
willing to put an amendment that adds a
staff person to the districts that don't
have them
well either that if we do that then we
would the state would have to pay for
that
um
I would be interested in hearing what
things in particular a superintendent
isn't already doing that is in here
that you would need somebody else to be
doing
well I'm just going to put something out
here I mean we can we can work this as a
work you know it's not an early bill
right we can
well that I'm going to respond to that
so the general public knows what is the
requirement when we put early on a bill
in terms of a financial note has to be
over five hundred thousand dollars I
think we're in that neighborhood plus
here with the question that representing
cascadden was just asking if it becomes
that we have the responsibility to
recognize that and shove this on as an
early bill
so it appears to me that without you
know having a more thorough
understanding of this we're not going to
be able to get this out by the 16th of
this month
I didn't expect to okay
represent cascadden
sure
um I have a doctorate in teaching and
learning
and that's what I do
as a superintendent
I'm not expecting
to reach out and raise a child because
it's a partnership with a parent and a
parent needs to raise the child the
school needs to teach and learn
that's my answer I agree and the
responsibility as I said of the
superintendent was to submit the plan
everybody was to work together to help
come up with the plan and I know we've
been doing that in our town with public
extra public not public hearings but
actually public joint Community getting
together and working we have
um and there'll be like an hour of
unrestricted where everybody just goes
around and
talks to every you know it's kind of
everybody's there and we all talk to
each other make suggestions and whatever
and then there's a time of more
controlled question and answer and then
they can take that so so and that's
you know I can see where I
I am not expecting one person the
superintendent to do this all by
themselves I'm expecting this to be a
community effort
the superintendent is just responsible
to make sure it happens and to submit
the plan
does that help
s okay
one more question to you here
representative uh Lucas yes do you
believe this bill is ready
do you believe if this bill is not ready
do you think this committee is going to
have this ready to get out of here by
March 16th
I do not believe this bill is ready
I would even be fine with retaining this
bill as long as we're actually working
on it to make it something that is
functional
thank you represent Damon do you have a
question
yes thank you Mr chair
so
correct me if I miss her but I believe
in your discussion responding to
representative cascadden you indicated
that the superintendents are already
doing this and that
essentially it seemed to me like you
were saying it wasn't an added workload
so if it's already happening I'm not
clear on why we need this spell
the what I was saying is that they are
responsible for overseeing the district
and
what happens within the district
and so that's
and their responsibility in this is to
get the community and input from
everybody to come up with an improvement
plan
which I don't believe they are doing but
I believe it is still their
responsibility now to get input from the
community
Etc to see so
it's like I believe they should be I do
not believe they all are
but I believe they should be getting
doing this already
this is to make sure that yes they are
they are pulling in
you know if I was superintendent and my
school was not doing well I would be
turning to everybody the community
having Community hearings Etc trying to
come up with how are we going to fix
this how are we going to improve this I
would think that was part of what
so
thank you not having any other questions
here from the committee and no think
cards
um I'm going to close this hearing
thank you
yeah
thank you thank you
I saw everyone's it was a rotary this
morning I don't think it's okay
it's Sergeant Bronson from Northwoods
he's our district fishing game
good to do that it's good um
okay
are those all 514
just looking for the prime sponsor
foreign
thank you
thank you very much we are now going to
go into a hearing on 514 HP 514 relative
to dissemination of of obscene material
by schools and institutions of Higher
Learning uh representative cordelli
welcome
thank you Mr chairman and honorable
colleagues uh for the record uh Glenn
cordelli uh representing tufton Borough
Wolfeboro and ospi in the beautiful
Lakes Region
and um
this bill
has been referred to in some places as
Banning books but that's not the intent
of this bill
as parents we do much to protect our
children from all sorts of things
provide a safe environment we have
parental controls on TV movies have
ratings
do all sorts of things including I
remember the days when I had my desktop
computer and we had that in a public
place so we could see what the kids were
doing on the internet and so forth but
technology has changed that and I'm not
sure if it's all for the better
but uh certainly we've talked about
um sending our children to
school to be in a safe welcoming
learning environment
um
and I'm submitting this bill because I
realized that
our state obscenity laws
exclude
education
from the laws
and
I don't think that that contributes to
having schools as a a welcoming
environment
um a safe environment for our children
so what this bill does in the first
section is
remove K-12 education
from those exemptions
it leaves higher education in their I'm
not touching that but for K-12 education
I do not think they should be exempt
from our obscenity laws
um that's the case in quite a number of
states and I believe there are some
states
um looking at doing similar things
but
um
I think it's a required step uh you know
some people will
um
probably uh behind me uh talk about some
of the materials they found
objectionable in in their schools
um but the second part of the bill lays
out a process for any parent who does
find objectionable materials whether it
be an app or a uh or a book or or
whatever materials
in the school
so that's the second part
um so that parents have some recourse if
they do find objectionable materials
um
and part of that process is going
through the superintendent and the local
school board and I think that's
important
if we look at the Island Trees versus
Pico decision
um
the plurality of Brennan Marshall and
Stevens said this
we are therefore in full agreement with
the petitioners that the local school
boards must be permitted to establish
and apply their curriculum in such a way
as to transmit Community Values
and there is a legitimate and
substantial Community interest in
promoting respect for authority and
Traditional Values to be social moral
and political
so we are adhering to that with this
process in providing the school board
with their decision-making process to
look at what someone might a parent
might come forward with objectionable
materials
um
they are again in the same decision
Justice Berger Powell rehnquist and
O'Connor said this
um the administration of the public
schools there is to be
uh
Traditional Values they be they social
moral political
if as we have held schools May
legitimately be used as vehicles for
income inculcating fundamental values
necessary to the maintenance of a
democratic political system School
authorities have broad discretion to
fulfill that obligation
so
the second part of the bill
laying out the process for parents I
think is in line with the Pico decision
and that it provides the school board
with decision making Pro process for
determining if the materials brought
forward to them by parents are a
legitimate and adhering to Community
Values
uh but I think the basic premise is
that um
obscenity laws
for New York or any other state should
not uh should not exclude K-12 education
thank you thank you very much other
questions for representative cordelli
represent Belcher
thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative cordelli for bringing
this forward
um I believe we're going to hear a
number of arguments today I think a lot
of them are going to hinge on the
concept of free speech
so what I would like to ask you is
in our constitutions where free speech
is protected
is the protection for free speech
applicable to Citizens or is it
applicable to government
where the Constitution here and over
here we're the Constitution protects
free speech is that a protection that is
granted for citizens to have free speech
or for government to have free speech
I I think the basic premise is that
individuals have free speech
um and uh
I think this is in line with that in
that
anyone can
come forward with an objection as a
parent but likewise the school board who
has ultimate decision-making Authority
as held in many law uh cases should have
responsibility for that and
students Librarians Etc are free to
exercise their opinion in discussing the
issue with the school board
just a quick follow-up
um so given that the Constitutional
protection on Free Speech applies to
Citizens not to government does this
burden the Free Speech rights of
citizens
does I'm sorry I'm not sure what does
what burden I guess what I'm trying to
ask is if Mr chair
um if
the the
um the the First Amendment to the US
Constitution even isn't even being
reflected properly here and and I you
know I'm not quite sure where we're
going okay so I think what we ought to
do is
ask the question don't ask a number of
questions leading up to what you're
trying to attain you see where I'm going
100 I'm just trying to get to the heart
of the issue of the matter of the
Constitutional perspective protection on
Free Speech and if it applies to protect
the free speech of citizens it applies
to protect the free speeches
no no I mean we need to be asking a
specific question to the person that's
testifying right now
understood then my question would be
does this place any burden on the Free
Speech rights of the citizens of this
state
I I do not believe it restricts Free
Speech rights
for the question represent cascadden
thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative for taking my question
um first of all there are quite a few
safeguards in a public school because
you have licensed people your criminal
records checks on staff and whatnot
and I'm not sure if you're aware but
School Board policy ige allows parental
objections
um policy ijk ijl are all specific to
that material so I really don't see the
need for this Bill thank you is there a
question oh question is are you familiar
with those
uh no I'm not familiar with all those
school policies but I think that this
needs to be in law because right now
K-12
schools are exempt from our obscenity
laws and I think that that needs to be
changed and I think that's the basic uh
thing that we're addressing here I'm not
as concerned with school policy I'm
concerned with state law just a very
very quick one so my question as a
follow-up is are you aware of what's
already being done
foreign
I am aware of lots of things going on in
various school districts in the state
represent McDonald
thank you Mr chair thank you
I'm looking specifically on page two
line 11 but there is multiple places
within this bill where it says the
school principal or his or her designee
would you see that some school districts
if the principal is overburdened with
other tasks that they need to
designate a permanent person or maybe
even create a new job position to be in
charge of handling these complaints with
obscene material I think provision for
the principal or destiny satisfies the
need
is from the committee represent woodcock
thank you chairman LED
um I may follow up Rosanna cordelli on
President McDonald's question
specifically to that line of the school
principal
um it appears to me that uh with this
person or designate is making the
determination because they shall
determine if it's objectionable right
that what a material and representative
McDonald's School whose principal as
compared to the school I'm principle of
how we determine what's objectable and
not maybe totally different we may have
the same item and be totally different
so I'm looking for how is there
something consistent in that uh in my
question thank you I think as we
um we mentioned in the Pico decision it
talked about Community Values and I
think that that's reflected
throughout statute so in your community
in the North Country Community Values
could differ from a community in
Southern New Hampshire
but that's a community decision that's a
local school board decision and
based on objections of parents if they
have any
is that one quick call
very quickly because I would like to get
out of here yeah thank you so it's CR
you're it's accurate to say then there's
something that might be maybe you've
seen in place though is not obscene in
Pittsburgh
that's a local school board decision
based on objection raised by a parent
thank you thank you Mr thank you further
questions from the committee yes
representative Balboni
um yes thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question
um online
uh 29 on the first page
um it says that the board shall adopt a
complaint resolution policy for its
local school system to be used to adjust
complaints submitted by parents or
permanent Guardians uh does this bill
only relate to complaints for parents or
Guardians
uh
yes
are you thinking of someone else or I'm
not sure
where you were going I don't know where
I was going with it is this policy just
relating to parents or guardians or for
the general Community as a whole that
would come into the school board or
object to any kind of Publications
objections raised by parents or
Guardians
thank you
representative miler thank you Mr chair
and thank you for taking my question Mr
cordelli I want to follow up with a
comment you made earlier regarding local
the Aegis of local issues around this
particular topic uh we're aware that
local school boards currently have these
kinds of complaint policies so is it
your concern that this needs to be a
state law because you don't feel that
local school boards are doing their job
as it relates to this policies relating
to these materials
I I think that I'm not sure what happens
in every school district in the state
but I think that there needs to be
consistency in place and that parents
have that ability to present
objectionable materials and to get a
resolution and decision from the local
board oh please yes so follow-up then
you're not sure exactly what is
happening at the local level then is
that correct
not not throughout the state
um you know we've we've seen newspaper
reports
um continually about
um situations arising and parent uh
objections
um and I I think that uh trying to
address that and provide a mechanism for
those parents to make sure that they
have a mechanism uh mechanism for
um bringing forward issues that they
believe uh are inappropriate for their
minor children
um and uh that might run afoul of our
obscenity laws thank you thank you are
there further questions just
representative Tanner does this have a
criminal penalty to it this law
uh I don't believe there is anything in
there
um
the agreed uh to to uh the to the
commissioner of Education to the
Department of Education does it does it
end up in a
I don't think that I don't think that
the commissioner has any ability to
launch Criminal
um
uh any kind of criminal action
thank you
well are we finished over there yes
represent Damon
on the last page of the criminal code
chapter 650 obscene matter Roman numeral
number three reads
state or any dependent May appeal from a
judgment such appeal shall not stay the
judgment and then any defendant engaging
in conduct prohibited by this chapter
subsequent to the notice of the Judgment
finding the material to be obscene
matter shall be subject to criminal
prosecution notwithstanding the appeal
from the judgment
so that sounds pretty serious to me
is there a question there
no we need we need to have questions
please
further questions if I could clarify I I
was answering the questions about the
commissioner's ability to uh take a
criminal action
thank you
yes representino
thank you Mr chair representative
cordelli one of the things that has
surprised me is how many people have
come forward showing me material that
they have been that has been distributed
to their children or that the children
have access to in school and I'm
surprised that they're reaching out to
me as a state representative to do
something about it I'm wondering if
you've had similar experiences that
would have led to you
thinking this legislation was necessary
uh yes I I think we've probably all
received uh correspondence from
constituents
um and seeing newspaper reports
um and one of the that plus uh an
article that I read in the National
publication about uh state obscenity
laws and education led me to filing this
legislation
thank you further questions not seeing
any from the committee thank you very
much representative cordelli I'd like to
welcome representative David page
all right
good morning
uh thank you Mr chairman and thank you
to the members of the committee for uh
considering my testimony today
uh I'm representative David page and I'm
lucky to represent my neighbors in the
town of Conway
I have also been fortunate over the last
many years to have worked very closely
side by side with Educators Librarians
and local boards all across the United
States as they've navigated our
country's escalating crisis for book
Banning
so
let me tell you what this crisis looks
like in two simple numbers
in 2021
the American Library Association
received reports of 1
597 different books different titles
either banned or unsuccessfully targeted
by bands
at the time this number
1597 different book titles was a record
preliminary data
from Ala for 2022
is that we saw 2
548 unique book titles targeted that is
roughly a sixty percent increase in
censorship activity in a single year in
one year
and I come here today to share the
perspective that I've gained through my
work over the last decade addressing
this problem
I oppose this book Banning Bill HB 514
start with what I hope are some clear
points of consensus
the first one I hope
we all share the belief
that every parent
has the right to determine what is
appropriate for his or her own child
to put it another way I do not believe
that it is my place to tell you
what your child should or should not be
allowed to read I will always defend
your right as a parent to make that
determination for your kid
and in return
I ask you the same courtesy
not to tell me what my child should or
should not be allowed to read
a second point of agreement
we all agree we all agree there needs to
be a mechanism for concerned parents to
raise complaints and request
reconsideration of materials in schools
fortunately and as representative
cascadden observed earlier this
mechanism already exists
this mechanism exists in the form of
locally determined District Challenge
and reconsideration policies is required
agreement I'd like to emphasize and it
seems silly to even have to say this
but we hear it so often in these debates
schools are not Distributing pornography
let's put it plainly we all agree we all
agree pornography has no place in our
schools every teacher every parent every
administrator every legislator agrees on
this
but let's be real with ourselves about
how miners today are accessing
pornographic materials because there are
problems
we know for example that the majority of
teens
have viewed pornography on their phones
a majority right and even more
alarmingly
a Common Sense Media survey showed that
45 percent of teens feel that online
pornography has given them helpful
information about sex all right
so there are real problems right if we
want to be serious about protecting
miners from obscene material let's begin
with an understanding of how our teens
are actually encountering these
materials
and that quite simply if they're seeking
out these materials they are not doing
it by going to their school library
Stacks they are not doing it through an
English language arts assignment okay
it's not happening not in this day and
age that's not where they're finding it
so this bill is not going to eliminate
our kids access to obscene materials
it absolutely will however
create a number of troubling problems
for both students and the Educators who
serve them
first and most egregiously this bill
takes the remarkable step of stripping
K-12 educators of their long-standing
protection under the law from being
arrested charged or indicted prior to
any Court determination that educational
materials that they've made available
are in fact obscene in nature okay
um you know and I heard representative
cordelli say they're exempt from the law
they're not exempt from the obscenity
law
it has to be proven that the material is
obscene right it's not like a free pass
here
so I'm not going to belabor this point
since I'm sure there are others
testifying who can speak to this better
than I can but the ramifications of this
change are momentous
and not only is the criminalization of
teachers in itself troubling
but the ways in which it will force
teachers to change their practice are
detrimental to Student Learning
second we know exactly what the
Practical effect of this legislation
will be on the ground we do not have to
do any guessing here
we'll probably see very few instances of
a court determining that educational
materials are obscene probably none and
why is that because Schools they're just
not using or collecting materials that
meet a legal definition of obscenity
in spite of this
the impact will be real and significant
administrators and their employees will
choose to operate within a safe harbor
they're going to deliberately make
choices to avoid potential controversy
and to avoid the risk of getting
embroiled in litigation
we have abundant scholarly research and
data on the topic of self-censorship in
schools the phenomenon is real it is
pervasive and it is well documented that
that self-censorship activity is getting
worse following the passage of laws such
as this one and so what does
distribution represent how much more do
you have you we're running out of time
here I've got about a minute thank you
yep
well we have the benefit of over three
decades of data collected on book
Banning by the American Library
Association and we can easily see broad
patterns emerge the first and most
obvious pattern is this
the majority a majority of those titles
targeted by book bands those 2 000 plus
titles
are by or about black people or buy or
about LGBT people
the direct effect of this law whether
it's the intention or not will be to
limit schools purchasing of materials
buying about those populations as they
work to build curriculum and collections
that reflect and serve their student
bodies
so here's the good news
public opinion research has consistently
shown that a majority of Republicans
oppose book Banning that a majority of
Democrats oppose book Banning and a
majority of Independents oppose book
Banning there's broad public awareness
of the crisis and in the most recent
major poll conducted in September of
last year by a nonpartisan public
opinion research firm
uh nearly all voters were aware of this
crisis
but of those polled the number that felt
that there was a significant number of
books in our schools that were cause for
concern it was only eight percent
eight percent
so I want to thank uh the committee for
your time and attention and I would ask
you to join me in stating clearly that
censorship is not a Granite State value
by voting in expedient to legislate on
HB 514 thank you representative are
there questions from the uh for the
representative representative
thank you Mr chair thank you
representative page
um can you explain to me what a book ban
actually looks like I mean if you remove
objectionable material from an
elementary school maybe it's available
at the middle school or is a book
Banning like
completely eliminating that piece of
literature from our culture never to be
seen again I'm confused about what that
ban actually means
it doesn't necessarily mean that it has
to be eliminated from from everywhere I
will also say that there are instances
where a mistake can be made and that is
why we have Challenge and
reconsideration procedures this is part
of the profession so yes something could
be purchased for an elementary school
collection for a K5 library with the
best intentions it is later determined
oh that is really not age appropriate
and it should not be in our Elementary
School library it would go through that
process that would not be considered a
ban a band would be an attempt to remove
something because an individual parent
feels as I said it's not appropriate for
their kid and that parent I believe
should be able to say and they can say
my child will not have that cannot have
that but we're not going to then remove
it uh from access for other children in
in the school or District if that makes
sense
representative Luna
thank you very much Mr chair thank you
very much representative page for
joining us this morning
um part of the um part of Public School
adequacy uh is defined as I believe it
includes a uh a live professional
librarian uh for uh for every 500
students that's part of our definition
of adequacy and uh how it's funded and
and I think we probably all realize that
you probably need to have more librarian
or media Specialists not not just one
for every 500 students but uh my my the
question to you though is
for uh for our do professional
Librarians just buy any book that's out
there and put it on or do they uh our
school librarians really curating a
collection of books that are appropriate
for the the education of the children
that that school serves
the latter
um so the the choices made by the school
and first of all I should say there may
be others who can testify better to this
but I'll take a first stab for you
um the selection decisions of the school
librarian are going to be going to be
determined by the school or districts
collection collection development policy
which is going to seek to meet the
educational goals of that institution so
they're not being random here oftentimes
it's going to vary a bit from school to
school district to District but
oftentimes there are requirements for
example that they are going to look at a
certain number of professional reviews
of the titles to determine their
appropriateness to determine the grade
range level so there's a lot that goes
into every single one of those those
selection decisions I would also note
that the school Librarian Is uniquely
qualified to do this work folks often
don't know but our school librarians are
often some of our most highly trained
Educators in the building they've often
been a classroom from teacher gone back
and gotten another degree or
certification
they receive very specific training on
this right it's a huge part of their
graduate curriculum and they spend a lot
of time talking about balancing the
needs of the whole Community about
protecting individual students rights
about representing the whole community
so this is very much Central to their
training so it's not you know the it's
not random that this is the person doing
the work
thank you very much uh yes
representative try thank you Mr chairman
um please help me out I'm looking at the
the preliminary hearings in the code of
the criminal code and it was talking
about
that no one is arrested or charged or
indicted unless the material is found to
be obscene and they continue to make it
available I'm having a hard time
reconciling that with what you were
talking about about being charged so my
reading of the bill and I mean you could
certainly talk to the sponsor about this
as well
but my reading of the bill is that it
has struck him out
schools and replaced it with
institutions of higher education
so that it has removed that
that language as it regards our K-12
institutions does that clarify them yeah
follow-up
well I I would like to see that I would
like to see that so whoever could answer
that question would be helpful thank you
further questions from the committee
representative Woodcock thank you
chairman for the page good to see you
again good to see you long ride down I'm
sure
um
my question is earlier on there was a
question I asked to the fire
representative if a book is pulled by a
consider obscene and plaster
and not considered of seeing a
Pittsburgh how is it then of seeing
material
so I think there's a couple there's a
couple things I'd emphasize first one is
a determination that it's obscene is not
necessarily the only consideration in
determining whether it belongs in in the
collection so for example to
representative pedernal's point
during reconsideration process
it may be you know when when that Review
Committee typically it's done is by a
committee that has parent
Representatives teacher or librarian Etc
will do the reconsider the review of the
material they will also read the whole
book as a committee they will look at it
it can be removed for another reason
that it then that it is obscene then it
meets the legal definition of obscenity
right so it may be removed just because
they say yeah this is not right for our
K-5 students we're not saying it's
obscene but it's not meeting our needs
it's not conforming to our collection
development plan so it doesn't have to
just you know that's not the only reason
to remove something so I just state that
first
I think
one of the challenges with this bill is
and I think you made this observation is
who is making the determination of
obscenity
I personally think that that
determination should really be made by a
lawyer
um you know the the you put typically
you put things through various tests to
determine whether the material is
obscene one of those tests for example
is that it's devoid of educational
artistic Etc Merit
um so
I think a lot of these materials it
would be hard to make a legal case that
that they are obscene what this bill
will do and I think this is to your
point is if it's the principle making
the determination in two different towns
they may reach two totally different
conclusions
the page further questions from the
committee not seeing any thank you very
much thank you I've looked through all
the pink carts here and and most pink
cards are saying I need three minutes to
present so I'm going to put the three
minute rule in effect right now going
forward so the next person I'd like to
come for is Barrett Christina
thank you
foreign
good morning chairman lag good morning
members of the committee bear Christina
from the School Board Association thank
you for taking my testimony nhsba's
posed to House Bill 514
um a couple different aspects that I
want to
um uh talk about on hsba's objection
um Provisions at the bottom of page one
where it says the school board shall
have a policy
um nhsva has no objection to the
legislature requiring school boards to
adopt a policy on this topic we do have
an objection though to the remainder of
the legislation on page two that talks
about what has to be in the policy when
representative cordelli was giving his
init was introducing the bill he spoke
of a Supreme Court case and I believe he
said the court said the local school
board should establish a policy to
adhere to the morality and values of
their Community by the legislature
writing the policy for us it's not local
school boards
um writing policies relative to the
values of their specific community world
after policy we heard testimony that
many school boards already have policies
on these nhsba does have a sample policy
I pulled off some
Haverhill has a policy Dairy has a
policy Hudson has a policy
uh
uh Wakefield has a policy playing field
Salem Timberlane Concord has a very
comprehensive policy why I didn't go
through everybody on the committee but I
think you get my point the other aspect
that I want to make to
um is that
um there should not be an appeal to the
uh to the local or excuse me to the
State Board of Education putting that in
the hands of unelected bureaucrats
doesn't seem prudent also if we're going
to be looking at the definition I'm
sorry some language in RSA 650 the the
obscenity statute
um trying to find out where it is this
is RSA 650 colon one
paragraph 4A the material is obscene if
it is considered on the whole to the
average person a when applying the
Contemporary standards of the county
within which the obscene offense was
committed so if the State Board is going
to be um being the final Arbiter of what
is obscene or what is not in a local
community we should add language to the
bill that the State Board is going to
establish criteria for all the 10
counties in New Hampshire and they
should post that publicly on the website
distribute that to all the parents
um in each of those specific counties so
I don't know if the criteria will be the
same in Hillsborough County it is in
co-host but the State Board should at
least be doing that they're going to be
given authority over what is obscene and
what is not so that's another objection
nhsba would have
um
uh we have policies I spoke about that
the other aspects too I believe somebody
mentioned at RSA 186 colon 11 paragraph
9C is the opt out provision and I
believe I have that in front of me
um
school boards are required to adopt a
policy allowing an exception to specific
course material based on a parent or
legal Guardians that happened yesterday
when I was testifying too oh is that is
that the three minutes I apologize
um or legal Gardens determination
rc1 18611 C you have to have a policy
that allows parents to opt out if they
find the course material objectionable
anyway I could go on for a long time
about this I know you got a lot of cards
chairman lad three minutes uh we opposed
written testimony I scribble my notes
down and very good very well I've done
this before chairman Ladd I've heard it
before
okay are there any questions from the
committee for fair Christina
from the School Board Association
yes representative luno sure thank you
very much Mr chair
um I I I actually I'm asking the
question because I wanted to give you a
little more time to answer particularly
with some details behind the the opt-out
policies that that families have right
now sure that are in New Hampshire
statute not not not uh subject to school
boards yet they are currently the the
the reconsideration of instructional
materials or reconsideration of Library
materials policy that nhsba has on the
books is not required by law it's
recommend nhsba has it as a recommended
policy and different school boards have
different
um sort of levels of who's going to be
on a committee to review it I mean but
they're all generally the same but again
not every I don't know every school
board or whether or not they have this
but we have it on the books
um it's a recommended policy from nhsba
if you want to mandate a policy that's
fine we don't think the legislature
should be writing local school board
policies though up I'm really asking
about state law that that gives parents
um rights to opt out of what what you
know what as as representative page was
saying yeah one parent might find
objectionable another parent might might
find appropriate that type of thing yeah
so what's I'm not sorry about that
what's the question
do we have state laws yes yes well yeah
this is RSA 186 colon 11 paragraph 9C
school boards are required to adopt a
policy allowing an exception to specific
course material based on a parent or
legal guardian's determination that the
material is objectionable and then it
lists a couple other Provisions about
what you have to do in the policy so
that's a required policy by law and hsba
has that every school board should have
that on the books and follow up on that
and that gives parents unilateral rights
correct to that material correct correct
thank you for the question that policy
has been placed for quite a while I
think 2011 or so I think that I believe
that's when we put it in yeah
further questions of the school boards
Association Nazi thank you very much
very much I'd like call forward and
Marie Banfield
um can I go a little bit later because I
think you think you receive these
materials before I speak on my behalf so
I would like maybe one of the parents
well I'll just take the next one in the
Heap here I've just work my way down
okay uh next one down is Betsy
Harrington
thank you
I really really appreciate you guys
having me today this is
this is something that came up last year
and it's been shocking to me ever since
and I really appreciate you having me
my name is Betsy Harrington I'm from
Deering New Hampshire I'm hoping you
will give me the whole time today to
tell my story because I feel like I'm
the most informed parent in the room
although maybe not it seems like some
others see what I have seen I'm praying
that you will ask a ton of questions
about how our kids are getting exposed
and exploited I have sent a video to
every one of you that's about a minute
long and I also sent some links like to
ratedbooks.org ratedbooks.org you can go
and look and
um
see the excerpts that parents are
complaining about so if somebody were to
say this book is bad and you didn't have
time to read the whole book you could go
to that spot and say oh I see what you
mean just to know that if you challenge
a book you have to read the whole book
but there are resources for us to look
and see what other parents are saying
and I appreciate that so I wanted to
make sure you guys got that email
I'm a long time therapist and I'm a
former prison sex offender counselor I
was once the unit manager of the North
End house and the transitional work
center at the prison
I received my master's degree from UNH
in 2000 I have significant experience in
the field of sex education and
boundaries
I learned of the inappropriate content
in the school's online library from my
son who attends Hillsborough during High
School his 15 year old friend had the
soar Library app open and showed him how
the book lesbianist guide to Catholic
school was being advertised
I'll submit these so this is how it
looked on his screen
and
he was my son had him open the book and
he started to read it he took
screenshots he was shocked and he knew
immediately that this was not for a
school library he brought it to his
English teacher the teacher said it was
all fine to be available so my son read
the first page of the book out loud I've
got that here I can't read it it's not
readable
so he read it out loud it was really
really offensive so he was in trouble
his point was made the principal saw it
and just sent him to his next class
it started me looking though once my son
told me what happened I insisted he show
me exactly it's been a shocking
Discovery ever since I read that book
Let's be on his guide to Catholic school
then the other that was also
inappropriately advertised that day here
in queer both were explicitly sexual and
offensive throughout it made me realize
our kids were indeed being advertised in
appropriate books through their school
computers so I started looking for books
that other parents said were
questionable and how certain Burke's
books were being promoted
I read the book flamer through the app
it was so graphically sexual and had so
many inappropriate themes for children I
felt compelled to request a private
meeting with my school board the main
character is graphically sexually abused
by others and his confusion leads him to
attempt suicide this is a middle school
book
my husband and I please allow me more
time well I'm going to give you one more
minute but that's it my husband and I
met with the school board on June 6th
they listened and said just take the
library app off my kids computers and
the problem was solved I was quite aware
of the harms the other students were
being subjected to but hope that someone
would look now that I had said something
that never happened I continue to read
the books from the app becoming more and
more concerned about what I was finding
available to the students in my district
the most dangerous book I read so far is
this book is gay by Juno Dawson it has a
section boldly titled how sex apps work
it has detailed explanations on how to
perform blowies and handys explaining to
everyone that everyone and I mean
everyone has anal sex and all men like
to put things in their anus it explains
that bombing is a normal feeling of
wanting to put your penis in everything
it's a perverted view of sex under this
the disguise of sex education it's
sexual misinformation that is openly
accessible to students at all times
without support the book also has an
embedded hyperlink to match.com
and explains in detail how to use
grinder for hookups
the embedded link the embedded hyperlink
is right at the part of the book that
gives sex app instructions you've gone
beyond that extra minute plus now
so we're going to open it up to
questions if you're willing to take
questions
questions from the committee
not seeing thank you very much please oh
reps represent Rock dry thank you Mr
chairman could you explain to me the
difference between things on an app and
books in a library please thank you
so that's a good question
um these books are not for the most part
in the physical Library they're mostly
on the soar student Library app so our
student library is available to 53 000
districts around the country
our district uses something called the
New Hampshire shared collection and
that's pretty much used by most
districts in New Hampshire
that is the particular catalog that is
full of sexually inappropriate books and
it is advertising them to my kids
through their Chromebooks
yes you may
so is this something that a school or a
district signs into to make available in
my district we they they charge I think
250 dollars to have access to 8 000
books these books I I reviewed like like
kept going through them just to kind of
see what the overall content is I did a
search for Donald Trump in the Sora app
the only book that resulted was
his opponent I don't know if I have that
here
I did let me show you real quick
the folded piece right there I want to
show you because it's so perfect
I I searched for Donald Trump
and Joe Biden comes up in the library
Donald Trump's a writer Joe Biden's not
like the Sora Library app has an issue
and the Librarians are not seeing that
they just trust the app 100 some other
librarian has vetted that they say to me
so I opted my kids out but I am here for
all the other kids
it's not okay and my kids don't have
access to the library
okay okay okay uh we're gonna we're
gonna move on here are there further
questions
thank you very much
I'd like to invite up uh Anne-Marie
Banfield um
let's submit these things
including this these Middle School
representative guy
all command Marie thank you
good morning
my name is Anne-Marie Banfield I'm a
parental rights Advocate focused on
academic excellence in education so
today I come here in support of HB 514
um I will explain from the website
stopitnow.org why
this needs to stop in our schools
the question on the website says Dear
stop it now is it considered check child
sexual abuse if someone shows a child
pornographic pictures but does not
actually touch the child doesn't child
doesn't a child need to be physically
molested in order to for it to be
considered child sexual abuse
the answer was showing pornographic
pictures to a child is considered sexual
child sexual abuse child sexual abuse
can include non-touching behaviors
purposely exposing a child to adult
sexuality is considered a form of child
sexual abuse whether or not a child is
touched
please note that they please note that
although there may not be harmful intent
so there may not be harmful intent
even having adult pornography or sexual
toys in the home where a child comes
across them can be viewed by authorities
as sexual abuse in some circumstances we
are talking about child sexual abuse
with some of this stuff that's going on
in our schools right now I've been
talking about objectionable but we were
kind of using objectionable objection
but we have a law and I advise parents
all the time replace it we have a law we
don't remove those kinds of materials we
are talking in this bill about
pornographic and obscene material that
you have to have seen because I've seen
it because I've had this parent and
other parents contact me and show it to
me
if parents and parents have taken this
material and posted this on social media
posted it on Facebook and their account
was suspended and the material was
removed because it violates Community
standards the the pictures that you are
seeing some of the parents in New
Hampshire have posted that and have had
that removed you need to know that this
is not about objectionable material we
worked hard to get that bill passed it
many people oppose that are now throwing
that up and saying well wait we can just
remove object well yeah you opposed it
when we were fighting for it years ago
and now you're right we can't replace it
and it gives parents the opportunity to
keep their kids in that public school
but you're talking about child sexual
abuse with some of this material that's
what it qualifies as and what what
qualifies as pornography I've been told
you know it when you see it I mean come
on I think we all know that if we took
our kids to the neighbor's house and
dropped them off and they came home and
they said you know what my um good
friend's father you know took me in a
private room and showed me these
pictures I think all of us some of these
pictures we'd be going okay I need to
alert the authorities so I asked you to
support this Bill thank you very much
are there questions from the committee
that's in your hands thank you very much
thank you yep I'd like to invite Megan
Tuttle
foreign
welcome Megan
okay
um thank you chairman and members of the
committee
um for the record my name is Megan
Tuttle I'm the president of Nea New
Hampshire we represent over 17 000
Educators across the state in our K-12
public schools and also a few higher ed
institutions I'm here to testify in
opposition to hospital 514 because this
this bill would insert the Department of
Education and school boards into a
criminal adjudication process when
that's not their role the Department of
Education should focus on supporting the
Educators who serve our students and
stop trying to find ways to bring in
some you know intimidation with
heavy-handed tactics like this moreover
the bill is confusing and we don't feel
it's really ready to become law
so a question we have is what's wrong
with the current process it's been in
place for about 50 years why does the
sponsor of the department think that
school boards or the Department of
Education are better equipped than our
courts to determine what meets the legal
threshold of obscenity
in section two of the bill the language
adds the Department of Education to the
law enforcement entities whose current
role is to initiate a preliminary
hearing regarding obscene material
if I read the bill correctly the process
would no longer apply to K-12 schools so
we're not sure why the doe would need to
be added to the agencies who could
initiate this process
Section 3 of the bill would require
school boards to adopt a policy or
process for adjudicating whether
material is obscene where does the
policy and School Board process fit
with the criminal process of prosecuting
obscenity if is this school board
process supposed to replace replace the
current preliminary hearing process done
by the courts in most cases school
boards wait for criminal investigations
to close before taking any action and
that's at the behest of law enforcement
this proposal would require the opposite
by having the school board and then the
State Board of Education make the
initial determination before law
enforcement would bring charges
so why would this process that could end
in prosecution be removed from the
jurisdiction of law enforcement and be
given ultimately to the State Board of
Education to decide
Additionally the bill appears to create
a new standard for determining if if
material is obscene which is whether the
material is harmful to minors this is
not the long-standing criminal of Sanity
standard and as a standard its broad
suggest subjective excuse me and
nebulous as we heard earlier you know
what one family commissioner or School
Board thinks is harmful is not the same
necessarily as what another one thinks
is harmful so that's why we feel these
decisions really need to be left in the
courts to be examined with the statutory
definition relevant case law
finally what happens if the agencies
listed here have a differing opinion on
whether to initiate a hearing under this
legislation does one take precedent over
the other who's speaking for the state
in such circumstances
the chief law enforcement department of
the state or is it one of its state
agencies
the process that this bill seems to set
up seems confusing it's subjective and
at the end of the day we don't feel it's
an effective way to do what the current
law was designed to do which is to
protect children from obscene materials
that would cause some harm
so thank you for considering the
testimony just standing look at that
three minutes right can I just add in
hope you'll find it in experience a
legislative thank you very much uh there
are questions from the committee
not seeing any thank you oh yes
represents
I just once again based on your
testimony we read through this can I see
these as two different things and you're
saying that the second section the new
subdivision is replacing or putting in
front of
uh the criminal
section and I see I don't see that and
I'm wondering if you can explain to me
because my reading of it is
the one is for their local school
as just removing or keeping the material
no criminal anything or prosecution I'm
not seeing anything in there just a
whether or not the material should be
removed or restricted
and the first section has to do with our
criminal code and law and whatever
so I see these as two completely
different things and I'm not sure how
your or why you're conflating them thank
you thank you for the question we're
putting them together because it's in
the same bill with a new subdivision
talking about the complaint policy in
the second part
we read it as taking the school out of
the first part because it's crossed out
and then there we read it as putting in
a process or a policy in the second part
which is fine to have the process policy
on you know where it could be going or
how a parent could come in and say they
didn't want the material for their child
but we don't think it should be ending
up there or the safe part of Education
it'll be moving on to the next so if
they were two different things my
understanding and we can differ on how
we interpret this which I think is part
of the problem with the confusing for us
is that it still is part of
the same piece
yes
would you have the same problems if we
just put this one bill in as two
separate bills
I would need to see it before I could
answer that same thing just divided
between the first part which has to do
with this
the first part amends this the second
part talks about something completely
different if we just divided it right
there would it be more clear what was it
could be are you yeah they could be
thank you for the questions from the
committee
now seeing thank you very much I'm
written testimony I'll hand in yes thank
you very much uh Mary uh Wilkie is it
w-i-l-l-c-e
um
thank you Mr chair and members of the
committee I'm Mary Wilkie I'm from
Concord
and I'm here to oppose HB 514 there's a
number of issues with the bill and other
people have addressed quite a few of
them and I'm hoping others will get
addressed later I wanted to focus um
just on my experience as a public school
teacher I taught in Concord school
district for 20 years and I had more
than a thousand students overall I
taught in four different schools
um one year I gave a homework assignment
to some of my fifth graders that
involved reading an article about
dinosaurs and the next morning I got a
call from a mom saying that she had told
her child not to read the article
because um the notion that dinosaurs
existed millions of years ago conflicted
with her religion
so I think too for telling me and I
excused the child from the homework I
gave them a different assignment to do
during independent reading that would
cover the same skill I was trying to get
at if a conversation was friendly and
respectful we worked it out no one
suggested that nobody else get to read
about dinosaurs and I just felt like
that's the way usually situations work
teachers and parents work together as a
team they collaborate for the benefit of
the child
um
but more
yeah
you have a little button right there
there you go that's good you might I'm
sorry thank you
um
so there's already a law that prevents
schools from providing obscene materials
but currently it allows
um
because the law of defining obscenity is
so
um subjective
it the current bill allows schools and
libraries and museums to get a court
opinion before they're held liable for
presenting materials like that
the uh the HB 514 would take away that
protection for K-12 teachers so they're
left knowing that they could face
criminal penalties if they don't if they
make a if they judge something
differently from the way a court might
in the future judge it
okay
I don't understand why we just don't
leave it the way it is there's already
protection against the kind of materials
that some of the witnesses have referred
to
in general the definition of obscene
materials though it's not it's not just
anything that makes somebody feel
uncomfortable and I'm not I'm again I
think those materials sounded obscene to
me
but what I worry about is people have
different ideas what makes them
uncomfortable and uh the definition of
obscene materials in the statute is very
is it it's materials Who quote
predominant appeal is to the brilliant
interest in sex that is an interest in
lewdness and lascivious thoughts I don't
think our our school teachers are out
there you know pushing those kinds of
materials on kids if they're in some
apps somewhere then that should be
brought to that judicial proceeding and
address is that my time yeah oh it goes
by so fast so
um I would just like to say okay two
more sentences sure
as a public school teacher that been so
many bills lately that kind of
allude to ideas that are cast teachers
in a bad light as if we were all out
there pushing pornography on our kids as
a teacher the best interest of my kids
was what kept me awake at night I was
not doing that and it kind of breaks my
heart to hear that people think that
public school teachers are doing things
like that thank you very much thank you
are there questions from the committee
thank you very much thank you
uh Deborah house
good morning good morning
good to see you all again
um my name is Deborah house I'm here
from the American Federation of teachers
New Hampshire and I am pleased to uh
just chairman by the members of the
education committee today I represent 4
000 members in uh public K-12 education
uh as well as public higher education
New Hampshire and between us we
teach about 29 000 of the public school
students in this state as well as
thousands of University students and we
oppose HB 514
um
just we disagree with the sponsor of the
bill we see that it is indeed going to
lead to book Banning and material being
removed from public schools and
potentially public universities
I am not going to go over everything
that's been testified to before but
we are clear that our Public School
boards have in place
procedures for
um
for parents who object to material to
to
um you know raise their objections to
them parents have the right to raise
objections to materials to challenge
those materials and there's already
processing places for that we don't need
a separate law for it
but what we don't want is for one parent
who objects to a a book in the library
or in the classroom to be able to decide
for all children in that school what
your child is able to read
um you know representative luno said it
very well earlier that you can't decide
what my child can read
um
and
we are we are in favor of creating
good readers and in order for kids to be
good readers they need to have books so
we are in favor of getting books in kids
hands as a matter of fact aft is uh in
the midst of a reading opens the world
effort and we've given out over a
million books two kids and parents at
community events across the country
including three aft New Hampshire locals
where we've given out 8 000 books so
rather than trying to ban books we're
out there giving out books at community
events so this really goes against what
we are all about which is making sure
that kids have plenty of books to read
and are exposed to you know the whole
world through Reading now another part
of this bill that we have concerns about
is where
in revising
um
Who falls under the obscene materials
the statute
where it says
uh public universities that now exposes
the universities to the criminal
litigation if material is deemed to see
obscene so previously they weren't
mentioned and now you are going to
potentially limit
what adults can have access to at
universities
and that's going in the wrong directions
I do have my testimony to give you today
I have it cool thank you very much are
there any questions from the committee
yes representative parano thank you Mr
chair and thank you for taking my
question I'm confused I keep hearing
this mentioned over and over again that
we don't want one parent
making a decision for all of the rest of
the students but we all know sometimes
it takes one person to make a group
aware of what's going on so I'm just
curious how many parents would it take
so that one parent should bring their
concerns to well first the the teacher
would be the place to start because it
works best when parents and teachers
work as a team for the individual child
but then you know there there is
following the command you will go to the
principal and the school board you have
a community to work in if enough of the
community agrees then you would
reconsider that material
I mean we've got that process in place
we've already got those kind of policies
if you find something that
you think is inappropriate and
representative page I don't be still in
the room describe that in in very good
detail
yes
it also can seem to keep hearing the
assumption that this is material that's
being presented in the classroom but it
also sounds to me like this material
might be just available in the library
how would parents go about approaching
that
if it's something in the library
yeah
no one is forcing your student to take
out a particular library book
library books are not assigned so those
are choices and and I'm always hearing
that we need to give students more
choices so you uh if there's a
particular topic or book you don't want
your student reading that's a place to
actually proactively have a conversation
about hey
I don't want my child taking this book
out so that's that's another place where
teamwork really needs to come in if
that's something you don't want your
child having then please speak up we
would really rather not have an Irate
parent saying oh my goodness my child
brought home this book and I'm horrified
um
yeah but again taking away something
that another parent thinks is a valuable
resource and again I'm not going to
address the particular items those those
parents brought because I I haven't seen
them I mean so I I it would not be fair
um but
it's not something that one person
should decide for everyone because these
are public schools for the whole
Community not for just your family
thank you for the questions
representative
I'm also confused and I'm hoping you
will enlighten me you were talking about
how this opens up higher education but
the first part are those who were
Exempted from the obscene matter and
before it just said educational and
higher education was put in as Exempted
specifically because they're adults
and and what they're what's not being
Exempted is
um minor education of minors but the and
so I'm confused how how by exempting
them you open them up
they are
they are opened up once the material is
deemed to be obscene
to further prosecution or further legal
action if they continue to display
disseminate or
um you know otherwise circulate the
material
and if you look into the upside ID
statute which uh representative David
referred to earlier
um
if it's gone through that adversarial
hearing
uh and has been found
to
you know not have the
um
you know found to be obscene and not
have any
um redeeming value which is a very
subjective
definition
what has educational value to one person
might not have educational value to
another person so you're getting into a
somewhat squishy area
then you have indeed open those people
up to
um
legal proceedings
that's the answer I've got so a
follow-up is I'm going to uh get you
more of an answer yeah so you can keep
asking I would suggest that on the side
you talk that without ripping electives
uh are there other questions from the
committee not seeing thank you very much
Alora L Azam
Chad Lee
uh Heather Raymond
did you look at this section right here
it says they shall not be okay so how
does that thank you committee and um rep
cordelli let me know that I should come
rep in front so that everyone knows that
so my name is Heather Raymond I am the
representative for Hillsboro District
Five in Nashua I'm also the chair of the
policy committee on the national board
of education I have over 15 years
experience as a child and family social
worker including five years as a
forensic interviewer for the New York
State Police which makes me a little bit
of an expert in child abuse specifically
sexual abuse of children so I noticed
that there was some testimony about that
earlier today I'm not going to touch on
that because it's something different
some previous speakers have said a lot
of my prepared remarks um so I just want
to highlight a couple of things
um first policy ige based on RSA 186
119c which is the parental objections to
specific course materials covers any
objection that any particular parent has
about material that they don't want
their child being exposed to the second
policy that I want to bring to the
attention of the committee and I know
that Mr Christina had referred to it is
policy ilja which is the removal of
media center materials which lays out a
process by which any local school
district can remove items from their
media centers which typically is because
they're old or out of date or falling
apart but also can be used for other
reasons
um I wanted to read a statement from the
American Library Association
and the statement is the unprecedented
number of challenges we're seeing
already this year reflects coordinated
National efforts to silence marginalized
or historically underrepresented voices
and deprive all of us young people in
particular of the choice to explore a
world beyond the confines of personal
experience
Librarians develop Collections and
resources that make knowledge and ideas
widely available so people and families
are free to choose what to read
though it is natural that we want to
protect young people from some of life's
more difficult realities the truth is
that banning books does nothing to
protect them from dealing with tough
issues instead it denies young people
resources that can help them deal with
the challenges that confront them
and just a couple more things from the
American Library Association 40 percent
of the books that were requested to be
removed in 2022 were regarding lgbtq
Plus student subjects or by authors that
are lgbtq plus another 40 of books that
were requested to be removed in 2022 had
main characters of color or were written
by individuals of color
so I know this is New Hampshire we are
not a diverse State Nashua is the most
diverse of all of the cities in New
Hampshire and our diversity is low about
half of our kids are non-white or
partially non-white it is very important
to me as a member of the board of
education but also as a parent and a
representative of my community to ensure
that we do not pass any type of state
law that would marginalize or silence
the voices of the people in my community
kids deserve to read books about others
that look and experience things like
them
thank you are either way willing to take
questions
from the committee
not seeing you thank you very much thank
you uh Bruce Burke
good morning thank you good morning
thank you citizen legislators we know
how hard you work my name is Bruce Burke
I live in Pittsfield I'm a retired
teacher of about 40 years uh so many
things have been brought up this morning
I'm going to uh go in a different
direction I think but I am talking about
this bill
so one of the things I've done in
retirement is I'm in my coaching my
fourth year on a casa case I have three
children uh two of them have IEPs one of
them has a 504 and uh maybe 10 days ago
we just had a meeting about this child's
504 myself the foster mom the principal
the teacher three specialists
I am talking about this bill please
don't think that I'm losing track here
tremendous effort
tremendous effort put into one child
and when I asked the Foster Mother after
the meeting if there were other kids in
the class like her foster daughter she
said there are at least four more
and the point that I'm trying to make is
our teachers are working incredibly hard
they're exhausted I would say they're
overwhelmed by the last two or three
years
and it feels like
perhaps for good intention but it feels
like to me that we continue to have a
series of bills that come before this
committee
that say we do not value teachers we
don't trust teachers
and so when I look at this bill and I
read it in the process makes some sense
to me I think what we're doing again
is we are jeopardizing the future of
teaching in New Hampshire because who's
going to come look for a job in this
state
if this bill becomes law
on top of a decisive you know decisive
language bill on top of perhaps a
loyalty oath bill
what happens to young people looking to
become Educators I'm afraid they're not
going to come to New Hampshire and I
think we already know there's a teaching
crisis in New Hampshire in terms of
Staffing thank you thank you very much
questions from the committee
yes represent Belcher thank you Mr
Sharon thank you for that testimony I
just wanted to clarify are you
suggesting that if we were to prohibit
as this bill were to say obscene books
in the classroom and prohibit the
teaching of critical race theory that
teachers being trained in teachers
colleges would choose not to come and
teach in this state I think what I'm
what I'm trying to say is I I don't want
to intimidate young people who are
pursuing a career in education
uh I don't want to take too much time
because of discuss I mean obscenity I I
we could disagree around the margins I
think most of us can agree on what's
obscene
right but what I what I'm trying to say
here is if we put too many roadblocks to
our to to teachers
they aren't going to stay in the
profession
it just becomes uh discouraging for them
uh
not to be redundant I mean these people
I met with last week they're exhausted
trying to deal with this child and other
children and so
really I think we should be talking
about pay increases and how do we
recognize teachers but that's a
different subject for a different day
another important subject though further
further questions we is no no
representative yeah yeah go ahead do you
think
um that it's not only
bills like this but the fact that they
carry criminalization and felony
convictions that probably
chill the teacher into even coming close
to the borderlines or and experimenting
with anything so I read the bill twice I
think I understand it then I thought I
heard a different interpretation over
here earlier but as I read the bill I
thought that there was after process uh
perhaps criminalization involved I think
that would be chilling and if I'm in a
faculty
where a colleague has been brought up to
trial whether there was a guilty plea or
not
I'd be intimidated
thank you represent Belgium thank you
very brief thank you Mr chair thank you
for the testimony again I just
I I understand the the issue around
um a criminal penalty but to draw
contrast if somebody were to
walk up to a child at a playground and
show them the content that is in some of
these books could they possibly expect
to have police involved in a charge
you want me to put on my Police hat now
look at I here's where I'm not going to
disagree with you I
as a parent as a former educator as you
know I think a pretty normal human being
we have to be careful about
what we there are things that obviously
that our kids should not be seeing I
guess I deferred to the comments earlier
in the day I think the school boards and
the principals and the teachers we have
to trust them to make the right decision
if there's a one percent of who aren't
then I you know I think they're ways to
go after that
thank you yeah
thank you further
thank you very much
uh Joseph Marquette
hello thank you for joining me my name
is Joseph Marquette I am a teacher in
New Hampshire I'm a teacher back in New
Hampshire after I didn't teach in New
Hampshire for 10 years because of the
homophobia that was alive in New
Hampshire I didn't get my career here
but then I left but then I came back
because New Hampshire was trying to
figure itself out a little bit and
showing some human decency to human
beings I don't have anything prepared
per se because I came here to be
available to you so just for clarity
um talk about teachers getting paid I
get a bonus if I don't take my personal
days but what happened to me as a gay
child was horrible horrible
and I will stay here with you as long as
you would like because I fought for my
marriage in these buildings I've been
put to shame in front of people publicly
in this state so much in my life that if
you want to sit here I'll cry I'm gonna
be kind of gross it's okay
but I'm here to fight for kids because
nobody fought for me
nobody gave me information
the lack of that information led to a
story that's worthy of a bad movie I
would never want to see
I show up every day
I am working on my third graduate
qualification I hope for Teacher
certifications I'm qualified for two
more my student during covid was the
only American student that was permitted
or as how do you say in English and
entered into the most prestigious Latin
immersion program in Europe the full
scholarship all expenses paid through
covet
I bring quality to the school every
single day I'm meeting 14 teachers
through a master's program after they
work all day one of them is our
librarian who's covering my class right
now because she is afraid to come here
again I've been beaten up by this state
so much I can just come and take it
she's afraid she's a mama
she's being harassed
and that's not okay
but something we not be thinking about
is that the kids know this is happening
they know you're throwing them around
they know you're debating them they're
hoping that some of you are kind
but they know that they're also
homophobes what is happening here is a
cultural process that's part of my
scholarship my first graduate degree is
actually in queer theory if you'd like
to know and understand I'm here for your
questions
if you want to know what it's like to
grow up without access to Brothers I can
tell you about learning trying to figure
out whether or not I was going to hell
because of the religious abuse I was
raised in in Barrington New Hampshire by
a community of people who thought that
they should raise children without any
access to the world
so homosexuality was a quote send the
cried out to heaven for punishment
I was 14 years old sneaking into my
church library which was the only place
I had access to books
looking for something to find out as a
14 year old healthy young man whether or
not masturbation was actually going to
get me to Hell excuse me three three
minutes is just could I have one more
minute like the person who was talking
about Donald Trump hi that is thank you
kindly
so
what I learned terrorized me
it also meant that I was not protected
again we don't have time and and I'm not
really well prepared because I just
decided to do this this morning and I
gave up my my who cares all right
teachers reported began with but I'm
here for you
I'm sorry that I'm not presenting well I
have to fit all of my PTSD trauma
through this
but if you would like to ask me
questions about what's going on and what
you're feeling because people are
putting right now I'm thinking there's
lots of emotions that's called formal
cultural response it makes you feel
formal cultural response it's part of
being a human being
your funnel cultural response is yours
I'm the world's biggest food
I was going to be a priest
I just stopped watching I'm just our
20th year anniversary the same on demand
was this thing on Netflix with my
husband we decided it was just too rough
that is my choice
I was six children in Portsmouth
they were safe because of the
professionals Imports but we kept them
safe excuse me the time has his time I'm
sorry so uh are there any questions from
the committee
nothing thank you very much
representative yes thank you for that
that's awesome I just I I know that you
said your first graduate degree was in
queer theory yes is that something you
would Advocate teaching in in uh
um earlier grades such as high school
elementary school or middle school but
so most people don't even know what
queer theory is like most people don't
know what socialism is like most people
okay I'm gonna you know that's right
here oh sure yes this is a bill that's
dealing with a different topic than that
question so I'm going to disallow the
question okay are there any other uh
questions from the committee that's yes
representative McDonald thank you Mr
thank you for asking me a question thank
you for being here
um you mentioned that you were a parent
to Children Here in New Hampshire yes
and the prime sponsor when he introduced
this bill he said his intent was not to
ban books actually his intent was to
give rights to parents so I'd love to
know if you could direct me to a point
within the bill where it would take away
your rights as a parent as you said to
um if you chose your children didn't
want to view a certain material wearing
here this would prevent you from doing
that I would see this bill as giving
more rights to parents I understood the
bill is giving rights to parents to try
to remove books such that they're not
available to the children of other
parents who want their children to have
access to books
I also know that as a parent and as a
child in New Hampshire that there were
standards in my family and that those
families that those standards selected
what I read active parenting takes care
of this issue
that is what active printing is for
so what we're doing when we allow
reading material that is vetted by
professionals nationally who work very
hard in Board review to be able to okay
attain the qualifications that would
which is what the Librarians do they
have entire data networks and then they
read all of the reviews that are put
forward by professionals when we have
that available to children they are made
safe
now children who don't want to read a
book because they do not feel that need
psychologically they open the first page
they go yeah not for me and they put it
down
and isn't that child perhaps lucky you
know who knows maybe the bill has to do
with abuse unless you to the bill the
book
but for the child who needs to know that
there's a word for something
and then needs to know how to be safe
that book can save a life
when we take away children's ability to
read books or parents trust in schools
that those things are there that they
need
we limit the processes of our democracy
may I ask a follow-up please no we're
not going to we are really well behind
in our schedule today I appreciate your
coming today and taking and giving us
testimony thank you thank you very much
um the last uh pink card we have is
representative sellers
thank you Mr chair thank you committee
members for allowing me to speak here
for a couple minutes
um I'm representative sellers uh from
Grafton 18. I represent uh Bristol
Alexandria Bridgewater Hebron Groton
orange Dorchester Grafton itself and
Kanan and Enfield
I've been working with the Department of
Education as far as through a workshop
and stuff and some of the stuff that's
coming up today is a process as far as
how a parent goes about bringing a
complaint and I think that's one thing
that this bill and I am supporting this
bill actually does it brings a standard
as to a complaint in how the appeal
would go so I think having that stand at
Statewide is a good thing
the
another representative brought up the
challenge as far as the uh one of the
excuse me for a second
the American Library Association uh
complaints about 1597 books uh I do have
the top 10 challenge books right here
I'm not going to show it uh it is
anyways I do have it here someone does
want it point I'm making here is
those Works have been challenged and
then he said there was even more in 22.
and the problem is
we the people are finding problems
within the school and probably most
likely the school library is more than
the actual uh classroom itself so the
libraries themselves I don't know if
they have a mission statement but if
they do they should be really honing
that mission statement to the core
subject of this for the students to
learn even more all right at that point
the um
I don't think anybody's really trying to
ban books these the kids the kids can
actually go to local libraries or
outside or at home and search these up
if that's what they want to do on the
Internet or even order them on Amazon if
that's the point if they want to so as
far as the school goes they want to make
sure it's age appropriate in a lot of
cases it is not and that's part of the
problem what might be good for our 12th
grader is not good for a ninth grader
all right well our ninth grade is not
good for a seventh grader so and that's
what's happening in our school so
all right I'll take any questions if you
have any thank you very much
representative uh representative Tanner
thank you thank you for taking my
question
how many of those communities that you
represent have libraries outside of the
school
uh I would absolutely say at least two
no probably three or four at least
at least uh Enfield I'm sure does have
one I know Bristol absolutely has one
and I would think Alexandria was
probably another if not Bridgewater and
also Kanan
um yeah further questions
thank you
so with that I'm going to close the
hearing that we have today on 514 and
we're going to take a a break here come
back and and open up one bill uh but
let's take a break so everybody can
stretch a little bit we've been sitting
for quite a while
foreign
okay we're gonna go ahead and and start
the next hearing we have that is on 604
relative to reading specialists
recognize representative cardelli
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker Mr
chairman
um sorry about that
um yeah right I don't think I'm going
there
is able to retire
uh for the record Glenn cordelli uh
representing Tuftonboro Wolfeboro and
Ossipee in the beautiful Lakes Region uh
I'm not sure where the Press went but
this bill is relative to reading
Specialists
we've talked about this a little bit
um in Prior days
reading specialist is in statute now but
it is related to Contract Services for a
reading specialists this just opens it
up for this for the Department to employ
a staff member who would be a reading
specialist so it's very simple it's
something requested by the department uh
because they do have someone who is
serving in that role uh so the statutes
should conform to uh practice thank you
thank you very much are there questions
from the committee yes representative
cascaden a great one thank you thank you
representative cordelli
um do you think there still is a need to
maintain that contracted Services of a
reading specialist
um who knows thank you for the question
I'm not sure what's going to happen in
the future so
um I I don't think it's
um bad to leave it in there because it
could be something needed in the future
and we wouldn't have to modify the
statute again at that point
further questions from the committee
represent whitcock
thank you chairman is this going to add
an additional staff person because they
have one the doe has one now right
I I believe that was the testimony that
we heard the other day Okay but I think
there is someone from the Department
here who could offer technical
assistance if so desired I'm not sure
it's technical the question is this
going to add a second position
no okay thank you thank you chairman
further further questions
not seeing any thank you very much uh
does doe have a an answer to that uh in
terms of
reading curriculum reading coordinator
Specialists etc etc that might be at the
department
good morning Melissa white division
director for learner support for the
Department of Education we currently
have an English language arts education
consultant position within the
department that currently exists we were
able to uh luckily hire somebody that
has a lot of extensive experience and
meets the requirements of the reading
specialist so we would like to be able
to have her serve in that capacity and
meet the requirements of the RSA as
stated earlier we do want the ability to
have the flexibility of the unfortunate
event happens that we no longer have
that person on staff to be able to then
contract out for those services
so is that representative get towards
where you asked that question
go ahead
thanks it's brief so that person if they
have all of those sharp skills that you
you admire in the person is there
potential for that person to become
certified as a reading specialist as
well that person is currently certified
as a reading specialist thank you
yes represent Woodcock thank you thank
you good morning
um
so if the current Ela consultant is that
a is that a contract Service or that
it's a staff position okay so with the
bill add an additional staff position as
a reading specialist no it would just
allow us to meet the requirements of the
RSA by having that person can serve in
that capacity yes
oh thank you thank you with the ELA
consultant position as a as a physician
be eliminated no it would just be that
those um responsibilities and duties
would be rolled into that position okay
thank you thank you chairman
further further question represent
cascadden would that person be
responsible to inventory the schools
that don't screen for dyslexia or
provide professional uh training to
those that need it correct thank you
within your department do you have a
specific job description for this this
person that's going to be now put in a
position of reading Specialists yes I do
I can provide that to the community
thank you
Beach to it
uh further questions
well thank you thank you very much
have a good afternoon
a rest of the morning
are there any other uh Pink cards that
we've received here on this particular
bill
not seeing any we're going to close this
hearing
well we have a little time so let's try
to slip into the next one as well
uh that is excuse me 623 establishing a
teacher candidate loan forgiveness
program
so that reps in Myers bill
foreign
good morning
good morning chairman Ladd thank you for
this opportunity to present this bill my
name is Mel Myler and I represent uh
Merrimack 9 the
lovely towns of Hopkinton and Bo
I would like to have you look at the
amendment and forget the original bill
so I would like to I would like to move
I'm not sure the appropriate procedure
is to move uh the amendment and I'll
explain why you don't know you don't
have to move it you can just talk about
it because then we will do that when we
get an exact session a bit of a wait do
we have that Amendment
oh okay yes a bit of a background for
the committee uh last year
you should have enough
we don't have enough
how many are we short
well I'm probably about four four short
okay I'll get those for you for then
okay yeah
uh the
just a bit of a background last year
there was a uh work group that worked on
the issue of teachers teacher shortage
uh the members of that committee uh was
myself representing the lad represent
representative Ford uh Senator Khan and
Senator Ward
Senator Khan was the chair of that
committee and we spent a time looking at
the issue of teacher shortages within
the state
last year when we started the school
year we discovered that there was
significant teacher shortages around the
state
and we had various people come before us
to talk about the need to do something
about the teacher shortage
and as a result of that this bill I
presented this bill
to try to adapt to address the issue of
shortages primarily in a teacher
certification areas as well as rural
areas because that was a focus that we
looked at in the committee
and this is a loan forgiveness program
that would allow teachers who work in
identified teacher shortage areases as
well as rural areas to uh when they work
in these areas a graduated way of
re reimbursing loans that they might
have had to get their teaching
certificate you will note on the second
page
it talks about the uh the graduated
nature of the loan forgiveness so that
if a teacher were to be working the
first year they could get a fifteen
hundred dollars uh twenty five hundred
dollars up to four forty five hundred
dollars or a total of twelve thousand
dollars alone if that was their uh if
that was their loan and it's important
to note that I did this in a way to try
to make sure that hopefully if if folks
are in these particular areas that are
identified by the Department of
Education that they might stay there
after being there for four years or five
years and uh to help uh significantly
those that are underserved schools and
Rural schools and those schools that are
in short supply of teachers in the areas
of
Sciences math Etc and it should be noted
that the department does identify
shortage areas and they would be the
ones that would be able to uh
significantly indicate for school
districts that could then as they
recruit as they recruit new teachers
they can say if you come to teach here
for example you have this potential for
a loan reimbursement uh if they if they
work in the school district weeks so
that's really what this is all about and
it's a I will also say that there's a a
similar bill that is working its way
through the Senate now that basically
addresses the same issues that both
representing Ford and representative lad
and I worked on over the summer
so that's that's basically the
introduction of this and I will say that
the initial bill not that I want you to
look at it but the initial bill was to
have the loan forgiveness to come
through the university system and as I
was talking with the university
Representatives they said really it's
they're not they don't have the
capability of doing this and further
this really opens it up to many more
students because it was primarily
focused original concept was focused on
those individuals going through the UNH
system this would allow teachers from
any system any school that had a loan
that would work in these primarily
priority areas thank you very much thank
you very much uh reverse
we've discussed this question before
you've got a tiered system for over the
four years uh for this incentive award
um what happens for the individual let's
say that uh comes and takes a job from
you graduate at UMass Lowell comes
across and is is and that's perfectly
acceptable if they're working here but
then they cut bait after one year and
leave but they took their incentive
grant for it should there be a time
where you come in and stay uh for it and
then you collect your you know the
funding for your loan forget I know that
doesn't help with interest and all that
but maybe it would ensure that somebody
comes and stays in our state rather than
coming in you know them leaving well I
think that's always that's always a
possibility to have with any employment
we don't we don't have indentured
servitude here uh trying to get people
just to stay here but I think this was
just an attempt to try to meet the
initial needs of school districts that
could use this as a recruitment process
for their uh vacancies yeah
further question represent perineal
thank you Mr chair thank you
representative Miler for taking my
question
um do we have any idea how many teachers
might be availing themselves of this
opportunity I'm just trying to get an
idea of how many underserved what was
the word
um
uh critical edu shortages we have thank
you thank you for the questions uh very
good when we were dealing with this in
the summer time we did
um a survey of of superintendents Etc
and I don't I don't have the numbers off
the top of my head but there were
significant numbers at that time of
trying to recruit people to go into
these specific areas that are mentioned
in the bill so I'm sorry I don't have
the figure but believe me that that was
a big deal when we started school
because at many schools I did not have
teachers because of the the the short
shortages and they weren't really filled
until later into the uh fall of the Year
thank you for representative Lucas
foreign
on to previous comma and knowing what's
done a lot of times in Industry
um would you be amenable to putting off
this for a year or two before you start
paying back
to encourage teachers to actually to
better encourage teachers to actually
stay rather than this within four years
all of the money has been paid off and
there's and
I'm not really thought about that it's a
New Concept uh according to what
representative Ladd said my basic
concern was trying to meet the immediate
need that school districts were saying
that they they needed to have it at the
moment thank you
representative Damon
thanks Mr chair thank you representative
Myler I love this concept I've actually
been asked for it by constituents who
teach in Claremont and that is District
that frequently loses teachers to better
paying schools and in other geographies
sometimes still in New Hampshire
in your intro you commented about I
believe in the original version of the
bill
um
also having an incentive program for
teachers who teach in subject matter
areas where we have a critical shortage
and trying to read and listen at the
same time I may have missed it but I
don't think that's in the amendment when
you look at critical shortages it would
be both for Rural and those highly
highly needed
subject matters I mean we've talked
about science math there are the others
that we've special education right
special technology writing technology to
him so that is included here yeah and it
that it should be I mean I think it is
because these the Department of
Education basically identifies those
High need areas and this would would be
focused on those High need areas as well
as the rural issue too
and they and underperforming schools is
another issue here and the the
department also in the indicates which
those are under underperforming schools
too so it's the high need areas that
we're really we're looking that's the
intent of this bill
representative
no representative uh Ford and then
representative Hall
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question have you become aware
of since our committee meetings before
in which we went through these things
that there has developed a motion to
create different levels of teacher
certifications that include the various
steps of Paris and therefore this would
sort of help the process of recruiting
Paras as teachers because they would
then qualify for that I'm not aware of
that that's being floated and I don't
know how far along I'm not I'm not hurt
anything since our meeting I've become
aware of it and uh and so I think that
would tell you again that there are more
people still more people thinking
there's need it applies particularly to
recruiting
um
speakers of other languages who may have
degrees already and they're discovering
that these people can be appointed to
emergency kinds of certification
positions and things of that I know that
I know there are ways to have emergency
certifications that's not really right
but the same body of people tends to
fall in yeah representative
thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative of bringing this forward
very important I have a question about
is there a minimum number of classes per
day so let's say I am a
health teacher and I can teach two
science classes even though I'm not
certified in science
did you just say you have to be
certified in the science or you have to
be teaching the classes and I think the
intent here is that you have to be as it
talks about being a certified teacher uh
in their particular discipline or the
level that you're working at the the the
the bifurcation of the assignment I'm
not sure how that would relate to this
because I I'm just envisioning maybe
um oh no I guess that was a follow-up
never mind I'm good I'm sure when we
prior to getting to executing this we'll
have Mr Appleby in here and because
there are a lot of alternative Pathways
well High School certification of course
you're certified and taking the
practices in a specific area but you can
teach outside that for a course or two
as long as there's not over 50 percent
of the time I believe so there there's a
lot there that we can inform you about
I'd also say that Mr Appleby was also
part of the study group that we have
absolutely yeah he's a member of the
non-voting member
um question for you representative Miler
um we got these the rule underperforming
School
uh rural school districts
underperforming school we have some
schools that are in poverty areas but
they're still
their achievement scores may be fine
they're so not they're not
underperforming but they can't attract
teachers because they don't have to
where at all to pay the teachers so
their Source there's an additional
shortage there
so we might want to look at that in
terms of how do we make sure that
shortage can get into that type of
District as well very good yes
thank you
represent cardelli thank you thank you
representative for bringing this forward
um I'm just wondering in a bigger
picture
um we have many careers that have
shortages around the state uh even
advanced welding Etc how do we as a
general court
determine which careers should have a
loan forgiveness program
are you talking beyond the school
district or within this generally for
the many careers that have shortages how
do we
prioritize how do we determine which
careers get a loan forgiveness program I
don't have an answer to that question
very complicated issue that says
representative Cornell I think chairman
Ladd when you were asking about the the
economic disadvantage or I forget if it
was Brett Miller and line four on page
two says economic disadvantage of the
school based on eligibility for funds
pursuant to title one so wouldn't that
be the economically disadvantaged area
also so be rural economically
disadvantaged and underperforming
I I was thinking I'm a Manchester
I think we hit B and C
probably all but you know but there's a
number of communities and what I was
talking about some of the communities
which are small but they just can't
attract I live in one where we cannot
compete with Lebanon or Hanover down the
river and and so the
we're all of a sudden we're talking out
in our budget coming up how much do we
have to put in the budget for labor
costs to attract people to our community
I think that's very typical in the North
Country they're undergoing that
everywhere
so we got to address that we have a
shortage the biggest shortage we had
this year was 800 paraprofessionals in
the state that was number one but then
it came down those other three and it
adds uh CT in it was technology
further questions for yes representative
thank you is is this not something that
could be taken care of at the local
level through the local
school budget I'm just throwing it out
there well I I think obviously local
school districts are are looking at this
as they try to recruit people I think
the intent here is to provide another
arrow in their quiver so to speak that
they could then go to a potential
applicant and say you know we we fall
under this category and there is a
forgiveness program it's interesting too
that
representative Ladd and I were kind of
committing about this the other day that
when we were going to school there was
an NDA loan that we a National Defense
loan that many of us who are going to be
teachers basically took out that loan
and then there was a loan forgiveness on
that program based upon the numbers of
years you taught this is not the same
thing but it's in the kind of in the
same spirit because at that point in
time there was a problem as we have now
with uh with teacher of recruiting
teachers so thank you
further questions
not saying thank you very much thank you
uh Brian Hawkins
still morning so good morning thank you
Mr chairman and I'm very aware that uh I
may be the last person between uh you
and lunch so I will I'll try and be
brief
um for the record Brian Hawkins any New
Hampshire uh representative Myler
captured a lot of the introduction that
I was going to cover already with regard
to uh the committee that looked at this
as a as one piece of the puzzle in
trying to address the teacher and
educator shortage that we face as you
aptly pointed out there there's teachers
and then there's also the other staff in
the school that are are just as
important and um and we need to be
addressing that as well
um I think that the piece that I would
add is uh as a state we are competing
with our neighbors uh other states in
the country and we are seeing a lot of
states that are adopting these types of
programs uh that to incentivize uh
through and and one of those Central
components is this kind of loan
repayment uh concept
um the amendment that uh representative
Miler brought in looks very similar to a
law passed in Idaho uh which had the the
graduated increase
um and uh at least from the reports that
I've seen from that State uh it there
was a lot of interest in in in in this
in in applying for and participating and
um the other piece I would add is that
this concept is not something that would
be new to the state of New Hampshire
either in the area of Health Care uh we
have the state loan repayment program uh
that is uh through the depart the
division of Public Health
um that was uh
expanded significantly with the
assistance of arpa dollars but the
program did exist prior to that
um and so uh so I think this is
something that we can do and would be
more than happy to work with the
committee to produce a good product
because as I said our our neighbors are
doing this uh and it's important that we
uh keep up so so that we can compete for
that Workforce
um so with that I'll I'll close my
testimony and happy to answer any
questions
foreign
I know there's all kinds of negotiations
in whatever with schools and teachers
and I'm wondering if rather than doing
loan forgiveness can we give bonuses for
staying at a particular school or is
that something in the same amounts
is that something that is going to cause
problems with the teachers union
uh well I see the concept of what
representative Miller talking about was
really it's sort of more a repayment
specifically on on the loans and so I I
almost see it as a similar
situation that you're you're you're
you're you're giving
um uh the essentially bonuses for a
specific thing and I think the benefit
of this is the the quicker you pay off
those loans the the greater value that
is to the individual and that there's
not a you know added potential interest
and so
um and I think the other piece is uh
there are school districts that do uh do
offer uh uh I wouldn't be able to cite
them right now but I knew know that
there are uh schools that that have uh
programs in place uh similar to this but
um
you know one of the things that we heard
at the in the shortage committee was the
varying degrees with which school
districts throughout the state you know
have the flexibility to to do this
um we heard from two a couple of
superintendents in that uh in that
committee some of which talked about uh
this this along the lines of the rural
challenge is uh I think it was a
superintendent from Newport who cited
you know they they need additional help
in in attracting a young person
to relocate to Newport and
um so I think this concept kind of goes
to that uh particularly because of the
graduated increases over a period of
several years uh if they're going to
stay longer they're also likely more
likely to stay there and more likely to
succeed as an educator and that that's
and that was we heard that from
um I think the the both the the
superintendents uh that day who who
testified for the uh before the study
committee
the other superintendent from Manchester
we have Justified yes and I think from
the Mad not too I think mad knock as
well that's right
um You may did a a comparison to other
departments or agencies of the
government HHS
um
when I drive by Grafton County
nursing home Glencliff there's a sign
out five sign seeking lnas we will pay
for your LNA certification so is this
it's so different that that or so new
that our other department areas of edge
government as you alluded to doing
something similar to attract
um and then another question to follow
up how's the four-year system helping us
out on this many states
will say you come and we'll pay for your
master's program if you go teach out
there in this school district you come
out with a master's paid for
um I lived in a state where that
occurred but have you heard of that
occurring anywhere else in the country
yeah so um I'd be happy to uh I have a I
had just for reference for questions uh
a a paper copy but uh it it really has
links to it and so with other states and
what they do so I'd be happy I I was
intending on sending that to the
committee for you to look at what some
other states are already doing in that
in that area yep and then as I said
there are I mean there are individual
school districts that do some
form of this maybe not exactly the way
the The Proposal is here but
um yeah as we've said there's all kinds
of ways people are trying to compete for
um the workforce
no
yes representative Woodcock just a
follow-up to you as representative why
would DHHS did do a host or money that's
used for retention the same concept of
maintaining their staff in in nursing
areas nursing homes and hospitals are
the asset funds as well as police
department so the concept is the same
that was in the Omnibus Bill last year
where we had a committee conference I
remember fighting for glencliffe to
happen to have that money to back pay
for what they needed and to provide
these incentives and and division of
just and a quick comment on that and
division of Public Health does that
program that I referenced earlier I
believe does have a focus on on Rural
communities because of the critical
access Hospital needs and so uh
I had a chance to have a extensive
conversation with the now former
director there and uh it was very
helpful in terms of information on uh
how they structured that program
so just to note there's another question
but we're also seeing the demographic
the four-year systems like UNH Keenan
and uh Plymouth where participation
especially UNH and the Department of
Education where they're getting their
teachers ticket enrollment is declining
yep
yes
we're seeing fewer students
challenge to go into the education field
now for numerous reasons but salary is a
huge part of that puzzle yeah
representative Damon
thank you
um I perhaps should have asked this of
Representative Miler but maybe it fits
here
I'm wondering if there was any
discussion or consideration of
a situation so a teacher perhaps is
taught already for two years in a
district and and one that would qualify
and is now looking to move to a district
That Pays
ten thousand dollars more
is there any way for it to be built into
the bill for people in that situation to
have reimbursement for their first two
years that occurred before this bill
passes
I yeah I think so so I think that'll be
uh I think that'll be helpful in the in
the uh when I send you the different
ways states have structured these
because there are various ways that they
have done that including I think along
the lines of what you're referring to
sort of retroactive uh yes yeah thank
you
yes represent Tanner thank you
um I know this is a money incentive and
and it's really good but
um how much of a money incentive
keeps teachers at a school versus the
culture of the school and how they're
treated and in general how the teaching
profession is viewed in in New Hampshire
we had a
a speaker here I don't know if you were
here before when he was talking about
how you know the disrupting the
education system every way you can and
um
going after teachers with various uh
bills that that he mentioned
um does that affect teacher retention as
you know do you think do you think it's
a balance with the the money I mean I
wasn't in teaching for money
uh absolutely I think it does
um you know
it's uh
uh
many people obviously have gone into the
profession knowing what the salary uh
prospects are as a public school
educator
um and do it for many reasons
one of the things that we've seen
Nationwide and in New Hampshire and as
as we you know survey our membership is
the percentage uh of which are
that has increased in thinking about
leaving the professional together or
retiring early and a lot of that does
have to do with the environment yes for
the for questions
thank you very much we don't have any
further thank you cards so we're going
to close down testimony on this here and
we're going to break for our lunch
and let's be back here
how much time you need
one o'clock one o'clock is good
thank you
yeah we're gonna go do the scheduling
yeah
no what we'll do on 529 we're going to
take some time on the 13th
and well we all scheduled Maybe
a work session or something where people
can go different directions and work in
different things and we can go talk
we've got a quick second on Friday
morning 577. yeah one and a half two and
a half yeah yeah
because
yeah but I don't want to vote against it
but yeah because it's a thing that
really needs our attention
you can see how that looks like
significant
you know
yeah
please thank you
thank you
let's fill us up here right now five six
three is that yours can you open it up
and do it
I got uh Lindsay's trying to find a bill
out there tonight
435. okay absolutely
go ahead don't open her up and I'll be
in as soon as I get in okay
foreign
I think we're back for lunch and uh
we'll try and uh get back on schedule a
little bit
um and um first on the docket uh for
this afternoon will be House Bill
563 relative to the adoption of school
administrative unit budgets and I see
the prime sponsor representative sellers
coming to the microphone
thank you
keep going and skip
foreign
good afternoon uh committee and thank
you for the time to speak John Sellers
Grafton 18 representing Grafton 18.
um this bill is uh it looks long and
wordy and but really it's it's pretty
simple it's it's all it's trying to do
is take you have a budget for a school
budget and all I want to do is overall
is take the SAU the administrative part
of it and put it into a separate warrant
article so as you vote on the budget as
a warrant article they want to put the
SAU the administration unit or like the
all the administrators the SAU the
superintendent and all the uh
other folks there that make up the SAU
office right so it keeps that way they
can easily see you know how much is a
cost to me on the administrative side
versus how much it's cost me on the
actual School side
and when you have co-ops you know you
also have yeah maybe three different
saus that you're looking at uh and then
some districts like ours we only have
one SAU and it's not as a big a deal but
it's you know it's easier for anybody to
look in line by line to figure out
what's costing what
so that's that's one part of this the
other part is uh basically where am I on
page two here
uh if this is if anybody knows about
default budgets uh sb2 you have a
proposed budget and a default budget so
both budgets are presented the default
budget is there in case the proposed
budget never gets voted uh voted down
let's put it that way so the default
budget is always last year's plus or
minus
um adjustments at that point so that's
really what Essa the two is on page two
or four and then the last part of that
on page three or maybe a bottom page two
and Page Three it's just the process of
balloting and how that's going to work
make sure the balance of tracked and
given to the right person and so on
so I'm not going to stay up a lot of
time I just want to leave that with you
and I know somebody else is going to
speak to this as well
thank you representative questions
representative Balboni
hi thanks I have a couple questions
um because I I'm Pat representing towns
that have an SAU
um does this apply it says Spirit
districts without an annual meeting does
this also apply to sv2 tests
so I'm going to let the other person
speak to that because I I know there's
one part in here and I did read it and
I'll have to read it over again that
specifically says something about that
so yeah
and just
oh
yeah it's a separate card is that all
right yeah okay
um and you're essentially pulling this
SAU portion out of each town this budget
within the SAU and each and then it's
going to be voted on separately for each
Town what happens if it's rejected so so
that's the pot on page two here where
you have uh let's look at the lines 13
uh 14 15 16 right in there you know it
talks about the adjusted budget all
right at that point so you always have
the proposed budget and then the you
always have a backup budget which is
always the last year's budget no matter
what they always get the same amount
they actually worked with last year
bottom line plus or minus any
adjustments like if a one administrator
they said well we'll not keep an
administrator then that budget would be
down on the what I call the default
budget of these just a budget so there's
very little adjustments that go on on
that secondary budget at that point all
right the proposed budget is saying you
know it's the uh administrators saying
our you know the SAU uh superintendency
all right well we need a you know a
raise for this person this person this
person this person and uh we're also
hiring our new administrator to do XYZ
so this is our proposed budget at this
point say a million dollars but now the
old one could actually say the default
budget could actually say hey you're at
900 000 because that's what you well
that's what it took to run the
administrative part of the school last
year
does that make sense
yeah thank you
representative
thank you
um
I have two questions also the first one
is why do we need this bill
it's it's really for clarity it's it's
really making allowing the voters to see
how much the immediate administrative
side of the school budgets costing and
it's you know and like I said when you
have only one administrative unit uh
like a Nas yeah our district does it's
it's pretty easy to figure that out but
when you have three because you might
have three sau's all combined as a co-op
so it when you when you separate it out
like that now they're able to vote on
just the administrative side and just
the school side but no matter what they
both get an amount they they'll never be
zero
my my second follow-up yeah my second
question is uh also in those lines that
you are uh on page one I guess it is
um you know starting at 13.
um you have the apportionment at half
and half and a lot of the co-ops aren't
half and half on average daily
enrollment and equalized values so why
why in this one does it go to half and
half
so um
shall be based on half the average daily
uh membership and half on the most
recently available equalized evaluation
okay so look instead of me answering
that question I don't know the specifics
on that okay and I don't want to say
I I would hope to believe that it could
be all ADM or 50 50 or 100 you know at
100 so I don't want to answer that I'm
going to leave it to the next person
here so if that's okay sure that's just
not the way co-ops work okay
representative Damon
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question so on page two where you
were referencing the proposed budget
versus the default budget lines 13 to
18.
so what happens if communities don't all
vote the same way so one community may
approve the new budget that's presumably
more than the default budget and another
Community doesn't then
the funding of the SAU is compromised
yes I I see a point and uh instead of me
answering that I'm going to leave it to
the next person because he actually
deals with multiple scus within the
co-op mine's only a single so it makes a
little bit harder for me
I have representative woodcock thank you
chairman cordelli good afternoon thank
you thank you for taking my question
um I need to be totally up front as a
former School administrator this makes
me nervous
um because I see the isolation of
Administrators out there and sometimes
that has a difficult term with people in
the community and then but you didn't
isolate Athletics it didn't isolate
Learning Community he didn't isolate
Media Services he didn't isolate art and
drama the isolated administrators and
everyone else
and that makes me nervous for those
folks that are in the administrative
career track are working in the schools
that every time it's been well just kind
of ministry is kind of administrative
prime minister is versus look at the
budget and make a budget decision and am
I reading this right am I just am I in
the wrong Street altogether or is that
the intent well no I don't think the
intent are that way the intent is
realistically is to make sure there's
Clarity so all the voters can see how
much the administrative part of the
school district is costing versus the
school district you know the teaching
part and the operation of the school
district and I follow chairman cardelli
yes one thank you so why would you
isolate Athletics the media services and
have every every segment out there so
they can see very clearly what the cost
was
I would believe it I know as far as in
our budget we have about 1700 lines and
that's that
is a line item I can actually identify
okay so when you have three when you
have a co-op and you have three
different uh saus it's all together and
so you don't know as far as well this Au
SAU is this and that one's this one okay
all right thank you thank you Joe Kelly
any further questions
to see none thank you very much
representative thank you I'd like to
call Barry Christina
foreign
thank you chairman cordelli good
afternoon members of the community bear
Christina from the school boards
Association we are opposed
to House Bill 563. there are a couple
um a couple Provisions in the bill that
I think are convoluting two different
areas of law
um so for example I'm on page one of the
bill line 13.
I'm sorry I'll actually started at line
three it says at a meeting held before
January 1st this school administrative
unit board or board for school
administrative units comprising only one
district and then jumping down to pay
and I'll wrap this up I'll get to the
point and then pH third line 13 on page
one the provisions of this paragraph
apply to school administrative units
comprising two or more districts single
District saus are considered
um just single districts there's there's
no Provisions in in RSA 194c
that fully apply to single District saus
I'm trying to think Berlin is a single
District SAU Salem is a single District
SAU Manchester is a single District SAU
Hopkinton is a single District SAU just
to Dairy is a single District SAU
Wakefield is a single District SAU
Hudson is a single District SAU Concord
is a single District SAU that's trying
to vote no no you're with Dunbarton
these days so
um I I so single District essay used the
provisions of a the the SAU budget found
in RSA 194. C don't apply to single
district saus and that is in
194c3
194 C3 single District school
administrative units exemption single
district school district of units shall
be considered the same as a single
school district and shall be exempt from
the meeting requirements of this chapter
accept that they shall provide
superintendent super services pursuant
to RSA 194 C4 so the language in the
first parts of the bill we're talking
about this is what a single District SAU
has to do single District SAU has a
budget there's no SAU budget where
you're carving out the administrators
and the SAU staff and your special ed
director and things of that nature this
is also reaffirmed at RSA 1941a
this is the school district statute RSA
1941a single District school
administrative units as provided in RSA
194 C3 single District school
administrative units shall be considered
the same as single school districts so
um and you know and I'm jumping over
then to page two line eight paragraph 4A
excuse me the provisions of this
paragraph apply to districts with an
annual meeting oh then that would sort
of loop it back around to districts that
are a single District SAU that have an
annual meeting like the districts I just
mentioned save for Berlin and Manchester
where they would be doing this they a
single District essay you would I think
be having two budgets then which doesn't
make sense that's not what happens a
single District SAU has a single has a
single budget it doesn't carve out the
administrative costs you can do that by
looking at the line items within within
your budget that you'll have to pull
Post online and make public before your
public hearing
the other aspect why this bill nhsb
believes this is unnecessary I'm jumping
to RSA 194 C9
B and C
194 c9a has an alternative budget
procedure and a method of adoption where
if you don't want to just put it within
the SAU budget within your regular
District operating budget there's
Provisions in B and C RSA 190 I'm sorry
194cb
I'm going to start over with that I
apologize 194 c9a alternative budget
procedure and then Ultra and then 194
c9b alternative but also on alternative
budget procedure
um you the voters of the SAU can adopt a
provision where the SAU budget already
goes on to
your local District warrant article is a
separate as a separate article where
instead of just combining the SAU budget
in your operating budget it goes on as a
separate warrant article and the towns
collectively have to approve it so to
some degree that's what this bill is is
doing by saying you have to put it on
you have to put the budget on as a
separate warrant article for your essay
you want to have to be approved by the
majority of the voters within those
communities what the current law doesn't
have is the sort of default budget
provision but if the voters want to put
the D put their SAU Budget on as a
separate warrant article in their
communities they can already do that
they don't need the statute to do that
that's already allowed so those are
nhsbas I guess primary concerns with the
bill the the language in the bill about
a single district school district single
single District SAU having to comply
with these budget processes that's not
that's not how this works I mean there's
already a method in law that allows
voters to do this to put it on as a
separate warrant article and then vote
on it separately if they want so with
that I'm conclude my testimony I'm happy
to take any questions thank you
representative Myler thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for taking my
question I have two questions
one can you define for us what
administrative costs would be that's one
right and secondly can't currently if
somebody wants to know what the
administrative costs are in the
development of that once you define what
the administrative costs are can't the
budget committee at that point in time
then say okay let's call out those and
for those who want to know what the
administrative costs are then they would
be available I mean isn't that already
available two questions thank you very
much for the questions uh representative
Miler
um to one degree what I think I might
ask is I mean I'm not familiar with sort
of the dra
well I'm like in budget forms that
school board members have to put
together but so some of you might be
familiar with it is there a line item
for your SAU if it for your local budget
is there a linebacker for your essay you
want the dra form there may be there may
I don't know offhand you'd be able to
access the information that way so you'd
at least know aside from defining
administrative costs you would know this
school district the Bose school district
is paying this amount of money for SAU
services and the Dunbarton school
district is paying this amount of money
for SAU Services I mean you know I
presume an argument could be made that
all administrative Services would be
everything that your SAU
spends salaries paper clips Staples
toner some sau's rent space it's almost
often nominal you know like a buck a
year that town will donate some space or
whatnot so
um and I think I answered both your
questions representative Miler if I
missed one I'm happy to be here thank
you very much thank you
any further questions see none thank you
thank you
we've had one more person to testify
Eric power
thank you
thank you for having me uh education
committee you work really hard and you
have a schedule that is always goes long
for the record I am my name is Eric
power I live in Brookline I'm also the
president of the school district
governance Association I think I've
talked to you guys about it before it's
former and current school board members
and Buddy budget committee members from
across the state concerned about
responsible governance prudent budgeting
and educational excellence
I'm going to speak to you here a little
today about you know the bill the
motivation
um get background in the solution uh
first of all the history is that
spending a public education is rapidly
increasing Nationwide and in New
Hampshire
and a lot of the spending is on school
administrators it's driving much of this
increase
Hillsdale College president published an
article in November showing that the
number of Public School District
administrators from night from 2000 to
2019 grew 79 percent
but we only added nine percent more
teachers
so 79 more administrators nine percent
more teachers
um our state board of education member
Ryan Terrell did a union leading
editorial on January 2nd talked about
how the cost per pupil is Up 77 percent
adjusted for inflation but teachers
salaries are only up one percent
adjusted for inflation
the number of non-teaching staff
typically administrators is up 80
percent but the number of teachers in
New Hampshire is only up 23 percent
so I don't think we're at a risk of
having too few administrators the other
the other challenge is that
administrators are the highest paid
Personnel that we have in our school
district and many of them are in well
into the six figures
so the challenge is is that in many many
school administrators not all are
employed by the what we call the SAU or
the school administrative unit
these highest paid employees
um there's examples of how much they get
paid you can go to the Department of
Education site I gave you the link here
we have 10 superintendents in the state
that are making over 170 000 there's
actually one making almost 193 thousand
dollars
there's 51 assistant superintendents and
we have eight sau's that have two or
more assistants
so SAU Personnel growth and SAU budget
growth is a significant challenge
and we've had this happening despite
following student enrollment as you're
aware of from Department of Education
so if you have a background at most
annual district meetings
the SAU budget is part of the school
operating budget so it's generally not
talked about at a annual meeting the
SAU budget is actually uh you can find
it if you dig for it sometimes you can't
find it
um but the the where it comes from is if
you're not familiar with this process in
December every year
the the SAU board or the school board if
it's the single District
they approve an SAU budget
and that's what's being that's that that
becomes your SAU budget it's approved in
December besides those members that are
on the school board it's not modified by
voters
there is a provision for an adjusted
budget I'll talk about that in a second
so in multi-district sau's the SAU
budget is a portion to the member school
districts and I know there was a
question that came up about that the
current law is that it's 50 average
daily membership 50 equalized valuation
that's current law that's not being
changed by this bill that's the formula
it's the default formula for co-ops
that's what they use for SAU
apportionment if you want to call it
that
in multi-destrict sau's
so that the budget is then a portion to
the member School District so they're a
portioned part becomes part of each
School District's operating budget as a
line item
but the problem is you typically cannot
do anything about this uh as a voter
after that governing board sets that
budget in December it's pretty much
there you can't change it you can't zero
out as SAU budget line item and if you
do attempt to change that it can just be
moved around because that's the way
Municipal budgeting works
there is a procedure that was talked
about
um that is adoptable it's RSA
184c9b and a which is the adoption
procedure
that is only available currently to
multi-district SAU so you have to have
let me use an example so there's a
little bit of confusion on sb2 towns and
co-ops
so I'll use the example of where I'm
from I'm in uh I live in Brookline we
have a Hollis Brookline Cooperative
School District I was on the school
board there
we have a k-6 Brookline Elementary
District and we have a Hollis k-6
Elementary District so we actually have
three school districts two of them are
from the each town and actually one is a
co-op seven through twelve together
those three towns are a are under one
SAU SAU 41. so that's a multi-district
SAU
um
in each of these
each school district is free to adopt
sb2 or not and in our case the co-op and
the Hollis School District are still
traditional and the Brookline School
District is sb2
so that's kind of hopefully that
clarifies and we'll answer questions
more in that area so
we actually have adopted this procedure
and we use it so on every
current
warrant you will see an operating budget
and you'll see a separate SAU budget
an SAU budget that's proposed and then
we have the because we passed this and
it was not easy
we have also a what they call an
adjusted budget which is similar to the
sb2 concept of an of a default budget
last year's expenditures minus
adjustments
however so I mentioned this alternative
budget procedure is only available for
multi-discrit SAU so if you're in a
single District SAU you can't have the
budget pulled out you can't vote on it
you don't have the option of an adjusted
budget which I think is unfair to those
single districts for voters
so when you actually vote with the
alternative procedure at every district
meeting
you you it's a yes no question if it's a
traditional meeting it's a yes no ballot
at the annual meeting and if it's sb2
it's on the official ballot they just
count up the count up the ballots and
Hollis they count up the ballots in
Brookline and they count up the ballots
for the co-op they add them all up if
the yeses are greater than the no's you
have the proposed budget if the yeses
are not then you have the adjusted
budget that's how it works
and that's the current procedure so the
idea on this bill
going on to this is the SB 155 basically
provides this procedure to all school
districts
so that the essay budget's a separate
worn article
for all school districts it'll be on the
annual warrant so you'll have an
operating budget and you have an SAU
budget we have that now because we've
altered we've adopted the procedure
so I'm not doing it for my school
district I'm doing it for you know the
rest of New Hampshire that doesn't have
this there are a few school districts
that have adopted it
so the uh the seu budget already exists
so there's not a lot of administrative
work there's not really much more effort
the real only thing that would be extra
is determining your adjusted budget
that's really the amount of
administrative work that would be uh put
on saus for doing this if you're a
multi-discuit sdu you're already doing
the apportion because you have to so
it's there's nothing new there
uh let's see here
so there is one oversight that needs to
be amended to this bill to deal with the
case of the single District SAU and I
show it here down under solution
um it's 194c
colon 3 where we have to add in some
language that a single dish if we choose
to if you choose to pass this bill and
it becomes law it needs to have these
this statement here because it needs to
say that a single District SAU will have
a public hearing on the SAU budget and
they will adopt a budget and they will
conduct budget voting because right now
without that language they would not
require and I think you heard that that
from the previous speaker
so really the main reason we have this
is to really give voters a choice
and give more visibility to the SAU
budget because it's a challenge we have
we have a education spending problem and
you can see that a lot of it's being
driven by administrators they're not
doing poorly at all
so this gives the the voters in the town
in each School District visibility as a
separate worn article and also scrutiny
and the ability to vote on it so that
whether you're in a single District SAU
or a multi-district SAU
you can vote on your SAU budget and that
you have that say and help keep
administrative costs under control
so I recommend uh Auto pass with the
amendment
otpa on 563 and I'll welcome any
questions
thank you uh questions uh representative
luno
thank you very much Mr chair
um so and thanks for passing this around
and I noticed uh in the in the first
piece you talk about a report from
Hillsdale College presented by presume
an administrator the president
um there so you know maybe that's a
Superfluous position at Hillsdale but
but really wanted what I wanted to sort
of go after is some of the um the
rhetoric that that's been repeated from
Ryan Terrell's op-ed piece which which
is is was just blatantly incorrect but
but at worst misleading
um and um and you're signing some
statistics here and I just want to ask
you when looking at teacher salaries of
just one percent over a over a 20-year
period I I think that sort of blatantly
laughable because I think we've all been
through district meetings where where
collective bargaining agreed agreements
come up for vote every three four years
and uh and and so so you know that's
that's even even one of those collective
bargaining agreements at least as far as
the salary schedule is concerned would
be uh would be more than just one
percent let alone over a two decade
period but um but the question to um to
you would be do you realize that um that
not all teachers make the same and that
when a teacher towards the end of their
career May retire and maybe is replaced
by a teacher earlier in their career
that that newer teacher may be making
less money and would you call that pay
be paying teachers
more or paying teachers less
I'm not sure the relevancy of the
question to this bill but you know
teachers there's a pay scale I'm
familiar with that I served on the
school board so I went through that
whole process we have numbers of years
of experience and then educational track
and they make more money as they get
more experience as they move up in
education so the years it's a pay table
just like the military has Rank and
years of service you got educational
level and years of service so Public
School teachers I don't think are
getting as much pay raise in general as
administrators
and so you know the purpose of this bill
really getting back to what it's about
is really to bring visibility to the SAU
spending
um and we we certainly have seen that
it's a lot of money that's going on and
each School District can determine
um what uh is right for their Community
to retain their superintendent their
business administrator
and to be competitive but the point
right now is right now it's just the
school board that decides that budget
the voters don't have any input unless
you have adopted this alternative budget
procedure and single District saus have
no choice so you're leaving it up to the
five seven whoever in many school board
members are to determine what the
administrators are being paid so
follow up on that because I think the
relevancy of the question was was
challenged
um
and uh and obviously you must realize
that the uh that the relevant that the
the questions relevant because you bring
up the comparison of administrator costs
versus
um versus versus teachers because the
question is and so so the um so the the
question is
oh where's the question on on this um
and when when looking at the um at at
making that comparison uh where would
you put
um staff such as
um
paraprofessionals school counselors
Librarians
um uh as well as where would you where
would you categorize uh SAU expenses
that might include Debt Service or um or
uh or salary pool and things like that
would that be uh on the um on the SAU
side or on the school side
so sau's cannot own property saus cannot
buy property they have to get it by
another means so they don't really
what's in an SAU is primarily salaries
and benefits and some uh so I would say
infrastructure like I.T equipment and
such that's about all you're going to
see there the Hillsdale College article
is actually referencing Department of
Education data so that's where that came
from
so the school districts will have
administrators that are in the school
districts we're not breaking that out
we're just breaking out all of the
administrators that are in the SAU
and representative miler
thank you thank you for being here thank
you for taking my questions I'll ask you
the same question I asked before how do
you define administrative costs
what what does administrative costs is
what is in the SAU budget line item
today
that is that's defined in it's defined
on what what the people that are in the
SAU and their benefits and their pay
administrative costs there are
administrative costs that are part of
the school districts that's not broken
out this is just for the school
administrative unit only
so follow thank you so you're basically
dealing with whatever the administrative
salaries are and benefits that's how you
define Administration
that's the way dra defines anybody
that's working for the SAU office that's
not that's not a member of this not
employed by the school district there is
some Provisions for somebody who might
be shared between an SAU they might say
50 is SAU 50 the Brookline School
District then they have to save it that
way
represent Belcher
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
your testimony I think
you seem to be looking for
um information that might guide you to
inefficiency of some sort of the result
of administrative growth but my question
on that
is if if administrative
positions and costs are growing over a
period of time do we have any concept of
what degree or percentage that might be
linked to Federal requirements that are
things we have to have in order to
receive federal funding
that's a good question the uh I'm sure
that some of the requirements from the
state and federal government is driving
the size of the sau's but I think that
needs deserves to be scrutinized and
I've certainly done that where I live
you need to understand why are you
adding another administrator you know
for example
where I'm at our SAU
had
um nine people in it in 2007 and now it
has 19. this last count I had now the
and the population is down 15
so you know and we've we have the we've
had the alternative budget procedure for
a little bit a little while so I don't
know if it might have slowed it down
some but at least we have visibility for
example they they wanted to hire a
compliance specialist and that was part
of the the
proposed budget and it wasn't in the
default budget so anytime they add a
person they have to bring it in front of
the voters and they have to justify that
we need this person because we have some
federal program that we have to meet we
have some State program we have to meet
but the voters get the weigh in on it in
ark's case because we have that budget
procedure if you're in a single District
you don't have that choice so that's
that's that's the point there follow
real quick follow-up if we were to move
forward with something like this looking
to pull this information out do you
think it would be useful for us to also
know what percentage of these
requirements are being driven by federal
requirements
I think that would be valuable thank you
I'm just kidding back to the different
ways it it seems as though it's already
in the statute that multi-town districts
can do exactly what your District did so
why do we need this if it's already
available is this just pertaining to
single District
good question so adopting this
alternative budget procedure is not a
trivial matter
um
citizens had we had to put it on
petition in the three school districts
and then had to get it approved
separately in the in the three school
districts and then it became the same
year and then it became alternative
budget procedure
um
the school typically the schools
typically Administration don't like it
because it puts more scrutiny on so they
can actually put a warrant article in to
rescind it and that's happened
unfortunately unlike some of the other
things that we have available with
school districts and municipalities like
a adopting sb2 or adopting a tax cap
which we also have in Brookline
it's a 60 super majority to adopt and
it's a 60 super majority to rescind on
both of those unfortunately for this
alternative budget procedure it's 50 50
so it can go back and forth
very easily and it's not really an
advantage to the voters and it's
happened in Timberlane they had that
problem where they had it for one year
and the school administration had the
school board put it on and it was
rescinded the next year and if you don't
have a singles District SAU has no has
no opportunity
just follow uh just a quick follow-up um
but you keep referencing that the
illustrators are making the decisions
when it's actually the four might you
know
um SAU there's four towns with four
different school boards that make those
decisions correct
that's correct so they're influencing
the school board but it's it's a matter
of semantics so you know rsau governing
board has five from Brookline five for
Hall of seven from the co-op it's 17
members
thank you
represent there thank you do you have a
commute um citizen budget committee okay
we so for the SAU it's a complicated
question so uh the co-op has a budget
committee
the Hollis School District Hollis town
has a budget committee Brookline does
not we have a finance advisory committee
so there's no budget committee that
oversees the SAU budget if you're asking
that question that it's just a they try
to take a couple people they take
somebody from the Brookline Finance they
take somebody from the co-op budget
committee and they take somebody from
the hot the the Hollis budget committee
and they become an advisor but there's
no they just advise on the on the on the
SAU budget
does it follow yes um I thought you said
before one of your intents of this bill
was to make
the SAU administrative budget more
um available to the public and to the
voters and
um aren't they getting
with with the school board and the
advisory budget committee so that you do
have they could actually
decide about the weed it out and see
what the administrative budget is and
make some recommendations on that I mean
it isn't like
um it's all hidden in the budget nobody
ever sees it
um it it seems like there's citizens
that actually have the ability to see it
and and work with it I know on my budget
committee we're we're with it for two or
three months before it's put before the
community so I guess that's my question
don't you think that there's there's uh
people that do oversee the budget and
the administrative budget as part of the
voting public on these budget committees
yes so I served on a study committee I
was a chair of a study committee look at
adopting a budget committee on our in
Brookline so I'm very familiar with
budget committees we did not ultimately
adopt it unfortunately and I still think
we need to but the the point is is that
there's no real Authority there's
advisory Authority for people to look at
it and the other challenge is as I
mentioned the SAU budget is set in
December which means they're doing this
kind of ahead of everything else and
it's decided on I mean I literally it's
usually right before Christmas there was
two years be two years ago it was
between Christmas and New Year's so
there isn't the highest uh
availability of Voters they're not in
the mode of looking at budgets there's
just a few people on the budget
committee and it's an ad hoc thing so
it's not doesn't have the same scrutiny
but I you know in ours I've had the
benefit of having this budget procedure
so I've seen others that I've talked to
that they have to go dig for the SAU
budget it gets apportioned and then it
becomes a line item and they have no say
they do not have any ability to have an
adjusted budget and single District su's
have no choice at all they just leave it
in the hands of the school board and the
budget committee can weigh in on it but
they don't have any authority over it
okay and and don't they have a public
hearing on this where all those
information comes out in spreadsheets
I don't believe a single District SCU
has to have a hearing they're exempt
from it for the RSA right now the
multi-district sau's do have to have a
hearing even if they're an sb2 town
even if they're an sb2 town because this
is this is regardless whether you have
an SB well sb2
is really the wrong term because you
have multi-districts so there may be a
mix of sb2 and traditional it doesn't
matter whether it's SP2 or traditional
and some seus have a mix like we do it's
really
um it's just a hearing and then that
governing board makes the decision on a
proposed budget and an adjusted budget
if they have the alternative budget
procedure if you don't have that
current state of affairs is they just
set a budget and it is what it is and no
one can change it after that but just as
a problem but you can still you can
still get that information any any voter
could get that information
if the voters diligent enough they can
look for it and they can find it it's
not easy though I just looked in the
Nashua website trying to find the SAU
budget and I couldn't find it
single District SAU representative
Ellison uh thank you Mr chair thanks for
taking Mike two quick questions I'm
trying to clarify I think I heard you
say that voters have no say in setting
the SAU administrative budget is that in
my am I quoting you correctly they have
no direct say in that they don't vote on
it unless they have the alternative
budget procedure okay second question uh
how do people get on the school board
and they get voted in thank you
are there further questions
perhaps and leckis
thank you for taking my question
um I know when that report first came
out and I was wondering what all does
who all is an administrator and I ask
um that question and I said well and I
what I was told was well depends upon
how that school district qualifies them
for instance we have a community
outreach person it's that Administration
you know and so how it says some things
and it says teacher Consultants
what would be teacher Consultants with
the Dei person be a teacher consultant
so I'm wondering how that's determined
or if it's just these specific things
that you have written down here
so the question is you know what
qualifies as an SAU
um expense and that's not really
changing in this bill because that word
is addressing how it gets voted on
but
some areas are very distinct it's clear
a business administrator a special ed
director superintendent assistant
superintendent those are all
in the SAU office
then you get to some other things that
are in the gray area we had uh two years
ago we voted on a Communications and
compliance specialist that was going to
monitor social media
was going to help with right to knows
and it was a close vote but the the
voters between the three towns approved
it and that but they decided to put that
in the SAU that's really a a board
decision on each of the boards that make
up the SAU if it's a multi-district
where you put them and I believe the
subject of this particular bill this is
just voting really how you vote on it
for the voters thank you
represent Damon
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question it's the same one I asked
earlier about the speaker uh didn't know
the answer so
multiple towns vote differently some
If This Were to go through
some say yes to the new budget some say
yes to the default budget then how is
the SAU funded
so that's a good question so
as I mentioned before every
say in my example we have Hollis
Brookline and the co-op
and yes no vote is conducted in the
co-op they count the ballots they report
them to the next meeting
Brookline votes sb2 we count those
ballots that they get added in Hollis
has their district meeting if they're
the last one for example they count the
yeses and the no's who's ever at the
meeting and the yes if the yeses are
more it's not if Brookline passes it and
the co-op doesn't and Hollis does it's
just the total that's the way it is
today in the alternative budget
procedure the the alternative budget
procedure is not changed that's as part
as part of this bill that's what exists
today it's just a tally of the S's and
the no's and that's how it works thank
you are there further questions
thank you very much
uh is there any technical support we can
get uh Barrett
on some of this discussion so that we're
we're dealing with
accurate information
or maybe how you see it
those can be one of the same
um
the statement that that
okay let's put
a single District saus do not they have
an SAU number that's assigned by the
Department of Education there is no
separate SAU office an SAU in a single
District SAU what would otherwise be
your SAU staff your superintendent your
special ed director assistant
superintendent B.A
admin assistance those are School
District employees all right those are
School District employees I'm going to
use SAE I'm going to use representative
halls I say you because it's the
simplest form SAU 67 bow and Dunbarton
two school districts sharing
administrative services that
superintendent is not an employee of the
boat School District that student
donbats Don Barton School District that
superintendent is an employee of of SAU
67 I believe the number is right two
school districts forming together to
create another political entity at least
her right to know law purposes budgeting
purposes things of that nature there was
also a comment that a single District
SAU that you you you can't pull out the
administrative services that or there's
no opportunity for the public to to
participate or something a lot or
every school district whether or not
you're a co-op a single School School
District a single School District SAU
and a co-op multiple uh
SAU town you have to have a budget
hearing under RSA 32.
and the public has a right to comment on
that budget I'm looking at the
Department of Education I'm sorry the
Department of Revenue Administration the
their their account codes
instruction this is the 1000 series
regular programs special programs
vocational programs Support Services the
2000 series student Support Services
instructional staff services
executive Administration line item 2320
SAU Management Services
line 2320-2399
School administration Services
2500 through 2599 businesses and then so
on and so forth student transportation
student Support Services I mean
if you want to know how much
superintendent is making you call the
SAU and ask the other aspect too is
we've got to be be clear that if we're
talking about a single District SAU we
need to Define what administration is
because your principles are
administrators they are not part of your
SAU though they are not part of your
central office with your superintendent
and your business manager and your
special ed director they're employees of
the district Beau High School has a
principal not an SAU employee Don Barton
Elementary School or whatever it's
called has an elementary school
principal not an SAU employee
and one other aside if we're worried
about having too many administrators
representative Lakers has a bill that's
going to require districts hire five
more administrators to implement those
Improvement plans we're going to need
curriculum coordinators and other
assistant superintendent and two more
principals just to get through it so I
don't the the notion that I mean first
of all the whole single District SAU
multi-district SAU I talked about that
but just because you're in a single
District SAU doesn't mean the voters
don't have the opportunity to look at
the money
it's all public life that you file a
right to know law requests look at the
dra forms go to the budget hearing ask
your business manager ask your school
board chair for this data and
information
thank you thank you
I'm sorry for my tone I apologize but it
just it it you know I apologize for my
tone but thank you for indulging me
well we appreciate the information
representative cardelli thank you but I
think the sponsors
um uh intent was to make it a separate
worn article so that that information
was readily available to the
um to the voter rather than going to the
uh dra codes Etc
and going to all the budget hearings
thank you
thanks for the question I'm sorry go
ahead I'm sorry
um that was my understanding of the
intent so you do not think that the uh
intent is uh needed in this case thank
you very much for the question
representative rsa194 c9a each School
District with a school district unit
that is composed of two or more
districts and they vote to adopt the
provisions of RSA 194
c9b to determine the means for adopting
the school administrative budget by
placing the question on the warrant of
the next annual School District meeting
the question shall be voted on in
accordance with the ballot and voting
procedures in effect in that school
district and then it lists the the the
the
um the language of the of the warrant
article that would go on the warrant if
the voters want to do this and then it
lists a whole bunch of other stuff in
that paragraph
rsa194
c9b in a school administrative unit
composed of two or more school districts
which has adopted the provisions of RSA
194 c9a the administrative unit budget
adopted the adopted according to RSA
194c9 shall be placed before the voters
of each district of that school district
of that I'm sorry that school
administrative unit in a separate
warrant article at the annual School
District meeting notwithstanding RSA 32
colon RSA 32 and RSA 40 colon 13 the
budget adopted by the school
administrative unit board shall not be
amended that's similar language there's
a provision and law that allows voters
to do this if they want this those SAU
budget to be on a separate warrant
article in their local town they have a
a there's already a provision in law to
do this
are there any questions representative
Tanner this may be a comment that having
been on the budget committee if we asked
at one of the meetings for them to give
us the at the next meeting all the
administrative costs we would have it
right so I I don't know any school
district that if you ask that as a
budget Committee Member or as a school
board member that you wouldn't get it
representative Luna
thank you very much Mr chair actually
Hopkinton is having its um it's a budget
meeting tonight
um I I think it's at six o'clock at the
Town Hall and this is under RSA 32. uh
are you are you are you sb2 or two you
must be traditional no we're traditional
okay traditional so it's the it's yeah
right and I'm looking at the um at the
the budget packet
that that the superintendent puts out
and uh you know it's about 50 pages long
and everybody Picks Them Up I know on
the board for a thousand years so I know
that everybody picks picks them up in
the and the meeting's pretty well
intended and towards the you know it
sort of starts with the big departments
and goes down to the smaller groups and
um sort of getting towards the end
administrative Services office of the
superintendent
um uh 23 20 23 32 25 10 25 11 25 15 I
think right account numbers that are
common in all district breaks it breaks
it right well I guess this is a would
you believe
um breaks it breaks it right out so
voters can see so in harmony
um you wouldn't need to do a 91a request
that's right it's
excuse me it's right there that's the
proper way to do it so that's what we
would advise our school boards to do
right that was the question do you
advise school boards to do that we do
thank you thank you thank you are there
are there Furs or further would you
believe type questions
not hearing any thank you very much
thank you very much Mr chair for
allowing me to come back up you're
welcome
are there uh for the cards we have that
was it okay we're going to close that
hearing
it was a
which one's up next 3.4
52 452.
there's
um
are there any other cards
for most things
thank you
next we have up uh House Bill 452
relative to the Department of Education
procedures for school building Aid
applications
and uh call upon the prime sponsor
representative
thank you very much chairman cordelli
and members of the committee for the
record my name is uh Rick Ladd I come
from Haverhill which is a single Town
Co-op in a multiple SAU and
it's really different
um 452 is a bill relative to the
Department of Education procedures for
school building Aid applications we
previously had this year a bill that
dealt with the dollar amount allocated
for new construction as you remember our
renovation projects you recall that was
50 million dollars on top of the debt
then we had a bill come in which dealt
with the 10-year plan and encouraging
districts to put forward their where
they're going with building construction
or requests for building a renovation
projects so that we as a legislature can
better prioritize and plan for our
future in terms of appropriating dollars
this portion right here is really the I
would say the guts of school building
Aid and if you have your um
uh bill in front of you let's take a
walk through it so that rather than uh
trying to read something I'd like to
just walk through and and take you
through it the way we work with school
building Aid is that the state provides
support and depending upon the the
various conditions within that
particular town you might get 30 percent
State support you may get 60 percent but
when you receive your money the grant
that's awarded to your town you will
receive 80 percent of that dollar and
that's right there on line 10 on page
one you'll receive 80 percent right out
of the shoot and upon you're getting
towards our upon completion of the
construction and verification that it's
it's it's done the way it's supposed to
been done by the department then you get
your other 20 of the Grant from the
state state
and we know right now there's been what
three grants approved tentatively until
dollars are available and all that we
were looking at Rochester we're looking
at Colebrook and looking at the
Monadnock area
going down on line 16 you can see in the
application process that if you have
received other other dollars for this
outside of uh the grant or outside of
what you're appropriating locally like a
charitable trust a bequest I guess
insurance policies and I I did receive
that when I was a school principal over
in in Maine where I received a
tremendous gift a petroleum company a
person died and gave us all the stock
and and that was a real benefit for a
small town like Belgrade Maine
um going on down to uh line 19 you can
see where it says eligible construction
projects shall mean project designed to
be energy efficient that's a a critical
need that we uh have not always had in
our legislation looking at Energy
Efficiency so that we really are
encouraging the the the savings of
dollars as you operate your building
going forward
um going down uh eligible areas that
your money may be used for are there on
lines 22 down through lines 30 on that
first page it's for the acquisition of
property and I I know that Amy Clark's
here and she can describe that a little
bit more for you when we get in there
but the acquisition of property the the
existing building is whether you're
going to renovate it or if you're going
to do substantial renovations to a
project
um
Etc it's all right there it also gets
into a lease purchase of materials
whether you're getting into mechanical
structural things HVAC and if you don't
cough up the dollars or support that as
you're getting the project on page two
you can see that the vendor can take
that back
um on line seven we're talking about
um the department shell issue annually
maximum eligible cost standards some
people have asked me what are the
standards that go behind uh this the the
size of the building this size the
property the location all that yes these
are standards and Amy will talk about
that she's the engineer she knows how
the update this information on an annual
basis is based on I believe national
standards
going on down further here you can see
let's see um when you're looking at the
size of standards and construction of
buildings we take into account when we
talk about the the area uh the maximum
growth square footage per pupil that is
specified in the standard
and there are some school districts want
to come and build the Taj Mahal and
they're not going to get you know that
money for their their huge building
they're going to get it according to the
standards up to that certain point then
they want to go beyond and that they
want to have a a 600 seat theater with
Orchestra pit and all that in
which I had in Alaska brand new building
and and uh but uh they're gonna have to
pay for that themselves we have 52 drops
on stage as well so it was a huge huge
Community Building
um going down the the commissioner of
the Department of Education can waive
some of these based upon certain
conditions uh that's on lines 3132
um
going on yes the approval of plans
specifications and cost construction
purchase
um
the the district will definitely look at
your your uh site plan in terms of
schematic design the the department I
mean the cost estimates and other items
that are maybe it needs to know in this
application maybe like what's your
demographic population looking like it's
going up is it down you're projecting
where that's going to be
um those are the challenges that you
have to be prepared to answer in your
application going on a page three
uh there's a timeline which the timeline
which we've had right now has been very
very difficult for for the Department to
really scrutinize these applications in
a way that it's it gives them the time
to uh do what's necessary to get out in
the field to ask the questions see the
facility
um and then go from where they get the
they receive this application they are
expected to rank order these
applications in terms of the criteria
and the standards which we have the
criteria
and once they've done that and they've
looked at things like the mechanical
electrical Plumbing structural
components of the building proof of
annual school budget to support good
maintenance and
it would go on the rank order sheet
would go on to the school building
authority now School building authority
is a an organ we've had that in statute
for a long time it was not initially set
up to do this particular task of
checking out and looking at these ranked
order applications that come to them it
was initially set up to see if the
bonding power of the state was there
whether the finances of the school
district are there to support what
they're obligating themselves to get
into the school building authority in
the case of reviews is there's three
people on this this Authority appointed
by the governor one is uh you has to be
somebody that deals with engineering and
knows buildings Architects Etc another
person has to be an education oriented
person has understanding of policy needs
curricular instructional needs within
the schools the other person has to be a
understanding of Finance you might get
somebody that's a really an account or
somebody that knows uh dollars the other
three people on the uh the the school
building authority are the state
treasurer
the commissioner of education and the
fire marshal or the Fire Marshal's
designee
uh so the timeline I'm going to let Amy
get in the timeline a little bit because
we used to have the applications come in
on one July and we had to have them out
through this through the rank order
process by the department to the school
of building authority which would look
at that they had the they had the
ability to re-re-rank the applications
came from the doe if they use the same
criteria as the doe had used
and that's an area that has been an area
of discussion here for the last couple
years is that they come all ranked
ordered from the Department the
application there and then the other
group sometimes wants to rank or based
on different criteria
um so that's an area where where we are
looking at I would say we have to have
the same criteria these the school
building authority can should look at
the bonding ability and the finances yes
once it comes back from the school
building authority and if everything
checks out it goes to the State Board of
Education for approval so July 1 had to
be out in the hands of people are
receiving notice that they had an
application that's going to be approved
by January 15th you can see that's a
very short time frame in there
especially when Christmas vacations in
there it's just impossible to do this
properly so Amy has suggested and the
department start to put this timeline
further out I'll let her get into the
explanation of that
uh you can see on page four there the
commissioner at the Department of
Education shall accept School building
construction proposals based upon
completeness when that application comes
in and these are some of the the
conditions which are looked at from one
through nine there so on page four those
are the conditions we're looking for
notice that there are some uh like
condition seven we put that in most
recently looking at the project
contributes to operational cost
efficiencies
consolidation and reduced property taxes
we used to have years ago a five percent
increase for skill building Aid if you
got high performance
um uh projects in your building high
performance in terms of saving energy
um and and saving the dollar that came
out but this this report right here this
bill right here still is looking at high
performance and seeing that as a vital
area when we rank order these each one
of these areas has a number of points
and the point systems added up and
that's so it's not very it's not a
subjective process of which well I think
that this school a is a little bit
better than D down here selling them
it's not based on that it's based on
this understanding of where they are in
terms of these and some of these get
more points for example health and
safety Fire Marshal issues would rise to
the top security issues help raise the
top although we have been able to help
with the public school infrastructure
fun money funny funding to to address
some of those issues in a separate
imaginary area
um
going down to the bottom part on this
page four here
applications with substantial
deficiencies as defined by the
Department of Education School
construction rules may be ranked ahead
of applications received at the prior
fiscal year
that has happened we've had some come in
here that haven't been ranked but have
real substantial issues that need to
jump ahead of
this whole process right here is that so
we award these grants out in year one of
the biennium the second year
or the do we let projects in the second
year jump ahead of those which were on
the list for the first year
and there is a question which we asked
and and
um or just the order that was on that
first let's stay like that and you can't
jump unless you have this real
substantial issue to jump ahead of
somebody else
um there again this is a topic which
we've had to really look at and I let
the department answer some of the things
right there the last part I'd like to
address in page 34 of page four
we used to have
um the project start and we had the
person who was the clerk of the work so
if you're familiar with the terminology
so Clark is the one is supposed to be
there supporting the district
oftentimes we've seen some projects the
clerk of the works been owned by the
contractor or the subcontractors
and we've had a lot of change orders the
change orders of course change the value
of the cost of that building and then it
results in somebody else having to Fork
over this these additional costs and and
I I've been in a number of projects
where I've seen change orders come up
and the amount is extends well into the
millions of dollars and we could avoided
some of that if we had a positive Clerk
of the works a person trained as an
engineer overseeing this and it was also
bonded so that they are this is their
job you don't have somebody that's been
on your staff that's the chief
maintenance person come and say you're
going to be in charge of this building
project a lot of districts have done
that in the past and they've gotten in
trouble like they did in the middle
school I was in up in Haverhill where we
had no Clerk of the works at the time
and of course they've invented the art
room out the lower level up and into the
attic and we lost the roof not more than
20 years 15 years later through rot
um that should have been changed and it
noticed it wasn't
so that walks us through what we're
proposing here we're looking at a real
overview and and a rewrite of the whole
building School building uh aid program
uh which it it drastically needs we we
have this thing we call the tail right
now and the tail is absorbing half of
what we have for school building a and
when you look at the list which we just
received the 17 projects on that list do
look at the fourth one which is
conquered and the state share would have
been 70 million dollars that's more than
we're allocating for the whole biennium
so we're seeing buildings coming at us
that we're going to see how many
buildings may be built in the period of
two years it could be one
depending upon you know the the building
and the nature which it might be if it's
a 30 percenter it's going to be a huge
amount of dollars these new high schools
are up close to what 100 million dollars
more
uh much more and and so uh we've got to
look at this whole process and we have
to ensure that we are really rank
ordering and recognizing those projects
which really need to be there
there's a lot more I believe we have to
do this on terms of other types of
facilities leasing buildings we need to
look at that the pot of money where
these pot do we break pots out for
renovation do we bake pots out for
Capital new construction
those are all questions
I'll take any questions and don't forget
we got the technical people behind me
and thank you representative miler
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question so you've indicated
uh Rick in your testimony that we've got
three grants that have been granted
for 2023 correct that's correct and
you've got well there they they're
depending upon the money you're right
yeah I'm gonna get to that uh this is a
series of questions if you don't mind Mr
chair uh and you'd indicated that there
are were 17 requests for Grants correct
that's what I understand okay and how
much money I mean we've been around this
since you and I've been on this
committee for 11 years has a major
problem how much money do we have right
now that or as this is being proposed to
be budgeted for these three Grant three
grants that are going to be out there as
well as the tail
okay if you're if you're talking about
the 10 I'll just use Brown figures here
I don't have that the finance sheets in
front of me but the debt for each one of
those years if you total over to it for
the the two years of this biennium is 50
million dollars approximately and we're
allowed to appropriate 50 million
dollars each year of the biennium
so when you take half of that that's 100
million dollars for the biennium but you
know that half of that's already being
used to pay debt off that leaves you
just left the 50 million bucks
for new construction or renovation
projects thank you very much for the
questions representative Tanner
do we ever get federal funds
particularly with the new infrastructure
Bill for school building Aid
not for school but we have had monies
that came down through these Federal
stabilization I like to call them
dollars
um astronomies and all that you can use
it for HVAC and we know that's occurred
we know that's occurred for things maybe
like Windows uh but it's not for the
brick and mortar
um so that is the school constructions
basically and you you have to recall
that we've gone through a little it's
about a 10 year more time it's a little
longer than that since the moratorium I
I Amy maybe it's only about six projects
which we have approved
so during that time there was no
construction going on other than what
the local school districts were doing on
their own and we've had a number of
bills that come to us where the those
that did it during the moratorium are
trying to get reimbursed what would be
their estate share uh Unfortunately they
did not you know they haven't complied
with a lot of the timelines and the
conditions within the school building a
program so at this point in time we just
need to move forward
and try to make the program work the
best way we can and hopefully we can
make some changes here which are going
to streamline it so that we can have
more time in which the the district
itself has times to get things time
enough to get it on a warrant article
find out if the talent's going to
support that Grant we've unfortunately
had some towns that on the Career Tech
side that have refused to take their
money for the capital cost for the new
CTE program and they've it went down the
tube uh so uh there's much to this I
hope we can do something here
um this is what I call the fourth leg of
the stool School uh Construction and
building is it does matches right up
with correct curriculum instruction and
labor costs we have to have the
buildings yep
representative Woodcock thank you thank
you Rick last year do I recall or in the
last session that we did deal with the
clerk of the clerk of the works bill
yeah I think it's almost like two years
ago it was a while back was that and I'm
looking at 34 specifically is that
already in that's that's already in law
and we're requiring that we have that
knowledgeable person on board that's
okay so that's not a change no we're
that's still required thank you yes
um I had a question
um
I'm a little confused between Roman 2A
on page three and uh to be on page four
in that
um 2A on lines 19 through 23
approximately it talks about
um uh the commissioner accepting the
applications based on completeness and
building a preliminary list
and then submitting the ranked list to
the school building authority
but then on B over on page four it talks
about the commissioner accepting the
proposals based on completeness okay Amy
yeah so I don't go around the bar the
the school building authority has to
have that out earlier now in this one
you can see the date is October 15th
before it was the end of this or in
December and so we're trying to backing
everything out so far you're looking at
the those some of those criteria for
ranking first the the areas which were
you know doing on on the next page on
page four which we use a lot of that
information for that signing the numbers
like that it used to be 275 points I
don't know whether it's the same Amy now
or not
um and each one's had different amount
of points okay to rank order based on
that criteria one through nine okay
maybe I'll follow up with Miss Clark
yeah yeah any further questions thank
you thank you
Eric power
I don't see him
Amy Clark from the Department
good afternoon
for the record my name is Amy Clark and
I'm at the Department of Education I
work for the school facilities Bureau
I'm the administrator for the school
facilities Bureau and the school
building aid program falls under my
Bureau so mostly I'm here for technical
assistance but I did want to walk you
through I do have a handout that walks
through the timeline
and just I want to point out some
important pieces to this language that I
just want to make sure is clear
okay
and so if I think you all probably have
it
um on the first page is I tried to mimic
what the current law currently does for
a timeline and the second page is what
house bill uh 452 does to that timeline
for the most part to me anyway for the
most part this bill is about the
timeline I think representative Ladd did
a good job of walking through the bill
but for the most part A lot of those
pieces as representative Woodcock
pointed out a lot of those pieces are
there they're just kind of reorganized
uh in a uh easier fashion to process but
the real meat of this bill the big
changes in this bill is really the
timeline in which schools apply for
building Aid
well I think it's probably best
um if you'll allow for me just to go
through that timeline the existing
timeline
so I'll do that so on the current law so
this is currently how a building aid
application is processed and again just
for reminders building Aid is just a
state aid for the construction of large
construction projects we're not talking
about a room renovation and new
carpeting and a new roof uh and changing
out windows we're talking about a
rebuild of a new school maybe you're
consolidating to schools and building a
new school perhaps you're putting on an
addition or perhaps you're gutting the
building and bringing it back up to new
condition and that's what we call a
substantial renovation project
so what happens
um
keep in mind that this is all before the
state budget is approved so the dollar
amount is unknown to school districts
first they spend a couple years figuring
out whether a school construction
project is something that they want to
do I think that's really important to
understand that people school districts
are not talking about this over lunch
one day and just decided that they're
going to build a new school these are
many years of planning before they even
come to my office
so when they're ready they apply for
billing Aid by January 1st every two
years the state has a biennium budget so
they come in January 1st they submit a
letter that they intend on applying and
that comes in 18 months prior to the
state budget being approved
um
from there they then actually fill out
their full application
um by July 1st which is 12 months before
the state budget is approved
so in this particular case if you think
of the state budget hopefully being
approved July 1st of this year the
application applicants that you may have
seen on that application that list of 17
they actually applied last summer in
July so that's how that timeline worked
out for them
so July 1st we get a bunch of
applications on our desk we review them
as the Department of Education we spend
about four months July to October
reviewing those applications we do site
visits it's a it's a very thorough
review the applications are hundreds of
pages they include lots of documentation
important documentation engineering
reports Mechanical plumbing structural
reports things like that
um by December 1st the law requires that
the school building authority
um well the department of education
education then ranks those projects
based on the criteria that are really
that are in the law right now and the
proposed bill for the most part fairly
the same uh and then by December 1st the
school building authority reviews the
department of education's ranking
verifies it and submits it to the State
Board of Education for approval and
State Board of Education by law is
required to review and approve that
ranked list by January 15th January 15th
is now about six months before the state
budget is approved
by March
um schools still don't know whether the
state budget is approved but then if
they want to construct they have to then
go to their Town voters without knowing
if the state has any money for school
construction so then they get a warrant
article ready and they don't really know
whether State funds are going to be
there but they put a warrant article
together for March which is about four
months prior to the state budget being
approved
okay now of course you have February
Town meetings April summer cities and
some operate differently but for the
most part that's what a lot of
communities are doing
by July 1st we have a state budget that
could be currently there's not a minimum
amount of building Aid so that could be
no money or that could be 50 million
dollars somewhere in between
um
now interestingly construction projects
don't work on fiscal years so by July
1st a school district has found out that
they're going to get building Aid
they don't have a contractor sitting
there waiting for the governor to sign
the budget on site and it's and they're
going to be able to put a shovel in the
ground in July so they really lose that
whole summer and most of the projects
that unless they're building on a brand
new site it might be easier for them but
keep in mind most of these projects will
be substantial Renovations or additions
and they have to move kids around so
summer is a really important time for
schools to be in construction so they
for the most part have lost that whole
summer and will probably start that
fiscal year and sometime maybe March
April May I'm starting to do some
preliminary work
so that is the current process and it is
repeated every two years
so what house bill
um 542 does
um is this is the different this is the
new timeline same planning goes on
but instead
um the the bill requires that schools
apply by April 1st
three months prior to the state budget
being approved so this is jumping way
ahead of the existing timeline then the
Department of Education reviews uh those
applications just like normal all of the
stuff is the same process
uh by July 1st then the budget is
approved
by August 1st so we're not giving out
that money right away we're kind of
holding it we're holding it waiting for
those projects to be finished ranked
they then go to the school building
authority by August 1st then they go to
the State Board of Education by November
15th then towns go to uh vote in March
and then they can begin construction
that spring summer whenever they are
ready so the big and the other big
difference is then we repeat this every
year so that schools aren't having to
wait every two years
so the key differences if you're going
to sum all of that up the key difference
is this house bill does
is it first it creates an annual
application process instead of every two
years now it's every year
um which interestingly
means a lot to school districts if you
tell them they have to wait two years
it's like forever but they can
understand next year that's okay just
seems I'm that way too one more year
comes and goes but two years is a long
time to wait
um then um House Bill 5502 also ranks
those projects after the appropriation
is known and the current building Aid
ranks the projects in schools are
essentially waiting their Community is
waiting to figure out what they're going
to do
uh House Bill uh 542 also publishes the
list the school the State Board of
Education publishes the list in November
instead of January and anybody writing a
warrant article for a school district
knows that having an understanding of
what funds are going to potentially be
available by November versus January
15th is a lot more difficult
and then lastly I just want to point out
that I already kind of mentioned it but
houseboat 552 also allows for a more
efficient construction schedule again
you're not losing that whole summer
which costs increase a lot of um that's
a lot of frustration too because the
town voted on it yet you're not even
able to put a shovel in the ground until
much later waiting to see if the state
can award any funds so with that I guess
I only I the only other thing I'm hoping
I can spare your time on is just
pointing out a couple of the things that
the bill does that um
um I think may need some attention
and and it's probably my fault but I'm
gonna say for something for you to
consider uh would be for process wise
looking through the bill
um would be that you may want to define
a school district if you look on page
and I'll pass these comments along too
but um on page two uh school district is
defined in the current law and there's
existing language and it hasn't carried
over into this bill and again I know
that I've reviewed this bill and that's
probably my fault for not catching that
earlier but number one you may want to
Define school district
and number two on the top of Page Three
foreign
S one and two it talks about projects
with approval from the local school
district's legislative body to construct
not subject to receiving building Aid
this is essentially telling people who
can apply and I don't think that's the
intent there so again it says
um that essentially a school can apply
for school building Aid I don't think
that the intent is for schools to see
receive legislative approval prior to
applying
um but I may be wrong
uh and then lastly that same comment
something you may want to consider is on
page four
um it talks about
um when you stay on the list and line
line 27 and 28 on page four talks about
also schools would get bumped off that
list if they didn't receive District's
legislative body approval so essentially
if the town says no you get booted off
the list I would I would say on my end
process wise they're just going to apply
the next year and we're just gonna have
to redo their application so I would
probably prefer that they stay on that
list if you wanted them to only stand
that list so many years that might make
sense although the Department of
Education has the authority to make
those rules um and we could
um we'll be doing rule making if this
passes anyway to meet all these
timelines and we would include it in
that area so that'd be another thing to
consider
and then I think that's it unless you
have questions
yes reps
thank you
um thank you for answering my question
I'm trying to understand the whole
process
so
the
the town knows whether or not they're on
the list
before they go
to vote
but if they vote down and the next
number two on the list votes down and
number three
so you keep being bummed up so do you
put then to make sure that you're let's
say You're Number Four
and you figure we haven't got a chance
because we're number four but the top
three don't go now you're on so are you
putting on your ballot the question just
in case you get it and can you write in
on your ballot on your warrant
provided the town the provided the state
gives this money we approve this that's
very good question so under the current
process that's one of the complications
that school districts have to face is
they don't know whether other schools
have passed or not because that's not
done until after the budget has been uh
approved uh and they don't know what
other towns have done so
um there are towns that are further down
on the list that don't know how much
money is going to be available uh and
don't know the the fate of the other
Town votes so they are putting they are
at least considering putting on two
Warren articles and that also presents
challenges but just like you said they
some schools are looking to go with
contingent warrant articles and other
schools are just going to hold off and
wait to see what happens that's legal
for them to do that I believe so only
because that seems to be what some
school districts are doing thank you
very much
foreign
yeah yeah I will
represent Miley
thank you Mr chair and thank Amy for
being here sure uh so if I have this
right
we've had 17 projects that were
requested
three were funded
and that basically took up the 15
million dollars that was available
uh not including the tail expense that's
there is that correct
um not not technically
um so the ranked list is a ranked list
and it sits there ranked one two and
three right but what we don't know we
don't know how much money is going to be
appropriate for building Aid so assuming
you're right in the assumption that the
um that building is fully funded which
means a maximum of 50 million dollars in
Aid is given each year there would be
enough money to fund those top three
projects however those top three
projects have not voted yet so we're
waiting to see so to say that they've
been awarded money is definitely not we
Department of Education would never say
that because one no money has been
appropriated for new projects uh a
budget is in not been signed and then
also the towns have not had their votes
at so all three could fail and it would
go down to others kind of similar
presenting some other problems not
problem good problems but some surprises
so if if one of the three they don't
pass in their town meeting or whatever
then it does then go down to the fourth
one that's on the list correct correct
that money is appropriated the way I
would look at it is it just happens to
be 50 million uh minus the tail gives
enough for the for the top three
projects but really money is offered to
that first ranked project if they pass
their local funding piece and if they
can they take whatever award their their
application is for and then it keeps
moving down until we run out of money do
we know what the as you monitor this do
we know what the budget proposal is for
building Aid and the pending budget
um well not for the pending budget
because I've not seen it yet but what I
can say is if building Aid were fully
funded which when we use that term we
mean the law allows a maximum of 50
million in Aid so 50 million was
appropriated in year one of the budget
in year two of the budget and that
passes and signing a law on July 1st
then after we pay all our debt for old
projects and then our state Bond debt we
would have 49 million dollars left for
the biennium for new projects and that
would allow us to offer the first ranked
project money and if they accept would
be enough we'd have left over to offer
number two if they were able to accept
we'd have enough to offer number three
and we would then run out of money and
finally if I heard you correctly
this is an annual request so in other
words those 17 we don't fund all of them
obviously do they then if they are still
in the queue for
requesting again they have to do that on
an annual basis that doesn't hold over
for the biennium
um they have to do it in a our list is
for the biennium and the current law
would require that they apply again in
the next biennium unless they have their
District's legislative body approval and
they did not construct okay so so it's
for the biennium that the that the
grants go through there correct the
request correct thank you very much yeah
you're welcome Carson represent cordelli
thank you
um could you speak to the letter of
intent and where that fits into the
process
um with the proposal
um correct it's missing um on purpose I
mean you you could so what the letter of
intent the current letter of intent is
one sheet of paper that school districts
fill out the superintendent signs it it
says we intend on applying for building
Aid and what we have done is we've
um used we my office of one has use that
to plan for what's going to happen in
July and it kind of like oh how many
applications am I going to get we were
coming into this as a fairly new process
this is the third time we've ranked
projects the first time you have to
apply 18 months ahead of time so those
first round were applying during the
moratorium which you know they were
crossing their fingers really tight and
they got really lucky but most schools
didn't put resources into applying the
second biennium that they were to apply
their deadline for application was July
of 2020. so obviously pandemic brand new
so that list might have been a little
short too and then this last time is
really probably when we got the first
round of applications I guess the reason
saying that is the letter of intent
really helps me planning it really I
think I spent more time talking to
schools about all they needed to do it
for me it's just not worth it to have
the letter of intent but if it was added
in there schools could certainly give me
a heads up that they're intending on
applying I just don't know if it would
do anything it didn't add value
further further questions you have a
follow-up yes please
um uh if you have
um let's say four or five projects and
the available money is used up
um for the most part by the top three
but then there is some money left over
for uh project number four but not what
they need really are they better off
taking what's available then or are now
waiting until the next year to resubmit
maybe being high on higher on the list
so currently the process is we obviously
we can't promise money we don't have so
when we run out of money let's say we
had a million dollars left and we can
offer it to that school and they can
take it and run and that's all they're
ever going to get is that million
dollars or they can apply the following
biennium
um that's if depending you know that's a
it's an individual little decision I can
see why schools would say yes and no
depends on how much money it is
construction costs Rising every year and
whether building Aid would be funded
it's quite a gamble to pass up on a
million bucks I imagine but then again
some schools wouldn't be able to
construct with a million dollar Grant
when they're seeking a 30 million dollar
Grant
thank you further questions represent
Myler do you have your no no okay you
got your mic
so thank you Mr chair and I'm not sure
if if um if if the question's really
directed to 452 or maybe the next bill
which I think uses
um the exist is based on top of the
existing language as opposed to the
language that could be amended by 452.
but
um but 452 does
um
does contain uh language on page one
lines 14 15 which which are from current
law with respect to uh building aid for
um uh for a chartered public school and
um
and I guess the way the way 452 is
drafted how would it work
um if a chartered public school was to
submit an application for building Aid
according to the schedule and I think
this is a really good improvement over
over the um over the existing lot which
is sort of tough to read right but how
would it work for a chartered school
application and then you know as as it
sort of enables it online it's 14 15 on
the first page and then how it would go
through the application process and the
ranking
um as as defined on page four and in
particularly lines 12 and 21 where in
factors in a school district's fiscal
capacity
um based on measurable criteria how that
would apply and then line 21 any other
criteria that the State Board of
Education made May determine is
necessary how would all that work for
Charter application I guess in view also
of the um the federal grants that um
that the fiscal committee has accepted
for um for Charter Schools over the last
biennium and um
and uh and as we've seen some Charter
Schools dissolve what would become of um
of a um of a capital asset that was was
funded at least at 30 percent with uh
with State funds I know there's some
some uh Charter dissolution bills not to
force Charters into dissolution but to
clarify what would happen
um you know in those events what would
happen
well those are lots of questions
um so so how how does it work for a
charter to navigate right so currently
charter schools are not eligible for
building Aid not because of the building
Aid law but because of a charter school
law that prevents them from applying to
building Aid and I'll be up here again
for your next bill as well
um but
um
so this really just targets the the
timeline but when I actually started my
position
um which was in 2015
um it clearly says in the building Aid
law that charter schools are eligible
for building Aid because it gives grants
them 30 eligible funds so for this bill
that wasn't changed it's in the existing
law
um should the charter school law ever
change they would be eligible for
building Aid uh and uh but as for the
ranking criteria
um
are I'd have to review our laws our laws
are no I'm not sorry not our laws are
um construction rules to see the
construction rules more defined more
clearly about the ranking but that is
actually something we should probably
take a look at because we haven't been
looking at it at the eyes of charter
schools because we know that they're not
eligible for building Aid
um but certainly it's an easy fix on our
um on our Regulatory and not in the
state law
and then I'll follow up on that does
does dissolution factor into either um
either you know recovery of assets as
far as as far as the the building aid
program or the charter
um
that's a very good question so
um the the building Aid
um law has a penalty in it it's in a
different section but it essentially
requires that school district charter
school would have to use the facility
for 20 years
um uh or more or pay the whole thing
back now that's a pretty hard ask when a
school is closing down
um usually for lots of
um economic reasons and so forth
typically
um so
um what the Department of Education has
withheld funds for those projects but in
our current
um
tale we in our old program prior to 2013
when we were building all but five
schools now are under this other side of
things where we were paying uh on the
bond for 20 years a portion of their
payment so what we have done is on those
projects that have closed for the public
schools that have closed we've just
stopped paying them the building Aid so
if they remained open 18 years we would
have just not paid them year 19 and
you're 20 on their 20-year Bond
um it certainly was easier to do that
than this model of paying 80 up front 20
upon completion then at year 15 asking
for you know a quarter of it back
um it it is um I acknowledge that would
be a difficult conversation the law does
say that those school districts are
required to pay pay it back
um and I know last year's that Charter
School bill again maybe I could talk
about this more in the next bill but the
that Charter School bill that's being
heard after this there was certainly
some concerns about dissolution like for
charter schools because they might be
closing more frequently than public
schools
um and I I actually think the bill does
a good job of addressing that okay great
thank you very much but this bill does
not it's really
um if both of those bills were to pass
then these two would obviously have to
merge together
because they're both 198.15 right
represent cordelli you recognize for a
question thank you
with the 80 percent
being paid up front and 20 upon
completion at this point
um is that a better process for the
state and for the district than
spreading it out over
a period of time 20 years let's say
well I guess I can just give me you my
opinion on that ultimately
um we can work with whatever process
that you all uh decide on I have heard
back from school districts that you know
you have to work through the tail and
there's a lot of pain working through
the tail because nobody feels like
there's enough money because we're
giving it away to past projects but I
think for the most part
um a lot of savings comes to the
taxpayer comes to the school district if
they are getting 80 percent of their
Grant up front uh and the only time it
seems beneficial is when you're further
down on the list and you really wish the
money was spread out
um I I think most school districts if
not all the school districts that I've
talked to that have received Aid I mean
there's a big savings in getting
multi-million dollars and not having to
bond that amount and not have to pay
interest on it for 20 years
for the
receiversary representative yeah thank
you very much
um Mr chair right along that that same
line of questioning that representative
cordelli um just asked you know that's
we've we've gone from a uh a 20-year
amortization or 20-year payment uh plan
which I think was consistent with a lot
of the um uh the bonds that that school
just would use to finance their portion
of the or to finance the construction
costs uh to uh 80 uh you know 80 20 all
of it you know essentially up front and
um and and obviously um there would be
some savings you know in terms of um you
know interest costs that that you know
you know would accumulate over over over
a 20-year uh period
um but you know then again a lot a lot
rests on interest rates uh you know too
and um and and
and and so when we when we went to that
like you as you've said
um it now limits the number of projects
we're able to go after in a year you've
talked a little bit about how many
projects are in the um you know how many
applications have have been um have been
submitted but uh but let's sort of you
know looking down the road you know over
the horizon a little bit further
um how many how many school buildings do
we have across the state and what's
their average you know and it may be
sort of like an engineer you know a
little bit of back in the napkin what's
their average age and how many do you
think we we may need to um to how many
projects do you think may come up over
the next decade
uh that's a great question
um we have
um we have looked at like what I
consider a sustainability snapshot and
trying to think of like what is the big
picture and if you look at the life of
the a building
um being 40 to 50 years we have 450 or
more
um schools and
um if you just base I mean I can kind of
take you through those numbers because I
have my cheat sheet here
um but if you just look we have 450
school buildings roughly we have about
165 000 students so we're already
talking about decline the enrollment so
this is the number of students we
actually have you can place a cost per
square foot and a a space amount per
student and you come up with
um 23 million square feet on average 550
dollars a square foot you come up with
about 12.7 billion dollars to
to construct all our public schools at
once right obviously that's not
happening they are lasting up to 50
years 40 to 50 years so if you take that
number and divide it by 4 40 years you
come up with about 318 million dollars a
year so I guess that's probably the
number you're looking at 318 million
dollars a year now that's not the state
share if you apply the state share of
our average share is 38 so that is let
me do that math real quickly and I had
the 30 A's a hundred and uh let's see 21
million a year for the state share
um so you know
um again that's a very rough number uh
and that would be spread out over over
over 40 years you could do that
calculation with 30 you could do it over
50 years or so forth but regardless of
all of that if you just took only
because I can do this math in my head a
lot better if you took
450 schools and said they need to be
rebuilt every 50 years that's nine
schools a year right 450 divided by nine
that's nine schools a year so a biennium
that's about 18 schools a year so our
previous list of 17 is probably what
we'll see over time I wouldn't be
surprised if we see a little more in the
next 10 years because we had a 10-year
moratorium I'd say if you were to look I
think New Hampshire should be really
proud of this personally I think if you
look prior to 2009 from the 1940s all
the way up to 2009 before the moratorium
the legislature funded based on need and
so our schools are in really good
condition
um up until 2009 but you know that there
were schools that were getting ready to
apply because they had older buildings
and those are probably the schools but
they didn't because of the moratorium so
most likely there'll be a little bit of
a blip but
um big picture when not talking about
always brand new schools we're talking
about substantial Renovations sometimes
too so so
follow up on that so so you said 17 over
biennium about nine a year would would
make sense and um and and I think
um it was either your earlier uh
testimony or or maybe uh maybe
representative Ladd's uh testimony that
that suggested under the current budget
we might be able to
I mean Concord Scout is one of the one
of the applications and that could use
up the entire you know the the you know
the entire bucket here and um and so in
one biennium that would be that would be
one project leaving 16
not funded
and two two years from now we'll have
another batch of 17.
coming coming in and so so is is this a
a situation that that that that that
develops and compounds because of the 80
20 the the the the paying all of it up
front as opposed to something where
we're able to chip away at more of these
projects over a 20-year
um
yeah I think that's a good question for
you all I guess I would just point out
two things they'll always be more coming
there'll be some you get like what
you're saying is true if there's not
enough money they'll create a backlog
but some school districts are going to
move forward with their projects without
stating they have to
um somebody asked earlier about jumping
the list the department of education's
rules do allow uh projects with higher
Life Safety uh points to to jump on the
list
um so sure there'll be a backlog I'm I I
don't know as if funding them
um over a 20-year
or I'm not sure it really matters the
the funding mechanism they'll always
you're either going to create a tale or
you're going to create a backlog
um
okay all right so thank you very much
okay further question well reps and like
us had her hand up for several times
here thank you chairman
um back to a couple conversations ago
when you were talking about
let's say we did those schools and there
was a million left
and I'm wondering what happens to the
million if the school's coming after
that are all like no we really need the
30 million
um does that can that can we apply that
million then to the tail do we just lose
that million we don't appropriate it
what happens yeah it's decided during
the next biennium budget so what you
can't do is you can't take that and
apply it to the tail because school
school districts don't have the ability
to pay those bonds off early because
it's gone but that money so this last
biennium that extra money was about
seven hundred thousand dollars and that
rolled into the next but the next budget
cycle so it added to the building Aid
appropriation is what they decided to do
that biennium what we can't do
um because some people would say well
why wouldn't you just have given it to
the school to so they could have started
it but what we don't know is if we'll
get any more and obviously the school
district needs a guarantee that the full
30 is coming right right thank you yeah
good question and I um sorry I have to
um just bring up a point and I don't
mean to pick on the Concord School
District
um but
um the list just keep in mind that the
list the amount of Aid that is being
asked for on that list is simply the
building Aid percentage times what their
project cost is the Department of
Education has yet to apply maximum
square footage per pupil maximum
construction cost per square foot so
um I guess I wish that I had those
numbers for you at this time but we
review applications from the top and
work through and we're I'm through like
three applications now so that detailed
review will eventually come for them
they're aware of what that number might
be as well as other applicants on there
but just keep in mind you know if a
school were to build a larger Auditorium
that the state wouldn't pay for that's
not going to show up on the list until
we fully review the project and say oh
this piece is not eligible for building
Aid I guess I'd just like to point that
out because it is a big ask I think we
understand that okay
representative thank you um just one
clarification with the uh the 80 20 any
split now does that mean in the new
money that's going out there will not be
a new tail
rex that means once this tail is gone
and that's going to be when 2041 2041
however keep in mind 2041 10 years
before 2041 2041 when's that ever going
to happen
um uh they'll Replay that in 10 years
I'm sure or how many every years
um but keep in mind that's because of
just a few schools had 30-year bonds a
bulk of the tail really gets paid off by
2029 2030 and then it gets really small
it looks you know according to my
numbers it's probably below
um two it looks like it's below uh 5
million in 2030. so so but no new tail
thank you so that's a new slogan there
no New Deal
are there further questions
representative Woodcock thank you
chairman good afternoon everything a
little while ago a couple hours ago now
but a little while ago you you were
talking about the 80 20 and the default
um and the payback on the default how
how often does that happen in uh in the
last 10 years the school system has
actually defaulted on their lawn and
gone out of business
well uh Berlin just closed Brown
Elementary School I can't remember if
they had building Aid
um Hallsville School of Manchester just
closed they were receiving Bill the aid
um
um those are the two that I remember
most recently so it happens but it's not
it's not frequent and a lot one of those
schools I can't remember which one was
at like 18 years since they received
building Aid thank you thank you and if
your default in that 20-year time since
you got that money guess who pays it
back
the district
to the state
so Rick yes just a quick comment I think
addressed to representative miler's um
no new tell uh type of thing
um
bonds aren't necessarily bad and tail
isn't necessarily bad in this um in this
type of case because these assets are
durable and and last as you said over a
period of 40 years so in this case all
the assets are actually going to have a
have a lifespan of of 20 years in excess
of the um the the
um the last payment if there were a
20-year sort of amortization of this I'm
not a financial analyst so I'm you know
and neither am I not gonna whatever you
decide
but I think I'm good but but I just I
just want to sort of put it out there
that I think it is worthy of a debate
um uh you know taking a look at the
number of projects and the impact on
taxpayers and the fact that you you're
basically funding the creation of an
asset that has a lifespan that's or
usable design life you know double the
the payment term and um and you know as
as I think you've made really clear Amy
there's there's a lot of need that's
going to be that has built up and will
continue to build up and uh and it might
be it might be valuable to see like how
this would model out over over the next
40 years let's say if we were doing an
80 20 versus a 20-year type thing how
many projects would we would we be able
to go after what would the cost to the
state be what would the cost to local
local taxpayers
um be because I think local taxpayers do
receive a benefit when um when when they
when they receive a building Grant from
the state whether that's 80 20 or you
know
um uh a um you know four percent a year
over or five percent a year over 20
years and
uh you know especially if if it means
that in some instances a lot of projects
are not going to receive a state Grant
so so I I'm just requesting that just
remember what our debt was back in 2019
540 million dollars but that was a
different tale that was when the state
took out its own we are borrowing from
yes so so there's really two tails two
tails yes here yeah and and so I'm just
sort of saying that it's not that I
think we are we are on the Department of
Education we'll process you know the the
time this bill focuses on the timeline
for us just to process it whether it's
80 20 or their tail mechanism really it
doesn't really impact the Department of
Education
um in the sense of we will review these
applications as sure but from a policy
perspective that you know in this room
it's it's two very different policies
one more card in this too so I want to
thank you Amy very much for working with
us on this uh your help is always
appreciated
um and I'm sure you'll be part of our
discussion here when we have further
discussions on like somewhat 30 for
everybody
you know that's another discussion so
I'd like to invite Eric power up
goes over to her problems
good afternoon education committee I'm
going to be brief
I support this bill money again for the
record I'm Eric power I'm from Brookline
I was a civil engineer in the military
so I construction is near and dear to me
so in the 17
applications that were put in
four of them came from my our schools
two from the Hollis Brookline Co-op and
two from Brookline for all our schools
that need the help and they were ranked
14 15 16 and 17. so we were the bottom
four so the reason I bring that up is I
think that you know having this
opportunity every year instead of every
two years is a good thing
um so I also think you need to look at
the I think it was mentioned by the
previous speaker on page three about the
contingency Warren articles I think you
need to allow a school district to be
able to do that to be able to approve a
warrant article contingent on state aid
being available
um because that so you probably caught
that one already the other thing I
wanted to mention on this is you know
from a taxpayer perspective this is
different than a a bond that you get the
state aid over 20 years
so there needs to be transparency to
taxpayers when they're voting for a bond
saying yeah this is only going to cost
you a nickel per thousand using the 80
and then the 20 that you're getting
kind of like you know you're only going
to pay a little bit the first couple of
years but when the full amount kicks in
after the the whole 80 20 is kicked in
however long it takes one two three
years here's what you're going to pay
and so I think we need to have caution
or you know some explanation from the
Department of Education or dra to make
it clear this is different than the past
this is new that when there's a bond
proposed and they say well the tax if
there's a tax impact notation and it
just says yeah it's only a nickel per
thousand but it turns into being 40
cents per thousand when it fully kicks
in people need to be aware of that so I
just wanted to bring that uh that point
up I don't know if it needs to go in the
legislation or it's somewhere else
and lastly I think the Improvement is
good for this because having it every
two years
is a long time in construction and with
school needs so having it having this
bill go to every year I think is a
really good thing
um and I and I like the improvements
that I've seen in the criteria in this
bill and this bipartisan bill so I would
recommend Auto pass with Amendment on
this Bill thank you very much thank you
very much other questions uh Miss power
now see thank you very much
are there any other pink cards out on
with that we're going to close this
hearing
and
okay the next fill up is
hb354 354. uh this is relative to
Charter Public School eligibility for
the state school building aid program
and with that representative Mooney you
are the prime sponsor welcome thank you
very much
okay and then
before that yeah okay
uh three five four oh maybe we have that
3.4
foreign
okay
thank you Mr chairman and good afternoon
to members of the committee for the
record my name is representative Maureen
Mooney I'm from the town of Merrimack
that Hillsborough County District number
12. I'm here as the prime sponsor and
speaking in support of House Bill 354
and act relative to chartered Public
School eligibility for school building
Aid I'm going to do this in three points
three points to summarize this bill
first and foremost this bill simply
allows public chartered schools the
ability to apply
apply for school building Aid like all
the traditional public schools in New
Hampshire can
just recently as I was sitting on my own
committee house finance we had the
Department of Education in front of us
and I asked them Direct
our public charter schools the only
Public Schools excluded from applying
for school building Aid
the answer was yes
0.2
House Bill 354 is applicable to only
only those public chartered schools that
own their own buildings
there aren't many but it is for them
on page one of the Bell lines 14 through
17 there is a very important section
there it's Roman 2 hyphen a and that
section was drafted and crafted based on
discussions in this committee when I
proposed a similar Bill last term it
makes it clear that the public chartered
school applying for the aid shall own
its own building and shall be subject to
a plan for disposition according to
current law
the grant payment is also spread out
over a typical loan term
and set in law at 30 percent of the cost
of construction for chartered schools so
they are capped
but that leads to point three
and very important well they're all
important but this is important too
House Bill fee 354
corrects a glaring contradiction right
now in current law
currently there is a provision of law
that prohibits
public chartered schools from receiving
aid
and yet
the section I just referenced there's a
section on Aid
actually referring to quote the amount
of the grant to any public chartered
school shall be at 30 percent of the
eligible cost of construction
well which is it you've got a contrast
of one provision of law says they do not
receive Charter Schools do not receive
School building Aid and cannot apply for
it and then you have another section
that says they get 30 percent of their
construction progress project
Side Story
we had a bill just recently we heard in
house finance and the Department of
Education was proposing it it was to
hire somebody to re-codify the education
statutes because they are unclear and
somewhat contradictory
you'll never guess which example they
gave for this recodification position
it was this
the fact that in one section again it
says no building aid for public charter
schools
and then in another section of law it
says they can but you know up to 30
percent
in conclusion School building Aid is
defined on the New Hampshire Department
of education's website as quote program
authorized by RSA 198 call in 15 hyphen
a through which the state of New
Hampshire provides financial assistance
to local school districts for the
construction or substantial renovation
of educational facilities for grades
K-12
the passage of House Bill 354 will fully
complete
this definition
and clear up discrepancies in current
law
by adding chartered public schools that
are and continue to be significant
contributors as K-12 New Hampshire
public schools with that I conclude my
testimony thank you and thank you all
for listening thank you very much are
there any questions from the committee
yes representative Miler thank you for
being here and thank you for taking my
question how many Charter Schools own
their own facility
The Unofficial answer from what I know
is about two or three thank you very
much
further questions
representative uh Cornell Thank you for
taking my question we earlier heard a
bill asking for more money for Charter
Schools per student and they charter
schools are having a difficult time
raising money paying costs and I'm just
wondering how they would raise the money
to pay their portion of the of the
building
construction if they're having a heart
attack because I think when Charters
were first okayed it was that they would
they agreed to raise a certain I don't
even know what the percent was or if it
was ever put into law what percent but
when we asked them I think most of them
said that it was a very small percent
that they were now raising on their own
good question I would imagine that they
would raise as they have been now we do
have individuals here associated with
several Charter Schools who might be
able to give a more expansive answer but
I would say uh continuing what they're
doing now in terms of fundraising
represent cordelli thank you just a
point of information in terms of owning
uh building uh Charter School proof
Charter School in uh our area is in the
process or they've submitted a bid and I
understand it's the only bid to purchase
an Old Courthouse that is owned by the
county
and they plan to renovate it by taking
out a mortgage
further questions from the committee
thank you very much
um Mr chair and uh and and thank you
very much representative Mooney for
bringing the sword
um to to at least to your understanding
how many um how many charter schools
that I don't mean this in a in a
disparaging way at all it's just the
question
um how many uh charter schools have
dissolved and what would happen to real
property in in those cases
thank you
uh thank you for the question so
dissolved over time I don't know I mean
I know one recently within the last year
or so very close to Concord here if not
in Concord did
uh but over the course of Charter
history I do not know someone else may
though that's number one and um with
results with regard to dissolving that
has to be in their Charter as I
understand it so there's a plan for
dissolution
in the charter application when a
charter files with the Department of Ed
and the Board of Education
follow-up is is that currently spelled
the dissolution plan are those
parameters currently spelled out in
statute I believe there is a bill this
year that that that goes that
um that is directed to uh to this but
was wondering if is it if it's currently
spelled out
thank you I don't know the um if it's in
law however I do believe that the
department of Ed does give parameters
and guidance in terms of developing a
charter and it would the idea would be
laid out there
if I could too Mr chairman the
contradiction in law I would like to
just spell out the two rsas if I could
for everyone to be able to get a full
understanding of that so where it says
Charter Schools do not get school
building Aid as RSA 198 colon 15. hyphen
B
Roman one
or I
lowercase a
number two
uppercase C
as for where it says they get 30 percent
of their projects is the following
RSA
198.
colon 15 hyphen B
number two
number one
uppercase C
thank you
further questions from the committee
yes representative Cascade
thank you for pointing those two rsas
out
and this is a question that I don't I
don't know so
it's not intentional that it's facetious
but if if Charter Schools receive
building Aid would they be responsible
also to do all of the data reporting
that public schools do I don't know if
they already do them I'm talking about
asbestos management air quality
Emergency Management plans doe 25 ms25
school safety all of those requirements
I mean I interpret them as uh
accountability and Tran you know being
able to account for everything that we
have
do you know of charter schools public
charter schools have to complete all
those data reports as well
thank you for the question my
understanding is as public schools yes
they do okay
thank you and those reports like any
others would be online okay thank you
have you looked at the the school
building I'm sure you have uh the the
law which we went through on 452 198.15
Etc and where it identifies that funds
received from charitable trusts bequest
gifts insurance policies federal grants
or grants from other state programs are
subtracted uh from the total project
costs uh for public
schools
in your case the the public school has
taxing Authority through their District
you don't have that as a charter school
so you're going to need to be able to
use those
gifts charitable gifts etc etc etc uh in
in your your cost of your project is
that correct
or are you following my line of thinking
here
I am and to get to the Crux of that I
have not explored that that was your
question you explore and look at so that
there
it's something I think we need to look
at yep
Point well taken but I myself in
preparation of this bill did not take
that angle thank you it's just reading
the fine print all through both these
like you know I think it was represented
pill that's putting forth the
codification and we're seeing that in
numerous areas in the statutes numerous
where one says one the other says the
other
further questions of Representative
Mooney
thank you very much
um the next is
Bob best uh Bob do you have to get out
here
okay good I know we're closing in on
that
thank you very much Mr chairman and
members of the committee my name is Bob
best I live in Merrimack New Hampshire
um let's see I am on the board of the
founders Academy as the chair I'm on the
board of spark Academy as the treasurer
I'm also an attorney at Solway and
Hollis
um I support this bill and I hope that
you do too it's very very important for
charter schools to be able to access
this kind of Aid up until now there's
about 33 existing charter schools in New
Hampshire I was just counting them on
their website I hope I didn't miss count
and Miss anybody
um I I think that there are very very
few that own their own buildings but
that's sort of the outfall of the
regulatory environment that's always
existed when the charter school law was
first adopted Charter Schools couldn't
borrow money for their first five years
of existence and so they couldn't buy a
building because they couldn't get a
mortgage and so they would create a
foundation and get private donations or
find some leasable space on the market
and try and work their way through that
and that that law had been amended so
now they can go to the bank and borrow
money
um and and try to acquire their own
buildings but it's obviously very very
difficult for them to do so so by and
large they are
created with the private donations and
and sometimes least and least with very
friendly terms from people with our
interest in school choice
um when we were here uh last week
talking about
um per pupil aid for Charter Schools I
talked about how
um the current rate is something like
forty dollars per student per day and if
that bill would have passed it would be
50 per student per day and I think if
you did some quick back of the napkin
math and see what does it take to run a
school you'd see there's very little
left when you pay teachers and books and
lights and computers and all of that for
the building itself and that's why they
relied so heavily on private donations
and you know uh what a blessing it is
for us to have the food the kind of
people that are there to support those
kinds of schools and make those kinds of
donations but at the end of the day
charter school students are public
school students just like any other
public school students and we should as
a state Embrace and and take care of our
Public Schools I know there's been a lot
of discussion about the ownership of the
buildings and what happens to them if
the schools fail
um it's charter schools are are the only
public schools that are sort of really
subject to that existential threat of
failing being it's because of the you
know the prep people Aid at 40 or 50 per
student
um if you uh uh have anything that comes
uh along the line in the course of a
year that's unexpected run toward it
could really tip over a charter school
and do it pretty easily whereas the
regular public school has other means to
manage that situation
um and so Charter's Public Schools can
fail they haven't terribly frequently
but it has happened
um but having building Aid would take
one of the biggest threats away and
that's the cost of the building that
they they have to uh incurate today and
so it may help in that regard and this
bill does deal with the notion of what
happens to the property if they do fail
separate from that separate from the
entire department of education and all
the education laws these charter schools
are all formed as non-profit
corporations in New Hampshire and every
non-profit Corporation in its Charter in
its articles of organization spell out
what happens to their assets that has
nothing to do with being a school or
anything else it's just being a charity
in New Hampshire you spell out what you
do with your assets and typically the
response is that they're contributed to
as a an organization with a similar
errors like a mission as possible now
this would be adapted a little bit based
on guidance from the Department of
Education under this bill
so I tried to quickly cover a few of the
questions that I've heard come up but
really I just want to express the strong
support for the bill it's very very
important for the continued existence of
charter schools and for school choice
that they have access to this building
Aid because the building is
um aside from the the staff and teachers
the most expensive element of trying to
deliver charter school for some Founders
Academy's building is is well over five
million dollars and that's not
particularly
art school so these are Big expenses
that have come from
kind-hearted people but these are public
school students and public schools so
that's all that I have and I got in a
minute or two if you had a question but
maybe you don't we got three or four
minutes here folks any questions from
representative
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
being here so one of the questions that
we dealt with earlier was the issue of
viability of a charter school to raise
money to to purchase a building so could
you uh tell us uh tell the committee
please how what is the percent of your
current budget in
the founders Academy and Sparks that you
do raise through fundraising so uh for
both schools it's very small it's a few
percentage points I'm not sure exactly
what it is but I if it was five percent
I'd be surprised it's probably one or
two or something like that now when they
raise money for the building that occurs
in the planning phase and sometimes
before the charter application is even
submitted somebody has an idea of how
they're going to solve the problem of
getting a building and um and you do
that through who you recruit to be
involved in the effort and what you
think might be available in the universe
but that's a one-time effort uh in the
in the Journey of a charter school and
like Founders Academy is now nine years
old or something eight years old or
something so that was I wasn't part of
the original formation of the founders
Academy what went into that further
questions
thank you very much thank you thank you
for letting me um uh be the first one up
and get out of here you're welcome
uh Kim Lavallee
thank you
good afternoon it's good afternoon thank
you for being here and listening giving
me a chance to speak my name is Kimberly
Lavallee I'm from Mount Vernon and I
currently sit on three Charter School
boards and two foundations that were
created over the last I must say 12
years at different periods to support
Charter Schools through a lot of
volunteer efforts
if I can I I am in support of this bill
but I would like to try to answer a few
of the questions kind of going around
the room if I remember them in order
regarding reports we don't file every
single report that traditional Public
Schools do but we file most of them so
all the ones that you listed I believe
we file I went through I was trying to
remember back in the day so those are
done yes
um there's been questions about how will
charter schools be sustainable and able
to raise money their share of it towards
these repairs if they qualify for
building Aid we currently have to find
that money because we have to make these
repairs I spent a summer looking for
loans to put a six hundred and seven
thousand dollar refund we're not looking
for millions and tens of millions and
hundreds of millions charter schools are
typically smaller facilities and I've
been involved in the renovation of one
which was a five and a half million
dollar project we were very fortunate to
have a benefactor on that way back when
um but maintaining that building we have
to fundraise we have to find the funds
we furnished it with or I'm sorry I
expanded it with another I think it was
8 000 square feet we had to raise the
money for that we had to find it took
out a small loan for it as well the roof
another 607 000 two loans plus donations
so we have to find it anyway regardless
the questions are asked but the repairs
need to be done if water is pouring in
your ceiling you have to find the money
to fix the problem
they've been doing it and they'll
continue doing it building Aid would
make a huge difference
let me just check here
um there was conversation about the
dissolution statements I looked one up
just an example and this is an old one
but I'll just give you some general
language I know the department of Ed has
definitely beefed up their requests on
these but this one has language that
starts with should the school seize
operation or have its Charter revoked by
its authorizer the board shall consult
with an attorney in the Department of
Education
to assure that contractual and financial
obligations are met so these are schools
that
are approved by the state we have to
figure out what we owe and pay it back
so the statements today the solution
statements today that are in the
charters are much more comprehensive and
focused on how those funds or how those
assets will be dissolved and where those
funds will go I think that's something
that this board could have a
conversation about or this committee
um let me look
and that's what I've had that's what I
had for notes to try and answer anything
that was outstanding are there any
questions
from the committee
I've got one for you
um so we've heard that there's two
possibly three charter schools which are
are owned uh not not through rental or
some but they're owned uh are those
buildings when they're looked at by the
department of education do they meet all
the the standards that we would have
within our building aid program right
now do they you know idea stuff uh do
they have you know the square footage is
necessary for the classrooms
there's so many different standards
engineering required standards fire
codes building codes all that do I can
answer
to Fire and Building Codes because I've
been through those inspections and in
the planning process with several
schools that were renovated I don't
believe and Amy may be better able to
answer this I don't believe we are
subject to the square footage
requirement
we're not required to adhere to the
square footage per pupil Etc
okay thank you
further further questions from the
committee thank you thank you
next card is Eric power
hello uh Eric power uh president of sdg
I live in Brookline and our organization
supports this bill
um
you know
I in our recent uh in the recent ranking
we came in the bottom four places I
mentioned in a previous bill but I think
you know this makes sense to allow uh
Charters public charter schools to be
eligible for the aid
sorry I had the wrong paperwork
the fact that they're not eligible for
building Aid is probably the reason why
there's only two to three charter
schools that actually have their own
building so the building Aid may be an
enabler for them
um I would I think you need to look at
this bill and and along with uh House
Bill 452 the previous Bill to take a
look at one is proposing sort of the
20-year
approach and the other one's doing the
80 20 80 percent start 20 so I think you
want to align those if you're feeling to
support both of these bills with
Amendment
um and also I think it was mentioned
about the charitable trust gifts being
deducted from state aid I think that
would not be a that would not work at
all for a charter school I think you
caught that one so I think that's on the
list for an amendment but I think just
what I wanted to say is it's really a
matter of fairness that public school
public charter schools be eligible for
public aid they serve the students that
go there they are public schools and
they should be supported so I recommend
ought to pass on House Bill 354. thank
you thank you are there questions from
the committee
not seeing thank you very much thank you
is there anybody in the committee that's
looking for technical support from the
Department we have from Amy Clark a card
here
if if we need it on this bill
good enough
so with that we don't have any other
cards on this so we'll close the hearing
for uh 354.
and delve into the next one
does anybody have to take a five minute
break
I I hear oh yeah okay we will take a
five minute break
time to get some water
out of water
I saw you falling asleep back there
Barrett
see you still
thank you
okay here we have tonight
foreign
there's some extra 294s in the table
over there
excuse me 394.
one or two would be great thank you
art me want one thank you
a new one
thanks thank you thank you
okay we're gonna go ahead with the bill
in front of us it's 394 relative to the
organizational proper school boards I
welcome representative sellers
foreign
good afternoon thank you for your time
um
I just want to point out I guess I am
the actual sponsor of this bill and as
you can see the there's a I don't know 8
9 10 11 so co-sponsors and a couple
Senators on here that actually is uh
liking this how it is this is adding
um
just trying to basically play nice all
right in a Cooperative district
and again it's it's adding language in
here basically saying
if you have a co-op that they just want
to make sure they're being
um
equal and and basically access so you
have a co-op you might have one town
with three reps of another town with
four reps and so what happens that one
time with four reps technically wins and
they what happens they have all their
meetings in the same town
all right and since they win they always
have the same chair all right every year
after year and uh the person behind me
Eric will be able to explain uh what's
going on in the last I think nine ten
eleven years in his case
but so what happens is they never get a
chance to go from one town to the next
and so all the people that are in one
town always have to travel through the
other town to actually go to their
meetings and also the what happens is
the other Town that's in the co-op never
gets a chance to have a chair because
it's always one town in one case has
four reps and and when one has three and
the one with four always wins so even if
they get you know if they're on the
seven members
they always lose the chair they never
get a chance to have a chair and at that
point
um they never get a chance to actually
rotate the meetings so that's what all
this is all about
thank you are there any questions from
the committee
you off the hook
thank you thank you
like to invite Eric power
foreign
president of sdga New Hampshire
um
this bill is trying to make a
Cooperative School District a little
more Cooperative
um I know that sounds ironic and funny
but you know
it's a net it's human nature that you're
going to if you have a two-town co-op
for example I'll use Hollis Brookline
that currently has used to have five
members from Halls two from Brookline it
got switched over a number of years ago
to four and three four from Hollis three
from Brookline and I served on that
board and each year I attempted to be
the chair
and uh this is back 2014 2015 2016 time
frame and it was always somebody from
Hollis that was picked because the
Hollis people all voted for the Hollis
individual and the proclaimed people
voted for me
and um and it wasn't the same person it
was a different person each time
and if I go back for
um you know since that time since 2013
all those years I think it's 11 or 12
years we've actually had the
chairmanship from a Brookline rep one
one year the rest of the year as it was
it's been Hollis and it continues to be
Hollis for example so
um
the chair actually sets the agenda
controls you know a lot of the meeting I
mean there was there are other members
there but it sets the tone so it makes
sense in a two-time co-op and even in a
multi-town co-op to be able to uh rotate
that chair among the towns the other
thing that would that's nice is you're
also got to consider the public and if
you have a co-op and you're rotating the
location between your two towns three
towns however many have it gives an
opportunity for a shorter commute for
those board members from those towns but
it also enables the public to
participate a little bit easier
um obviously they have students going
from all those towns so it does it makes
sense for the school board to rotate
among the member towns so that's really
the idea here is to you know share the
leadership among the towns in different
years to give the towns the the
opportunity to participate and you know
there's a provision in here that if
somebody in a town doesn't want to do it
they can continue they can do
consecutive years from the same town if
there's no willing board members to
serve as the chair
um same thing with the meeting if it's
not practical for is not a municipal or
school facility it's not required and if
the all board members want to vote to
not rotate the meeting that would be
unanimous vote by the board then they
wouldn't have to do that for that year
so it it provides some level of
cooperation in school districts but it
provides some exceptions as well
with that I'll take any questions thank
you are there any questions from the
committee yes represent Balboni
um again coming from a four Town
District I'm just wondering
um have you we've always rotated have
you asked I mean why is there a problem
with just requesting to move your
location
they don't want to do that they they're
insistent on just having it in the one
town they say that's that's their
convenience and there's four from Hollis
and three from Brookline and when that
vote comes up it's downtown lines so
that's the way it goes
but if this was if this was here then
that would happen it's a good practice
it would be a good thing and maybe some
districts do it but it it I think that's
we're trying to make it so that it
happens in co-ops co-ops are very
difficult to get out of so you're kind
of stuck in them and I know you guys
have talked about co-ops and I've talked
to co-ops with you as well so this is
you know we're getting out of a co-op is
not easy but this at some level of
cooperation I think
for the question represent cascadden did
you have your hand up too yes please
um it was very similar to that but have
there been any attempts like say
whatever town has the least amount of
people have they like gone out to the
public to try to get the public to
kind of get this board this Cooperative
board to look at their policy on this
kind of stuff I mean it's pretty similar
to what she just asked again you could
do you could take it to that level
um but you know even a petition worn
article at an annual meeting is still
would be advisory it's no enabling
legislation for that and
our school board has had a history of
ignoring petition Warren articles that
have passed they just said well okay
we're doing what we want so yeah that's
possible but it's it's is the limit
worth the squeeze I guess for that sort
of thing there's other bigger things we
deal with but just to say that you know
think about a co-op and think about if
you're the smaller town and you never
have leadership that's that's where you
want to put your put your your your feet
in those shoes and think about it that
way
further questions from the committee
yes representative Hall thank you Mr
chair thank you for taking my question
my references the um rotation rotation
of meetings are we talking meeting to
meeting or year to year or month or
so yes I can answer that question so it
says regular announce meeting so that
would be
um typically most school boards meet
monthly some will meet a little more
frequently it's it's left ambiguous but
it's saying it should rotate to some
degree so if you're always having in the
same time you're not going to be
following this law if it was passed so
you agree there is ambiguity and there
is but it's trying to be flexible for
that perspective but it does you can't
just have all your meetings in one town
thank you for a discussion
yes represent Damon
thank you
how many Cooperative school districts
are there in New Hampshire
I thought Mark was fine I think there is
33 yeah three dozen 32. okay I know it's
in the third low 30s yeah how many
districts
uh a lot right I mean
yeah there's a lot of two-town co-ops
there's a number of three-town co-ops I
don't know
that was my next question was the number
of towns in them
so I'm thinking for example of Kearsarge
Five Towns right
seven sorry
five in my Regional School District
growing up
um that's a lot of rotating to
communities that in some cases are
considerably less access than the
central location just an observation
yeah it's that's why the law says when
ex if there's a school or Municipal
facility available it should be rotated
those little towns deserve to have their
board members meet there periodically if
there's that many it might be once or
twice a year
good question for you is it would it be
easier for John Q public though to know
exactly where the meeting was going to
be held uh every two weeks or every
month that it's done rather than having
to try and figure am I in town eight
tonight or I'm Tom b or what
uh Mr chair I don't think that would be
a challenge because usually looking at
an agenda to determine if you're going
and the agenda would state that
um you know there's another bill coming
up talking about the budget committee
but we had a budget committee chair that
rotated because she was in charge and
that wasn't a problem when they had that
they just made it clear which town it
was which which which location they
would be in I didn't see that as a as a
problem any further questions from the
committee yes represent whitcock thank
you uh Mr Paul thank you my question
about how many uh general public
attended meeting
it depends on the subjects that are on a
regular night
I'd say a a dozen or two dozen
depending on what you're talking about
thank you
thank you further questions
not seeing thank you very much thank you
Barrett
thank you again Sherman land for the
committee good afternoon I won't be as
brief as possible
um I I want to thank representative we
are opposed to the bill but I do want to
thank representative Star Wars
especially for his comment this is the
play nice bill and I will agree with uh
Mr power that indeed these are best
practices in rotating the meetings
um uh you know throughout um throughout
the community
um or the various communities in the
various towns um within the Cooperative
school district one of the concerns that
we have
um and Paige uh I get paid one line nine
it says one school or Municipal
facilities are available Municipal
Municipal facilities may be available
that doesn't necessarily mean that
they're conducive to having a meeting
um I happen to meet representative Damon
um uh before she was on the before she
was elected here in at the Goshen school
board meeting the Goshen School Board
meets in the town hall that building is
probably 150 years old if not because if
not older I don't you know there's
really no Wi-fi there's no AV there's no
technology we're sitting on folding
chairs and folding tables so it's a
great old building though and but I love
I love going out to Goshen um no I do I
I one of my former board of directors
John Scranton has been on that school
board forever
um kind of like my grandfather like he
just he's just a great guy
representative Damon knows John screen
just uh he just he did everything he
could to keep that ghost and loves the
school to start together with his own
two hands just a wonderful person
um so I meant I meant no just by that by
any means anyway aside from that um so
the location you know yeah rotating them
you know yeah that's a play nice thing
but we also know and representative
Damon you mentioned cure starch they
have that whole I don't know where they
meet but they have a whole professional
development center there with like
technology and things of that nature I
know representative cordelli um at
Governor Wentworth High School they've
got um like a conference room and they
able to have a media center where
they're able to I think maybe broadcast
live or stream or YouTube some of their
video or some of their meetings so there
may be some of those reasons why you're
holding the meeting a specific location
they've got the technology it's usually
at a school
um and yes other schools may have the
technology as well too it's a best
practice I don't think it necessary
should necessarily be put in law and
relative to the school board chair
person I do appreciate the language that
says unless the person next in line is
is not willing to become the chairperson
because when it was first
conceptualizing this you know we have
some some for example conval 13 school
board members I believe I don't know 12
or 13 towns but you know 13 school board
members if you've never run a meeting
before that could be a challenging task
if you're you got elected on March 15th
and on April 1st you're having to share
a meeting of 13 people might be a little
bit of a challenge with that said though
we think that the school board should be
allowed to elect who they want to elect
as their chair and officers sometimes
it's to help run the meeting you know if
you have three or four new school board
members it might make sense to have the
person with the most experience running
that meeting until you have a vice chair
for a couple years to get up and and get
used to it
um you know and we don't rotate chairs
in this committee every every session
but there's a reason we do that there's
historical knowledge there's historical
background knowing the rules of of the
legislature and this body you want
somebody with experience necessarily to
be in that seat to teach they're going
to be the newbies until until next year
folks I hope I hope that's okay just
teach you the protocols and how to get
around and and listen to customs and
term Traditions that that go on in this
building and local communities and local
school boards and local school districts
also have Customs Traditions fast
practice so on and so forth so for those
reasons um again we wholeheartedly agree
these would be best practices and if
everybody can get along and find a way
to sort of do the rotation or whatnot
you know more power to them but it's not
something that we think should be
mandated in law and I would be happy to
answer any questions thank you very much
are there any questions for our repair
Christina yes represent dry thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question
um coming from a town that was a small
player and a large SAU
um a weighted vote
um helped us to equalize our position on
the school board uh The Joint School
Board and I wondered if you would think
that that might be a solution that we
could put in that would allow the vote
to be taken and elect someone but with a
weighted vote sure thank you thank you
for the question representative
um we're conflating two different issues
here we're conflating the weighted
voting under the school administrative
unit statute the saus that we talked
about
the last bill I was up here that's the
weighted voters in RSA 194c
I forget what it is seven eight maybe I
forget where the weighted voting statute
is this is dealing with Cooperative
school districts which are multiple
towns forming a single political entity
what can I ask what town you're from
representative
yes Plainfield
Plainfield so you are in an SAU 32 you
are not you're a single District
yes this is our past history oh okay all
right who are we can I just ask who you
were hooked up who are you involved like
who you were in the SAU with Grantham
okay you were with Grant them at the
time in Lebanon okay and then I know
Grantham split their SAU 75 now in
Lebanon is now SAU 78. so that would
have been your SAU that would have been
the three communities coming together
for the administrative services that we
talked about before your superintendent
business manager special ed director
this deals with Cooperative school
districts like the Cure Sarge
Cooperative school district for Five
Towns through articles of agreement a
contract essentially agreed to form one
single political entity the co-op School
District so they're there there's apples
and oranges here representing
respectfully if you need more
information by all means like email me
call me I'm happy to sort of go through
the nuances and the differences between
both of those and if I could one second
um representative Damon I believe I
counted real quick
um there are 32 Ops I believe I counted
a hundred 110 pounds I could be wrong on
that though I I was I was trying to
count them two I've got a sheet here my
own document uh I think I was about 110
but give or take five ten on either end
of that
are the questions do you know if there's
any articles of agreement and we know
that
several of our co-ops don't have
articles yeah they were created many
moons ago yeah however do is this
something that might be in some of the
Articles of agreement yeah I think for
the question Mr chair it could it could
be I don't know I'm not familiar with
any articles of agreement myself where
I've seen this provision
um I would also probably recommend that
it not be put in articles if somebody
were to ask me should we met our
articles of agreement to do this I'd say
it should probably be a board policy or
board internal practice because articles
of agreement are tough to change you
have to go out to the voters you have to
you have to vote on them you know this
way a board could just say you know what
we're going to start doing this because
we think it's the right thing or because
we've had constituents ask us to do it I
think it'd be easier it'd be it'd be
more malleable for the board to to do
what I wanted to do through through
board practice or board internal policy
prep sound forward thank you Mr chair
and thank you for taking my question
praise this as carefully as I can but
do are you aware of any circumstances in
which
prior
competition existed between the two
units before they were purged the two
and cooked communities uh that might
have affected this particular business I
I could follow this for the footnote I
sat on the on the Hollis board for a
year okay before we moved out of state
you did this did not surprise me at all
right so thank you for the question
um representative
um
I mean
disagreements Pro I mean so many of the
co-ops have been create will created
decades ago long before my time many of
them we know were first grade you're
right and one right so how's Brooklyn I
think early 90s if I'm not mistaken 91
um so I you know I I know there were a
few I think the Exeter Co-op was created
in 96 if I'm not mistaken that's Exeter
in the four or five surrounding towns
new fields and some of the other ones
um you know those those communities came
together and said that this is a good
idea whether or not that was for
educational purposes whether or not that
was for fiscal prudency or some
combination thereof
uh yeah I don't know but I am aware that
there was a distinct feeling in Hollis
that they were better
I I I can't I can't speak to that
should we ask Mr power his opinion on
that so
um I think any any other questions I
think I'm good uh within uh County
Administration I've been on the county
executive board of Grafton County our
delegation and shared that and we got in
some labor issues
and the chair and vice chair were called
in to address with folks those issues in
case it went a little bit further
um does in regard to this now we're
talking now a a school level
is the chair of the Cooperative board
have different responsibilities than
other members of the board so thank you
thank you for the question chairman Ladd
nhsba advises that the chair of a school
board is the first among equals the only
way per statue no there's no
distinguishment of a board share versus
a quote unquote regular school board
meeting in terms of Statute the school
board by its own vote either policy or
single time instance vote motion Etc can
grant a board chair additional Authority
for example we have a sample policy that
says roles and responsibilities or
duties of the board chair and that's
usually consult the superintendent on
setting the agenda up perhaps
authorization to sign contracts on
behalf of the school board
um I'm trying to think you don't have to
be a spokesperson with the press for the
for this for the school board but as a
matter of law there's no distinguishment
between a chair and any other elected
School Board member the authority and
power of a board chair has to be given
to that chair by the board itself
through policy or directive
thank you represent Damon
one more
is there any precedent for any
cooperatives having co-chairs
it's a good question thank you
um
I'm not aware of any
I mean there's usually a chair and a
vice chair if the chair you know is
absent or for whatever reason the vice
chair fulfills those duties that's again
also a matter of either vocal practice
or board policy but co-chairs I don't
recall ever seeing that if it's happened
I'm not aware
thank you are there further questions
thank you very much thank you all
we have no further cards on this one
that's closed
and we have one left right
so we're going to go right into 632 this
is relative to Cooperative School
District budget committee
um
6 32.
I don't have in front of me right now if
I representative SARS I'm assuming
you're the prime sponsor
thank you
this is what happens when you say yes
yes there you go you got it I gotta
learn a little bit more this is my first
time through so anyways uh
representative sellers grabbed an 18.
um again this is uh 632 hb632 it is the
almost identical if not identical to the
last one we did about the school board
this is about the budget committee all
right so again playing nice yeah as as I
want to use that term is what it's all
about and also rotating where the
meetings are and also rotating the chair
at that point
um
I was just trying to think as far as
you know when you have a when you have a
larger uh several town
within the uh the co-op here or the
district they normally don't change
every single person out the same year
it's always you know one or two people
that are on the boards or committees
will be changed out or voted in or voted
out during that time so you know I look
at this as the you're going to lose all
your knowledge and stuff and maybe they
won't have the right person to take over
the chairperson and again I don't think
that would be the case but also there's
language in here to say they don't have
to you know so if they can decline that
and they can still move forward so I
don't want to really add too much more
it's really the same stuff over it just
it has to do with the budget committee
thank you are there any questions of
Representative
thank you
and
Eric are you testifying this one too I
don't see the card here but must it
already went over that way okay
Eric power from Brookline president of
sdga New Hampshire
um speaking in favor of this bill
this bill is similar to the last one
this one's about Cooperative budget
committees not every Co-op has a budget
committee many do
um the idea is similar to rotate the
chair if there's a willing person in in
the other town or the another town so
that it doesn't say the leadership of
the budget committee doesn't stay in the
same town
perpetually
um just to speak to
Alice Brookline we've had the same chair
from Hollis in charge of it since I
think 2012. so we're 11 or 12 years
where it's been Hollis hands the last
time it was actually in brookline's
hands was my wife Diane power
representative power she was the chair
of the budcom committee I think in 2012.
since then it's been with Hollis but the
budget committee though you're setting
the budget for the the school district
so it's it's a fairly uh powerful
committee and committee you know even
though we've joined together in a co-op
Brookline has its character Hollis has
its character
you know if you look at how much we
spend in our k-6 districts
you see that Hollis spends about five to
six thousand dollars more per student
than Brookline does and then we come to
the co-op uh their number comes down and
our number comes up because the towns
have different priorities different ways
they want to do it so when you have a
budget committee that's continually
controlled by one town
that's probably not healthy it should be
rotated around and just a one other
Nuance to consider with a with a budget
committee
um if you're familiar with the budget
committee a budget committee assigns in
a normal town the budget committee that
exists in a town would assign a school
board member and a select board member
to be ex-officio members so a
five-person budget committee would then
be seven well we don't have really a
select board for a co-op because it's
multiple towns but you do have a school
board member that gets assigned to be on
the budget committee and votes and so in
my I don't even think there was a year
where we have had that school board
member be from Brookline because that's
appointed by the chair again the chair
picks who's on the budget committee and
it's
spend the person from The Big Town
Hollis all the time
so that's that can happen that happens
in others if you see who signed this
co-sponsored this bill you can see it's
a problem in other towns you know that
have caused well nine Borough we have
representative post who signed on this
she's in the smaller town of lineborough
so this happens with the budget
committee this happens with the school
board
and again
when my wife was the chair of the bud
com she did rotate the meetings as a
good practice but that was completely
discontinued when it got taken over and
now it's been in Hollis continuously and
so it can happen but it has to be the
good will of Brewers whoever the chair
is and the committee building being
willing to do it so again for the same
reasons let's make co-ops more
Cooperative by you know rotating the
chair and rotating the meeting places
and that gets people to feel like a
little bit more part of a co-op if we're
able to do that a small step
thank you very much thank you very much
are there any questions
yes representative
I'm sorry thank you thank you sir on
this bill in the last bill
has the full Co-op School Board had a
chance to realize these are both here
because Hollis and Brookline know that
this stuff is here I didn't talk to them
about it necessarily but I've talked to
the sdga organization who's brought this
forward okay but but so you're telling
me to be correctly that uh a fairly 20
years that was more powerful they are
aware of it they are aware of it they
are aware of it they put it in their
minutes that they're aware of it so
they've talked about it okay thank you
they didn't say they liked it and they
didn't say they didn't like it thank you
thank you chair for the questions
nothing thank you very much thank you
and this will conclude the hearing on
this one 6 32.
no
so with that we are done for the day
well tomorrow is uh
no it's not
well we have session
I just thinking on the 13th
thank you
yeah
I know
my weeks have been so messed up here I
thought this 13th and this is tomorrow's
the 14th yeah